TO IF I COULD IF THE SERGEANTS
CAN CALL.
A MR Y. KOWSKI WE WOULD LIKE TO
START.
OUR COMMITTEE AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AS WE WAIT TO HAVE MEMBERS
CONTINUE.
YOU ALL CAN KEEP TALKING IF YOU
LIVE
.
AS I MENTIONED THE COMMITTEE ON
US ON ON UTILITIES AND ENERGY
WILL.
OF PERCY WE ARE WAITING FOR A
QUORUM WE ARE TOO SHY OF A
QUORUM INTHE WE ARE PLEASED TO
HAVE OUR OUR FIRST PRESENTATION
TODAY THIS IS FILE ITEM.
NUMBER THREE SB SEVEN EIGHTY TWO
SKINNER THIS IS ENERGY DATA
TRANSPARENCY BILL.
WELCOME CENTER.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
I'M SB SEVEN EIGHTY TO THE
PORTION THAT'S BEFORE YOU TODAY --
YOU INEFFECTIVE ALREADY VOTED ON
ENDED MY BILL LAST YEAR S. B.
[inaudible]
THREE FIFTY SIX THERE WAS.
WHAT'S CONTAINED IN S. B. SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO PLUS A WHAT WAS
CONSIDERED MORE CONTROVERSIAL --
ISSUES AROUND GRID LEVEL DATA.
AND FOR THE GRID LEVEL DATA
ASPECT WAS THE PART THAT SEEM TO
GIVE FOLKS THE MOST DIFFICULTY
SO I'VE REMOVED THE GRID LEVEL
DATA.
ENTIRELY.
AND THIS IS THE NON
CONTROVERSIAL PORTIONS OF S. F.
THAT BILL.
AND WHAT THIS BILLS FOCUSED ON
ONLY IS DATA RELATED TO
BUILDINGS AND GIVING A LITTLE
MORE ACT MORE.
AT BILL WOULD BE FOR OWNERSHIP
BUILDINGS AND OTHERS TO ACCESS
THE ENERGY USE DATA IN THAT
BUILDING SO THAT THEY CAN THEN
APPROPRIATELY MAKE ASSESSMENTS
AROUND INVESTMENTS IN EFFICIENCY
UPGRADES.
AND OTHER SUCH WORK [inaudible]
SO -- I AM
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE DETAILED IN THE ANALYSIS BEN
I'D LIKE MY PRESENTERS TO
PRESENT AND THAN IN.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR IF
NECESSARY I CAN DESCRIBE THE
THREE ELEMENTS THAT ARE REMAIN
IN THE BILL.
I WILL LET [inaudible]
QUIET.
HI GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I MY NAME IS
MARION PARTISAN I'M WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL.
I'M WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE SPELL AS SENATOR SKYNYRD
SAID IT IS A SENSIBLE --
UPDATE TO WHAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
PASSED BY THIS LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE IT A REALLY A FUNCTIONAL.
A BILL AND ABLE TO GET THE
INFORMATION TO BUILDING OWNERS
THAT THEY NEED TO MAKE
INVESTMENT.
DECISIONS AND ALSO FINANCE
INVESTMENTS.
I'M SO AB EIGHT A THREE TO
PASSED A THREE YEARS AGO IT TOOK
A HUGE STEP FORWARD TO TO GIVE
MULTI FAMILY BUILDING OWNERS
ACCESS TO HOLD BUILDING DATA
AGAIN SO THEY CAN MAKE THE
SENSIBLE INVESTMENT DECISIONS.
THERE'S THREE WAYS AT THIS BILL
IS GOING TO CLEAN UP ON NATO TO
SO THAT ITS REALLY USABLE --
THE FIRST IS THAT THERE IS SOME
LANGUAGE ISSUES AROUND THE USE
OF THE TERM A BUILDING AS
OPPOSED TO PROPERTY.
AND WE USE THE TERM THAT BILL
USES THE TERM BUILDING AND IN
FACT THERE'S A NUMBER OF A MULTI
FAMILY PROPERTIES THAT HAVE
SMALL GARDEN APARTMENTS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
AYE MULTI FAMILY PROPERTIES ARE
ABLE TO BE AGGREGATED AND THOSE
PROPERTIES CAN RECEIVE.
ENERGY EFFICIENCY INVESTMENTS
AND BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACTS OF THE CURRENT ENERGY
USE IN THE CHANGES THAT WOULD BE
MADE TO MAKE THOSE ON UNITS MORE
EFFICIENT.
I'M SECOND AB IT ARE TWO DID NOT
REQUIRE THE CC TO ESTABLISH A
BUILDING IDENTIFIER FOR EACH
BUILDING.
ON THIS IS THE EQUIVALENT OF A
VENN NUMBER I'M FOR VEHICLE SO
THAT THOSE LARGER PROPERTIES
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO PUBLICLY
BENCHMARK THEIR DATA ENERGY USE.
CAN -- MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THE MEET THE ALL
THE DIFFERENT.
IT MAY SEEM LIKE --
SURPRISING THAT THIS ISN'T THAT
DISTANCE MORE COMPLICATED THAN
IT SHOULD BE.
BUT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY SINGLE
BUILDING IN THE STATE WE KNOW
WHERE THEY ARE AND WE KNOW WHICH
BILLS ARE ACTUALLY ABLE TO BE
ASSOCIATED.
WITH THOSE PROPERTIES SO PRETTY --
IMPORTANT FACT --
AND THE THE THIRD PIECE --
BUT THAT'S IT SO DOES BOTH SORT
OF THE MAIN ISSUES ON WITH THE
BILL THAT THE COMPELLED CLEANED
UP [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR JEREMIAH
JUSTIN FANS ALL SITTING IN FOR
ANDREA DEVOTE TECH THAT'S ENERGY
EXPERT BUT HOPEFULLY I CAN
PROVIDE YOU A QUICK EASY
TESTIMONY.
LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR FOR ALL
OF HER WORK ON THIS IN THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK THREAD THE
NEEDLE OUT WE BELIEVE THE BILL
AUTHORS --
MEASURED APPROACH TO PROVIDING
EFFICIENCIES --
TO ON ENERGY DATA THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY ALLOW COMPANIES TO
BENEFIT FROM --
ALL THIS DATA THAT IS GIVING US
TOWARDS OUR ENERGY GOALS AND OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS WE ASK IS
POSSIBLE.
TECH.
THANK YOU WILL NOW WELCOME BACK
ANY ELSE ANYONE ELSE FROM THE
PUBLIC WHO'S HERE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST OF MANY
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS ANIMAL
REPRESENTING THE EFFICIENCY AND
DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON OF FERRERO
WITH THE SCHOOL ENERGY COALITION
IN SUPPORT THINKING.
I WILL TAKE A TESTIMONY FROM TWO
WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE THE MEASURE.
GOOD MORNING.
OR GOOD AFTERNOON.
THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS PATRICK
WHAT FOR THE CALIFORNIA SP
TILDES ASSOCIATION.
AYE WE ARE OPPOSING LESS AMENDED
POSITION.
ON SEVEN EIGHTY TO BELIEVE THERE
ARE HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTATION
CONCERNS WITH AB EIGHT OF TO
WHICH JUST STARTED BEING
IMPLEMENTED THIS YEAR.
AND WE BELIEVE AT THIS POINT
TIME THAT ADDING AN ADDITIONAL
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS ON TOP OF
WHAT'S FORTY GOING ON ADDS
ANOTHER LAYER OF COMPLEXITY.
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT IT
UNDERTAKING THAT OUR MEMBERS
WILL HAVE TO DO AND AND IT'S
JUST ANOTHER LAYER OF COMPLEXITY
ON RT BURDENSOME.
AND FRANKLY NOT A SMOOTH PROCESS
THAT HAS BEEN GOING ON SO FAR
WITH AB EIGHT OF TO BE OF
SIMILAR AMENDMENTS TO THE AUTHOR
AND SOME OF THEM ALSO TO THE
COMMITTEE.
THAT WE THINK RESULTS IN THOSE
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERT.
FLEXIBLE FOR THOSE UTILITIES ARE
REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT AND THE
PROVISIONS OF AB EIGHT HOW TO
AND AND THEN AT SB SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO AS WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WILL TAKE A IF YOU
HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY IT'S A I
AS A NO POSITION ELECT TAKE A
MINUTE OR SO.
PART NOT JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
TECH LADEN STING ON BEHALF OF
* HAVE FOR THE REASONS STATED
BY SENIOR WAY WE'RE ALSO OPPOSE
UNLESS MANY POSITION OUT SHARED
AMENDMENTS WITH THE AUTHOR IN
THE FOUR TO WORKING WITH HER
THANK YOU.
SARAH TO HARRY WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY AGAIN
ECHOING THE COMMENTS I'VE SEEN
YOU AND MISTER WELCH SALAS MUD
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING.
DISCUSSIONS WITH OTHERS OFFICE
AND APPRECIATE OTHER
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO OTHER SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION WE WILL TURN TO
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
COMMENT --
SOON AS WE GET ONE THAT THE
MOTION WILL BE IN ORDER.
A SENATOR WE APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND CONTINUED ONGOING
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA --
EFFICIENCY AND YOU KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD ON THIS
AND SO HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO BE IN
A POSITION.
TO ATTEMPT TO PASS AS AMENDED.
AND SO SOON AS WE HAVE A QUORUM
WILL LOOK FOR A MOTION.
AND I TAKE ACTION ON YOUR BILL.
THANKS SO MUCH APPRECIATED AND
IF YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING.
OF LIKE TO MAKE FROM I THINK WE
WASN'T DESCRIBED IS THAT WERE
ALSO --
ALLOWING FOR WHAT'S CALLED AN E.
SIGNATURE INSTEAD OF A WET
SIGNATURE. TO PROVIDE THIRD
PARTY ACCESS TO DATA WHICH WAS
ARE REQUESTED BY AND VARIOUS THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY AYE FOLKS SO --
THAT'S ANOTHER KEY COMPONENT THE
BILL BUT WITH THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN APPRECIATE THE CLOCKS
WORK IN THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YOU'RE WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SENATOR IF YOU LIKE TO PAUSE FOR
A MINUTE [inaudible]
SENATOR.
IF YOU LIKE TO PAUSE FOR A
MINUTE WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
SO LET'S --
BUT SAID ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
HOLDEN.
HERE.
PATTERSON [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
GALLAGHER EDUARDO GARCIA MAYES
[inaudible]
MURATSUCHI THEIR QUIRK
REYES SANTIAGO.
TING HERE FRIEDMAN.
I SO NOW ENTERTAIN OF THAT
MOTION MS FREEMAN THAT THIS WAS
DUE PASSED US A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS A
ROLL CALL ON THE MOTION.
S. B. SEVENTY EIGHTY TWO TO PASS
A MINUTE APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN
AYE AYE HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I BURKE [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
CHEN NO [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO EGGMAN
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES NO MURATSUCHI AYE REFUGEE
AYE QUIRK [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
OF THE MOTION OF THE ITEMS ON
CALL SO WE WILL.
A WAY TO OTHER MEMBERS COME AND
MISTER WIECKOWSKI A YOU COULD
SENATOR YOU CAN PLEASE JOIN US
I'M GONNA.
TAKE A LITTLE HOUSEKEEPING IF I
COULD I'D LIKE TO GET THINK --
MS FREEMAN FOR JOINING US TODAY
FILLING AND ON THE VACANCY ON
THE COMMITTEE.
AND I'D LIKE TO IDENTIFY OUR
CONSENT ITEMS AND IF WE CAN.
I HAVE A MOTION.
ON THE CONSENT ITEMS FOR ITEM
FOR S. B. NINE OH ONE DOG.
ITEM FIVE SP ONE THOUSAND LARA.
ITEM ELEVEN SP THIRTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT HUESO AS AMENDED.
IS THERE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IT'S BEEN MOODY'S THEIR SECOND.
THE SECOND A ROLL CALL
[inaudible]
ECHO.
HOLDEN BY HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I BURKE [inaudible]
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK
[inaudible]
REYES SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
AVE.
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS ARE ALL
APPROVED WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE MEMBERS TO ADD ON I WILL
NOW TURN TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
SB SIXTY FOUR WIECKOWSKI THIS IS --
YOUR OPPORTUNITY PRESENT ON
FOSSIL FUEL GENERATION UNITS
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SIDE SENATE BILL SIXTY
FOUR ADDRESSES THE PROBLEM
THAT'S ALREADY STARTED TO OCCUR.
AND COULD BECOME WORSE IN THE
FUTURE EVERYDAY FOSSIL FUEL
UNITS ARE BEING CYCLE THE UP TO
A BACKUP RENEWABLE ENERGY IN IN
THE FUTURE THESE UNITS ARE
LIKELY TO BE A CYCLE.
MORE OFTEN AND MORE OFTEN AND
MORE OFTEN WHEN A FOSSIL FUEL UP
PLANTS START AND CYCLE THEY
COMMIT CAN EMIT UP TO THIRTY
EIGHT TIMES AS MUCH POLLUTION AS
WHEN A UNIT.
IS OPERATED UNDER A STEADY.
STATE IF WE DO NOT START TO
ANALYZE THE POTENTIAL HERE
IMPACTS ON OUR CHANGING ELECTRIC
GRID OUR AIR QUALITY IN
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
COULD GET WORSE.
EVEN AS WE MEET OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS AND RENEWABLE REQUIREMENTS
THIS BILL THAT'S BEFORE YOU
TAKES THE FIRST STEP IN STARTING
TO CONSIDER THOSE IMPACTS BY
REQUIRING MORE PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE DATA.
TRACK THE CHANGING PROFILE OF
THE GRID.
AN ANALYSIS OF THE AIR QUALITY
IMPACTS BY LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
OF THE INCREASED CYCLING
EMISSIONS AND FINALLY A STUDY ON
HOW BEST TO TRANSITION OUR GRID
TO GREEN FUTURE THAT GUY
PROTECTS AIR QUALITY.
SO LET'S LOOK AT THE ACCESSIBLE
DATA THE FIRST PART OF THIS BILL
REQUIRES THAT A CALIFORNIA
WEBSITE INCLUDE ACCESSIBLE DATA
THAT SHOWS THE CHANGES AND
STARTS STOPS AND CYCLING OVER
TIME.
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND DATA
RELATED TO HOW POWER PLANTS ARE
OPERATING IS AN ESSENTIAL FIRST
STEP IN A MEANINGFUL A DECISION
MAKING PROCESS.
UP NOW ALTHOUGH THE USEPA HAS
HOURLY EMISSION DATA AVAILABLE
RELATED TO POWER PLANTS.
THIS DATA IS NOT AVAILABLE RIGHT
NOW ON A CALIFORNIA WEBSITE.
AND IT TAKES A REALLY
SOPHISTICATED ANALYSIS I THINK
YOU NEED A SLIDE RULE TRANSLATE
INTO ACCEPTABLE DATA SHOWING
CHANGES OVER TIME.
WE'VE CHANGE THIS FIRST
PROVISION TO REQUIRED OF
FACILITIES TO DIRECTLY SUBMIT
THEIR DATA TO CARVE THE AIR
RESOURCE BOARD RATHER THAN THE
BALANCING AUTHORITIES WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS CHANGE RESPONSE TO
CONCERNS FROM BALANCING
AUTHORITIES.
IN THIS NEW LANGUAGE IS WRITTEN
THE PARALLEL THE U. S. EPA'S
REQUIREMENTS SO THAT EACH OF THE
FACILITIES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CONSENT CARP AND CAN THE
SEND THE U. S. EPA THE QUARTERLY
ADMISSION DATA SETS TOGETHER.
SO THE SECOND PART OF THE BILL
THE ADDRESSES ANALYSIS OF AIR
QUALITY IMPACTS.
AND FIRST I WANT TO NOTE THAT IN
ARM AMENDMENTS WE'VE ADDRESSED
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS BY TAKING
OUT PREVIOUS PROVISIONS RELATING
TO PERMIT LIMITATIONS THAT
IMPACT DISPATCH.
THAT GOT EVERYBODY'S ATTENTION
ALTHOUGH WE BELIEVE THAT
ADDRESSING THIS DISPATCH IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY IS IMPORTANT WE
THINK MORE DATA AND DISCUSSION
THIS NECESSARY DEFERRED TO
DEVELOP THAT CONCEPT.
NOW OUR ANALYSIS OF YOUR CALL
THE IMPACTS IS NOW LIVE IT IS
JUST TWO SECTIONS THE FIRST
SECTION SEE REQUIRES THAT AIR
DISTRICTS TO DETERMINE THE
ACTUAL EMISSIONS OF POWER PLANTS
DUE TO THE CYCLING.
THIS INFORMATION IS AND ISN'T
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TOWARDS
ASSESSING THIS ISSUE IT WILL BE
USEFUL TO US INFORMATION
[inaudible] TO USE.
BUT THEN THIS WILL INFORM THIS
IF THIS FORM FORMER STAR STUDY
OF THE FLEET AND AND HOW WHAT
THE FINAL SECTION OF THE ABOUT
BILL IS GOING TO MOVE FORWARD.
THE OTHER SECTION RELATES TO THE
ANALYSIS IN SECTION VI WHICH
REQUIRES AIR DISTRICTS TO LOOK.
AT THE ACTUAL IMPACT TO LOOK TO
THE ACTUAL IMPACTS AT YOUR
QUALITY --
ON THE CHANGING OF CYCLING IN
THAT IN THE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES THIS CONSIDERATION
IS ESSENTIAL AYE FOR ENSURING
THAT THE IMPACTS OF THIS CHANGE
IN THE CYCLING IS UNDERSTOOD.
THIS BILL DOES NOT THAT EXTEND
THEIR CHANGE CURRENT HERE
DISTRICT PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS
HE SAID IT AGAIN THIS BILL DOES
NOT.
DAD CHANGER ALTER CURRENT AIR
DISTRICT --
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS RATHER
IT REQUIRES THAT THE YEAR
DISTRICTS.
BLESSEDLY EVALUATE THIS
OPERATIONAL CHANGE AS WE ARE
SAYING FARM FORTS IMPACT ON
AMBIENT AIR WITHIN THEIR CURRENT
PERMITTING AUTHORITIES AND
FINALLY THE STUDY.
HOW THE WE TRANSITION OUR FLEET
THE BILL THIS BILL REQUIRES A
STUDY ON HOW TO PRIORITIZE TO
REDUCTION OF THE USAGE AND
EVENTUAL RETIREMENT OF NATURAL
GAS FACILITIES MOST IMPACTING
THE AIR QUALITY OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES?
AND COMMUNITIES BREATHING
UNHEALTHY AIR THIS STUDY IS NOW
IN THE THE STATE'S NEEDED RIGHT
NOW.
GAS PLANTS ARE ALREADY
THREATENING TO RETIRE ACROSS THE
STATE BUT THERE'S NO PLAN ON HOW
THIS SHOULD OCCUR WITHOUT ANY
STEADY WE COULD END UP WITH
INCREASE POLLUTION FROM POWER
PLANTS IN AREAS WITH THE WORST
AIR QUALITY.
THIS STUDY WILL GIVE US THE
INFORMATION TO HELP OUR
INFORMANT ORDERLY AND EQUITABLE
TRANSITION TO THE GREEN.
A GREAT.
NOW.
YOU WILL HEALTHCARE FROM
OPPOSITION.
I SAID DISCUSSED ARE JUST NOW
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
ARGUMENTS BY THE OPPOSITION HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED BY THE REMOVAL OF
A SEPARATE THE SEAS <c.green> IN</c>
SEPARATE SEIZE F..
THE CHANGE IN THE DATA
REQUIREMENTS HAS ADDRESSED
CONCERNS BY THE BALANCING
AUTHORITIES SO THE REMAINING
OPPOSITION CAN BE DIVIDED INTO
TWO ARGUMENTS FIRST THERE'S AN
ARGUMENT OF WHETHER THIS PROBLEM
SHOULD BE ADDRESS.
GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF EMISSIONS OF
POWER PLANTS CONTRARY TO WHAT
THE OPPOSITION STATES WANT POWER
PLANTS EMISSION CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT LOCAL AIR
QUALITY.
ANY SUGGESTION THAT MINIMIZING
POWER PLANT EMISSIONS SHOULD NOT
BE PRIORITIZE IGNORES THE AIR
IMPACTS ON COMMUNITIES ALREADY
BREATHING UNHEALTHY YEAR.
THE THE ENERGY COMMISSION'S
ANALYSIS OF POWER PLANTS SHOWS
THAT EMISSIONS FROM ONE FACILITY
CAN NEARLY DOUBLE THE
CONCENTRATION OF OF POLLUTANTS
AND CONTRIBUTED AREAS EXCEEDING
PROTECTIVE AIR QUALITY STANDARDS.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE THE
ANALYSIS AND THE DATA TO BETTER
ASCERTAIN THE IMPACTS THAT
INCREASED CYCLING --
HAS ON THESE IMPACTED CAN I MEAN
IS AN ARGUMENT FROM A KEPCO AT
THAT SECTION D. IS SOMEHOW
REDUNDANT OF THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DISTRICTS ARE REDOING --
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THAT THIS
ANALYSIS WE HAVE NOT SEEN THAT
ANALYSIS OF THIS SUIT IT THIS
ISSUE DONE IN ANY CONSISTENT WAY
ACROSS HERE DISTRICTS THIS
LANGUAGE IS INTENDED TO ENSURE
THAT A MINIMUM.
AT A MINIMUM THE AIR DISTRICTS
START TO ANALYZE THESE IMPACTS
SO.
WE CAN HAVE THE INFORMATION TO
MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION AND
DECIDE WHAT STEPS TO TAKE NEXT.
WHEN I'M TAKEN THE STEPS WHICH
GETTING THE INFORMATION AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN IVA?
IN WITH ME ARSON EXPERTS.
BUT GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF MY
NAME IS SEAN ALLOWS ZERO THEM
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE A
CO SPONSOR OF S. B..
SIXTY FOUR AND SAID HI AS SOME
OF YOU KNOW HAS A LONG HISTORY
OF WORKING ON ENERGY AND AIR
QUALITY ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
S. B. SIXTYFORCE PROTECTIONS ARE
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY FOR THE
WHOLE STATE AND ESPECIALLY FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE OUR
COMMUNITIES.
ARE BREATHING SOME OF THE MOST
UNHEALTHY THE DIRTIEST AIR IN
THE NATION.
BUT TWENTY EIGHTEEN AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION REPORT FOUND
THAT CALIFORNIA CITIES HAVE.
THE WORST AIR POLLUTION IN THE
COUNTRY.
THIS IMPACTS COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN THE COUNTRY CALIFORNIA CITIES
INCLUDE EIGHT OF THE TOP TEN
WORST CITIES FOR OZONE TAP SEVEN
OF THE TOP TEN WERE CITIES FOR
YEAR ROUND PARTICULATE POLLUTION
AND SEVEN OF THE TOP TEN WERE
CITIES FOR SHORT TERM PARTICLE
POLLUTION.
NO OTHER STATE HAS AS MANY
POLLUTED CITIES RIGHT HERE.
AS WERE BRIEFING TODAY.
THE SACRAMENTO AREA RANKS FIFTH
WORST IN THE NATION FOR OZONE.
AND ONE POWER PLANTS EMISSIONS
CAN MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
I'M I HAVE AN EXAMPLE FOR YOU
THERE ARE MANY EXAMPLES
UNFORTUNATELY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BUT I'M GONNA TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PINOCHET
ENERGY CENTER WHICH IS LOCATED
IN FRESNO COUNTY.
IT'S AN IN NON ATTAINMENT AREA
WITH SOME OF THE WORST AIR
QUALITY IN THE STATE AND IN THE
COUNTRY.
I'M THE AIR DISTRICTS MODELING
OF PANACHE FOUND THAT IT'S
NORMAL OPERATING IMPACTS WOULD
CAUSE LOCAL EMISSIONS. TO
VIOLATE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
PARTICULATE MATTER STANDARDS BY
OVER A 100% AND ANNUAL STANDARDS
BY NEARLY 70%.
THE AIR MODELING ANALYSIS DID
NOT EVEN CONSIDER THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT OF START UPS SHUTDOWNS
AND PARTIAL OPERATION.
AND KEEP IN MIND THAT THE FRESNO
MADERA AREA IS THE THIRD WORST
IN THE NATION FOR SHORT TERM
PARTICLE POLLUTION.
SO INTO THIS AREA AT THE AIR
DISTRICT WAS PERMITTING AT POWER
PLANT AND IT DID NOT MODEL START
UPS OR SHUT DOWNS.
BUT PINOCHET IS NOW UP AND
RUNNING AND IT'S STARTING AND
STOPPING NEARLY EVERYDAY AND
THIS IS NO EXAGGERATION.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN EACH OF ITS
UNITS STARTED MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TIMES.
THE START UP EMISSIONS FROM ANY
GAS FIRED POWER PLANT CAN BE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN STEADY
STATE EMISSIONS.
I'M ONE OF THE PILLOW SHE UNITS
HAD AND IT MAKES US OXIDE OR
KNOCKS RATE OF A HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN POUNDS PER AND THE TO YOU
WHEN IT STARTED.
AND A RATE OF EIGHT POUNDS PER
AND BTU DURING STEADY STATE
OPERATION THIS MEANS THE PLAN
ACTUAL EMISSIONS ARE OVER TEN
TIMES MORE THAN THE STEADY STATE
EMISSIONS.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE AIR DISTRICT
WITH MODELING.
OTHER PLANTS EMIT EVEN MORE
DURING START UP. FOR EXAMPLE THE
COLUSA GENERATING STATION IS
PERMITTED TO EMIT AS MUCH KNOCKS
IN ONE START.
AS IT DOES IN THIRTY EIGHT HOURS
OF STEADY STATE OPERATION.
AS CALIFORNIA INTEGRATES MORE
RENEWABLES PLANTS LIKE PANACHE
WILL BE CYCLED MORE OFTEN.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA LAW DOES
NOT PROVIDE A MECHANISM A
UNIFORM MECHANISM FOR AIR
DISTRICTS TO CONSIDER THESE
CHANGES.
THE DISTRICTS CURRENTLY HAVE A
REQUIREMENT TO ENSURE THAT A
PERMIT DOES NOT PREVENT OR
INTERFERE WITH THE ATTAINMENT OR
MAINTENANCE OF ANY APPLICABLE
AIR QUALITY STANDARD.
I'M AN AIR DISTRICTS CAN'T ISSUE
A PERMIT AND LAST THE PERMIT
APPLIES WITH ALL APPLICABLE
RULES ORDERS REGULATIONS.
I'M BUT THE AIR DISTRICTS SO
WHILE THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE LIMITS ON CYCLING IN
PERMITS.
THEY'RE NOT CURRENTLY SEEKING
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW PLANNED
OPERATION IS CHANGING TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE GRAD.
IN FACT INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
POWER PLANTS ARE OPERATING ON A
DAY TO DAY BASIS.
IS NOT EASILY ACCESSIBLE TO THE
DISTRICTS OR TO THE PUBLIC.
YOU HAVE ABOUT THIRTY SEC
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PERMITTING REQUIREMENT OF
SECTION DE OF SB SIXTY FOUR IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY.
THIS REQUIREMENT IS NOT
REDUNDANT TO WHAT THE AIR
DISTRICTS ARE ALREADY DOING
OTHER SOME DISTRICTS ARE LOOKING
AT IMPACTS FROM CYCLING THIS IS
NOT TRUE ACROSS THE BOARD THE
PINOCHET FACILITY IS A PAINFUL
EXAMPLE.
I AM BY CONTRAST THE SOUTH COAST
IN ITS PERMITTING PROCESS FOR
THE VALLEY FACILITY DID MODEL
DIFFERENT TYPES OF STARTS AND
STOPS AND LOOKED AT THEIR
IMPACTS.
IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH TO HAVE
SOME AIR DISTRICTS MODELING
IMPACT AND OTHERS NEGLECTING TO
DO THAT MODELING ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES DESERVE THAT
ANALYSIS AND SECTION DE IS
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE CONSISTENCY
AND ENSURE THE ANNOUNCES HAPPENS.
WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NECKS WERE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON LOWER WITH LYNN
WITH THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS GOING TO KEEP THIS
REALLY SHORT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT SENATOR WIECKOWSKI IN CHINA
JUST HAD A GREAT JOB INTRODUCING
THE BELL.
ALL TO SAY THAT YOU ALL KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
COMMITTED TO A TRANSITION AWAY
FROM NATURAL GAS TO MEET OUR
ELECTRICITY NEEDS ARE STRONG
CLIMATE POLICIES ARE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD ARE
INEVITABLY.
TAKING US DOWN THE ROAD OF
REDUCING OUR RELIANCE ON GAS TO
THE GREAT BENEFIT OF OUR ECONOMY
AND OUR ENVIRONMENT.
HOWEVER NATURAL GAS CURRENTLY
SUPPLIES ABOUT 40% OF OUR
ELECTRICITY NEEDS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO PLAY AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN THE GREAT FOR SOMETIME
AND I SAY THIS BECAUSE I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE.
THAT THE PURPOSE OF SB SIXTY
FOUR IS NOT TO ENDED
INDISCRIMINATELY SHUT DOWN GAS
RATHER THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO
ENHANCE OUR UNDERSTANDING OF AN
ISSUE WE'RE STARTING TO SEE HAVE
HAPPEN.
AND EXPECT TO GET MORE ACUTE AND
THAT IS THE MORNING THE MORE
FREQUENT INCREASE IN THE CYCLING
OF NATURAL GAS UNITS AND THE
POTENTIALLY NEGATIVE IMPACT THAT
THIS CAN HAVE ON LOCAL AIR
QUALITY.
SO AS WE HEARD BEFORE THE
PROBLEM IS THAT MANY OF THE
STATE'S PLANTS WERE BUILT TO
PROVIDE BASELOAD STEADY STATE
POWER NOT EXPECTED TO BE TURNED
ON AND OFF A LOT AS A RESULT.
THIS MORE FREQUENT CYCLING WAS
NOT ANTICIPATED AND MANY OF THE
ORIGINAL AIR QUALITY PERMITS S.
B. SIX BEFORE WE DO THREE THINGS
IT WOULD IMPROVE THE QUALITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY OF THE DATA MADE
AVAILABLE.
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING TO THE OPERATION OF
THE FLEET AND HOW THAT'S
CHANGING OVER TIME.
WITH THE AMENDMENTS AGREED TO IN
THIS COMMITTEE THE AIR DISTRICTS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO SIMPLY TAKE
THIS INFORMATION INTO ACCOUNT
DURING THEIR PERMIT REVIEWS.
AND FINALLY THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE EASY TO CONDUCT A STUDY
TO MAP OUT WHAT THE INEVITABLE
TRANSITION AWAY FROM NATURAL GAS
LOOKS LIKE. TO MAKE SURE THAT
SUCH A TRANSACTION I TRANSITION
HAPPENS IN A WAY THAT
PRIORITIZES REDUCTIONS ON
GENERATION IN COMMUNITIES MOST
IMPACTED BY FOSSIL FUELS.
SO CALIFORNIANS ARE ALREADY
STARTING TO FEEL THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND COMMUNITIES
IN THE STATE SOME OF THE
UNHEALTHY AS AIR IN THE COUNTRY.
FOR THIS REASON IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE SHIFT TO CLEANER NON
FOSSIL RESOURCES.
BUT THE STATE ALSO NEEDS BETTER
TOOLS TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE
CHANGING OPERATION OF THE GAS
FLEET MAY IMPACT AIR QUALITY.
AN EXPLICIT MECHANISM TO MAKE
DECISIONS IN THE FUTURE IF WE
DECIDE THAT IS A PROBLEM.
S. B. SIXTY FOUR WOULD ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S RAMP UP AND
CLEAN GENERATION DOES NOT LEAD
TO THE INTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
FREQUENTLY CYCLING GAS PLANTS IN
A WAY THAT INCREASES AIR
POLLUTION THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I LOOK AT IT.
POPULOUS IN THE MID UPPER IN
SHAW WITH A PEN WORLD ONLY A
COSPONSORED BILL --
AND I JUST URGE DRIVE VOTE LIKE
CAUSE ACCEPT EVERYTHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE SAID. FOR AS CHAIR
MEMBERS JOHN WHITE WITH THE
CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK.
THEN OF ASK IS WAY WITH ON THE
CALIFORNIA ROOM JUST SCIENCE BUT
I LIKE TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR A
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT ALSO FOR LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THANK YOU AND
SUPPORT.
HELLO THIS IS DOCTOR JEAN NELSON
WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR GREEN
NUCLEAR POWER AND I WANTED TO
SIMPLY.
THIS BILL IS REALLY IMPORTANT I
AND I WANT TO JUST A HIGHLIGHT
ONE DAY'S DATA JUNE FOURTEENTH
THE RAMP RIGHT WAS REQUIRED
ALMOST SEE.
TEAM GIGAWATTS OVER EIGHT HOURS
I MEAN THAT IS JUST AN
INCREDIBLE INCREASE IN POLLUTION
AND THE COURTS TO BEND TECH
STUDY PREDICTED THAT BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN THANK YOU.
A MORENO ON THE HAVE A SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SAYS LINE OF OUR WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR
PROTECTING THE HEALTH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU ARE CROWDED WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THAT'S WHERE A BUDGET WITH A
WHITE MAN GROUP UNHAPPY SPAY
COMMUNITY ENERGY IN SUPPORT.
GEN A PRICE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS.
OKAY WILL NOW ENTERTAIN --
WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE TO TALK
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
DON'T GO FAR [inaudible]
YES.
TAKE PITCHED CLARIFIED DID NOT
ARE THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE
REQUESTED A THEY REFLECTED IN
THE VERSION THAT'S ON OUR TABLET
OR NOT.
I JUST AYE WHAT I WASN'T THE
MAYOR INTO THEIR HOUSES YEAH THE
THE MINUTES ARE REFLECTED IN THE
MAIN ANALYSIS NO BUT IN TERMS OF
THE BILL TECH [inaudible]
NO.
OKAY PLUS CHRIS SO THEN BABY
AFTER THE TEST I COULD YOU JUST
TELL US WHAT AT LEAST WHAT WOULD
YOU RECOMMEND HE DELETED WE WE
WERE HERE WE TOOK.
NOT JUST A BIT BUT I JUST WANT
TO KNOW.
YEAH I I JUST CAN'T TELL OF I
HONESTLY FOR BEGIN THE BILL TAX
EXCUSE ME HER HER ENOUGH.
I WENT AFTER WE TAKE THE
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION THEN
WILL.
TURN BACK TO YOU AND THEN YOU
CAN CLARIFY.
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE THANK YOU
MISTER PLEASE PROCEED OKAY
TECHNICAL MONEY PYTHON NOW FOR
SOMETHING COMPLETELY DIFFERENT --
MIND CHANCE BUT HE JONES FOR THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS --
AND WE ARE --
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL WE ARE
POSTED WITHOUT PRIOR NATURAL
RESOURCES AND I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT IT'S BEEN AMENDED BUT
WE STILL DON'T LIKE THE BILL
WHICH UP PERHAPS WON'T COME AS A
SURPRISE.
WE BELIEVE THAT SB SIXTY FOUR ON
A IN NECESSARILY CREATES A
TENSION BETWEEN A NEW ERA THE
THE RELIABLE OPERATION THE GRID
AS IT EXISTS TODAY --
YOU KNOW POST ENERGY CRISIS YEAH
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB FIFTY
SEVEN OF WHICH RESULTED IN --
OVER THE LAST SIXTEEN YEARS OR
SO ABOUT SIXTEEN THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS OF NEW NATURAL GAS
FACILITIES THAT --
REPLACE OLDER LESS EFFICIENT --
UNITS ARE IN SOME OF THOSE OLDER
UNITS THAT WERE REPLACED BY THE
WAY WE'RE IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES LIKE HUNTERS POINT
PATROL HILL CHULA VISTA WHICH
SEEMS TO GO UNNOTICED BY --
THE PROPONENTS --
THE FACT A MATTER IS GAS
PRODUCES ABOUT 40% OF THE ENERGY
WE NEED FOR RAMPING WHICH IS
VERY IMPORTANT --
IN YOU AND AND OBVIOUSLY --
OPERATES AT NIGHT AND PRODUCES
POWER WHEN THE TRANSMISSION
SYSTEMS ARE AVAILABLE TO THE
FIRES AND ACCORDING TO THE S. B.
THREE FIFTY STUDY --
CONSTITUTES ABOUT 1% TERRY
POLLUTANTS IN THE IN THE IN THE
STATE SO LET'S.
KIND OF GO THROUGH THIS VERY
QUICKLY --
DE DATUL GAS INDUSTRY AVERAGE
REPRESENT MOST OF THE
INDEPENDENTLY OWNED --
BASICALLY ARE HEAVILY REGULATED
ALREADY BY THE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS --
IT TO MEET LOCALIZED --
STANDARDS AND REQUIREMENTS AND
THAT YOU KNOW IT WOULD WITH THE
GAY ISSUE OF KNOCKS THAT IS A
LOCAL ISSUE THAT IS NOT LIMITED
TO A CENSUS TRACK --
THAT IDENTIFIES THE DISADVANTAGE
COMMUNITY --
A BIT IS IT IT IT'S A BROADER
REGIONAL PUT OUT SORT OF ISSUE
AND IS ALREADY REGULATED THEY
OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO MEET EMISSIONS
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS AND
PARTICIPATING CAP AND TRADE --
THE FACT THAT THE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS ARE ALSO OPPOSED TO
BILL UNLESS ADMITTED SHOULD TELL
YOU SOMETHING IT'S NOT OFTEN
THAT THE REGULATORS AND THOSE
THAT ARE BEING REGULATED SORT OF
AGREE ON AN ISSUE --
SO WE WE REALLY HAVE A WE ARE
VERY TROUBLED BY THAT --
BASICALLY I THINK IT SECTION BE
AS WAS INDICATED EARLIER IS
DECIDE TO GIVE INFORMATION IT
SEEMS THAT THE REST OF THE IT IT
SEEMS THAT WHAT THEY'RE SAYING
IS THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA.
BUT THEN WE WANT TO REGULATE.
WE WENT AT THESE OTHER TYPES OF
REGULATIONS BASED ON THE FACT
THAT WE WANT TO APPLY SOME DATA
TO IT SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT --
PUTTING THE CART BEFORE THE
HORSE ON THAT --
DNF SECTIONS ARE STILL THERE
NEAR TROUBLING A AND AGAIN WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS CREATES YET A
NEW AIR QUALITY STANDARD THAT
DOES HAVE AN IMPACT ON HOW
PLANTS GET DISPATCHED.
OKAY IT'S BETTER THAN IT WAS BUT
IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH BODY IAN
HAVE SECTIONS NEED TO COME OUT
COMPLETELY --
AND THEN FINALLY SECTION --
TO IS IS --
AYE I THINK TOTALLY IN A THE
COMMISSION TRYING TO DETERMINE --
YOU KNOW HOW PRIVATE BRA
PROBABLY ALL POWER PLANTS ARE
GOING TO BE RETIRED --
AS ANALYSIS INDICATES A DOES NOT
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT ISSUES LIKE
COST RELIABILITY IN THOSE OTHER
ISSUES SO OTHER THAN THAT IT'S
FINE BUT WHERE TO PUT OPPOSED A.
B. ESPY'S AT SIXTY FOUR ANALYTIC
URGENT ABOUT.
RIGHT AND I AM MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THE AMENDMENTS WILL DO
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE SUGGEST.
YES RIGHT AND WELL YES PRODUCT
THE COVER I DON'T THINK IT PAY
TO THE AMENDMENTS.
OUT WILL COST THE ENTHUSIASM OF
MISTER SCOTT NAY JONES.
YES OPPOSITION WE DO AGREE ON
THAT WILL NOT A CLOSE LOOK ON
YET ANOTHER WE'RE MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION WHETHER.
WE GET IT THERE.
RIGHT RIGHT DATES.
ABOUT ONE'S ATTENTION TO AND
THEY WILL CONTINUE WITH THE
OPPOSITION BUT ON PAGE SIX OF
THE ANALYSIS --
WHERE WE REFERRED?
TO A STRIKE IN THE REPORTING OF
DATA BY THE DALLAS IN AUTHORITY --
WHICH IS PAGE THREE LINES TWENTY
FIVE TO TWENTY SEVEN AND INSTEAD
REQUIRE THE GAS PLANTS REPORT
THAT DATA TOOK PART.
CORRECT AND THEN ON PAGE
[inaudible]
SEVEN OTHER COMMITTEE --
MINUTES SHOW THAT --
STRIKING SUBDIVISIONS E. AND F..
PAGE.
FOUR LINES TWENTY THREE THROUGH.
TWENTY NINE PAGE FIVE LINES ONE
THROUGH [inaudible]
THIRTY SEVEN YES YES.
SO THAT MEANS SECTIONS DNF WOULD
BE DELETED YES CURRENT
[inaudible]
THAT'S CORRECT [inaudible]
IT'S GREAT.
WE THINK WE GOT MOST OF THEM BUT
NOT ALL OF THEM.
TRIP.
HAD BEEN JUST SO MISTY BUT WE
GOT THE N. F. THAT'S WHY THEY
CALL A COMPROMISE.
I JUST IT WOULD EVER BE WORK
CLEAR -- YES
I AM TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS
CLOSER AS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
BURGER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS AFTER YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALAN HAVE
SOME OF THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION I
REPRESENT THE F. THIRTY FIVE AIR
POLLUTION.
CONTROL OFFICERS.
IN CALIFORNIA --
WE VOTE WE'VE SUBMIT AMENDED --
AND PROVIDED AMENDMENTS TO THE
AUTHOR --
WERE WERE OUT WE'RE HAPPY SEE
THAT MOST OF THOSE AMENDMENTS
HAVE HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED --
REGRETTABLY --
I THINK WE STILL HAVE A ISSUE
WITH THE WITH THE SECTION DE
WHICH IS STILL BEEN LEFT IN --
OVERALL A CAT CHO BELIEVES
THERE'S A VALUE IN THE STUDY
APPROACH OUR OUR AMENDMENTS A
PROPOSED A WAY TO OF GET AIR
DISTRICTS INVOLVED WITH THAT
STUDY APPROACH TO PROVIDE THE
DATA NECESSARY TO THE BALANCING
AUTHORITY TO THE C. E. SEAT
ISSUE PIECE.
SEE TO OUR TO MAKE IT AN
INFORMED DECISION ABOUT THE ROLE
OF CYCLING POWER PLANTS ARE IN
THE FUTURE.
AND IT BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
SECTION D. --
DESPITE --
THE SENATOR'S STATEMENTS WE
BELIEVE IT IS DUPLICATIVE OF
WHAT THEY'RE DISTRICTS CURRENTLY
DO IT'S ACTUALLY --
RECORD IT REQUIRES A MORE THAN
WHAT AIR DISTRICTS CURRENTLY DO
BECAUSE IT IT REOPENS A PERMIT
AND AND THEN --
HAS THEIR DISTRICTS MAKE A THAT
DETERMINATION ABOUT THE ROLE OF
DISPATCH FOR EVEN MINOR
AMENDMENTS SUCH IS A CHANGING OF
MAILING ADDRESS CHANGING THE
FIRE PUMP SOMETHING OUT
SOMETHING REALLY MINOR LIKE THAT
TO AND IF A IF THE COMMITTEE --
CO FROM THE SAN JOAQUIN AIR
DISTRICT HERE TO TALK ABOUT OF
PERMITTING AND US SPECIFICALLY
SOME OF THE OTHER FACILITIES IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN.
A GREAT WAVE WE HAVE HAD TO A
WITNESSES WHICH I THINK IS
APPROPRIATE WILL TAKE.
WHAT WE DO THIS IF THEY'RE
QUESTIONS AMONGST THE OF THE
COMMITTEE?
CERTAIN TAKE YOUR YOUR COMMENTS
AS WE OR WOULD IT BE YOUR
COMMENT MISTER SHARON PATRICK
RAFTER THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES SITUATION BY CAN JUST
ADD.
A COUPLE THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT UP BY THE OPPOSITE YOURS
BUT I WANTED TO DO THOUGH I WANT
TO TAKE.
THE TWO WITNESSES IF IT'S VERY
QUICK NO PROBLEM.
BUT WHY DO WE HOLD IF YOU WANT
TO GO INTO A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL IT'S IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
THAT WOULD BE PERTINENT.
TO YOU'RE BEING ABLE --
TO ADD TO THAT THE COMMENTARY SO
WHY DON'T WE TAKE OTHERS FROM
THE AUDIENCE WHO WERE HERE.
JUST NAME.
AFFILIATION SOURCE SENATOR OUTTA
NOW I THINK THERE'S OTHERS WHO
OPPOSE THE BILL.
THEIR IT [inaudible]
NOBODY.
PATTY DUNLAP ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURE AGRICULTURAL ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
AMENDMENTS BUT WE'RE WE REMAIN
OPPOSED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARKER TO SOME
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE REMAIN OPPOSED AS
WELL THANK YOU.
DO ANY HUNTER FOR* OPPOSE.
MICHAEL SHOT CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURED TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO POSED.
ANTHONY SAMPSON HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC POWER AUTHORITY IN
OPPOSITION.
CASSANDRA OFF WITH CALPINE STILL
IN OPPOSITION EVEN WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
P. MONTGOMERY FOR ENERGY ENERGY
IN OPPOSITION.
MARGOT PARKS IN THE HAVE THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION UP IN OPPOSITION
SPECIFICALLY CONCERNED ABOUT A
IMPACTS ON COGENERATION UNITS
THINKING.
REX W. HAMA BE HAVE CALIFORNIA'S
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION ALSO POST.
ISRAEL SALAS WITH SAN DIEGO GAS
AND ELECTRIC ALSO POST.
SARAH TARRY WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY IN
OPPOSITION.
TOM EDISON OF THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AYE
HERE IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS EXPRESSED BY MY
COLLEAGUE WE THINK THAT SECTION
D. IN FACT.
MAKES OUR AIR POLLUTION PROBLEMS
WORSE IT CREATES BARRIERS IT
DOES NOT HELP US REDUCE
EMISSIONS IT CREATES A WORSE AN
IMPROV SET OF PROBLEMS.
WE TOOK.
HER WAIT DID YOU MEAN EAR DE.
DE IS OUT D. LIKE DOG OKAY THANK
YOU.
I GAVE ONE WITH THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT THAT MEDIA POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICER.
AND AT THE TEARS PLEASURE I AM
ABLE TO ANSWER SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY PERMITTING PROCESSES.
BOMB WERE ALSO IN A OPPOSITION --
CONVOCATIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OF FOR THE RECORD SENATOR I
WOULD HAVE SAID DO YOU LIKE
DELIGHTFUL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I WILL --
WILL TURN TO THE IT'S MURATSUCHI
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
FIRST OF ALL SAY THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR A BUT ADDRESSING
LISTEN VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE WHY
I SUPPORTED DEATH.
YOUR BILL OUT OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE OH HOWEVER I
TO HAVE --
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED BY THE CAPITAL OF
REPRESENTATIVES --
SPECIFICALLY AS TO SUBDIVISION
DE -- AS
MUST MONEY JONES INDICATED AYE I
AM CONCERNED WHEN THE AIR
QUALITY REGULATORS ARE SAYING
THAT IT'S GOING TO MAKE AIR
QUALITY WORSE --
AND IT WAS ALSO IN ARGUMENT WAS
ALSO MADE TO ME THAT --
AS INDICATING THE CAP BECAUSE
LETTER OF JUNE TWENTY FIFTH --
THAT -- THEY
ARE.
ASSERTING THAT.
SUBDIVISION DE IS IN DIRECT
CONFLICT WITH THE FEDERAL CLEAN
AIR ACT --
AND SO IT COULD YOU ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS [inaudible]
AT IF THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
AYE CHAIR HAD. FOR MY SPONSORS.
GET RIGHT BECAUSE AYE WE'VE HAD
MANY CHANGES AND BACK AND FORTH
I WANTED GIVE THAT COMMITTEE
EXACTLY WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
BY ALL MEANS AM THANK YOU SO I'M
SORRY WITH THE QUESTION WHETHER
SUBDIVISION DE THE OF THEM
WITHIN VIOLATE ON OF THE HIGH
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT.
AND THIS IS AN ALLEGATION THAT'S
BEEN RAISED BY --
BY THE V. SO POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS TO SO I HAVE SEEN THE
THE OPPOSE UNLESS AMEND.
LETTER FROM CAPT HOA ALLEGING
THAT SUBDIVISIONS IAN ATTHE.
WERE IN VIOLATION OF SECTION I'M
ONE OF THAT CLEAN AIR ACT THERE
IS.
NO SUPPORT IN FEDERAL LAW OR IN
STATE LAW FOR THAT POSITION
WE'VE DONE AT LEGAL ANALYSIS AND
THE THE CLEAN AIR ACT PLAIN
LANGUAGE DOES NOT SUPPORT IT IN
FACT THE CLEAN AIR ACT IS
STRUCTURED.
SO THAT EACH STATE.
IS ABLE TO PROVIDE MORE
PROTECTIVE [inaudible]
I'M.
REGULATION THAT VAN THE FEDERAL
CLEAN AIR ACT.
THE FEDERAL COURTS HAVE NEVER
INTERPRETED THE CLEAN AIR ACT
[inaudible] TO SUGGEST SUPPORT
FOR THAT INTERPRETATION.
AND WE'VE REMOVED SUBDIVISIONS
<c.green> ENOUGH FROM THE BILL.</c>
I'M AYE IT YOU HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE BAY AREA
AND KEPT COHERER.
WHO COULD IF THEY FELT THAT
SECTION?
D. WERE IN ANY WAY IN VIOLATION.
GOT WITH PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR.
YEAH HAPPY TO TRADING ANSWER
THAT QUESTION.
THERE IS ONE THING THAT WE AGREE
WITH THE SPONSORS ON IT FACT
SEVERAL ONE POWER PLANTS ARE
DIRTY NEED THEIR THEIR MISSIONS
NEED TO COME DOWN. TO THE
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT PROBLEM
WITH SECTION ONE TWENTY THREE IS
PROTECTIONS THE ENOUGH THAT HAVE
COME OUT OF THE BILL WHAT WE
DISAGREE ON INDISCREET QUITE
SUBSTANTIALLY.
IS THE NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES OF
AN THE WHICH IS BEING LEFT IN
THIS BILL ON AIR QUALITY THAT'S
WHERE THE DISAGREEMENT AIRS.
BUT WE ARE DELIGHTED THAT
SECTIONS <c.green> ENOUGH CAME OUT</c>
BECAUSE THAT WOULD HAVE CREATED
FROM OUR OUR STRONG LEGAL
PERSPECTIVE.
A FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT PROBLEM
THAT'S NO LONGER A PROBLEM AND
THANKS TO THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
THAT AMENDMENT [inaudible]
SO MISTER CHAIR I BELIEVE THE
FEDERAL CONCERNS WITH REGARD TO
THE MISTER OUR SUMMERS MARRIAGE
YOU MURATSUCHI IS QUESTION
HAPPEN TAKE CARE CAN.
HAVE BEEN TAKEN CARE OKAY SO
WE'RE JUST DEALING WITH THE
LOCAL CONCERN IN MY ENTHUSIASM
TO HAVE.
UPDATE REPORTING AND YOU KNOW
ASSISTING THE LOCAL THAT.
BOTH THE STATE AND ASSISTING US
IN UNDERSTANDING WHAT HOW THE
AIR QUALITY CHANGES IN IN THERE
AND THAT PERMITTING THAT WE'RE
DOING ON THESE.
PLANTS THAT WERE PERMITTED AS
CONTINUOUS CYCLE.
ARE CONTINUOUS USE AND OUR
CYCLING UPCYCLING DOWN AND WHAT
IT WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
[inaudible]
NHL. TO FIND POSTS ABOUT IT IF I
MAY UP THE FOLLOW UP THAT I I
WOULD LIKE FURTHER CLARIFICATION
AS TO WHAT EXACTLY YOUR CONCERNS
ARE WITH.
SUBDIVISION DE IT ABSOLUTELY AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO ARTICULATE OUR
SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH SUB THAT
SUB IT WITH PARAGRAPH DE.
AYE TO THE COMMITTEE.
THERE MULTIPLE FIRST OF ALL --
WE HAVE BEEN LAW TODAY A WIDE
VARIETY OF LEGAL REQUIREMENTS ON
HOW WE PERMIT POWER PLANTS FOR
EXAMPLE I WE'RE REQUIRED --
TO AS WE ARE FOR ALL PERMITS TO
DO WELL A WATERS ACT ANALYSIS
SAID I HEAR TOXIC HOTSPOTS
ANALYSIS TO LOOK AT THE IMPACT
OF THOSE FACILITIES ON ADJACENT
COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT'S A GOOD THING A MS
WATERS WHEN SHE WAS IN THIS
BUILDING AUTHORED A WONDERFUL
LAWYER TOXIC HOTSPOTS PROGRAM
THE PROBLEM WITH. ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS WITH THE IS THAT IN DE
R. PARAGRAPH.
I SEE WHERE REQUIRED NOW DO
SOMETHING THAT'S QUITE SIMILAR
BUT DIFFERENT AND IN FACT A AND
B. AND C. ARE ALL SIMILAR IN
THAT RESPECT IN THAT THEY PUT IN
PLACE A NEW REQUIREMENT THAT'S
VERY SIMILAR.
SEE IS VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
DO UNDER THE WATERS ACT BUT IT'S
DIFFERENT AND UNFORTUNATELY IT'S
WEAKER.
AND SO THE PROBLEM THAT WE SEE
IT'S COMPLETELY AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF THAT BUT THE
PROBLEM IS THAT.
WE'VE GOT OUR EXISTING WATERS
ACT PROCESS TO LOOK AT SPECIFIC
WE THIS ISSUE NOW WE'VE GOT A
NEW REQUIREMENT.
SO NOW LET'S SAY THAT A POWER
PLANT COMES THEN WHAT ARE THEY
GOING TO DO.
SUES ME.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET TOO FAR
THAT I MEAN I THINK ONCE YOU'VE
MADE YOUR POINT AND I THINK.
WE ALL GET YOUR POINT --
I THINK THIS IS A A MATTER OF
INTERPRETATION ON THIS SECTION
SO.
YOU HAVE YOUR POSITION ON IT
MISTER --
TING.
I'M SORRY DOCTOR EGGMAN.
I THINK YOU CAN THANK YOUR
SARKOZY SECULAR SCENE THE
SPELLING THANK YOU I THINK.
I THINK WE'RE MOVING IN OUR
DIRECTION --
I GUESS MY QUESTION HAS TO DO
ALSO WERE ALL TALKING ABOUT.
A SECTION D. AS IN DELTA
[inaudible]
BOTTOM.
A MILITARY VETERAN --
SO.
AND AND I SAID THIS IN THE LAST
COMMITTEE SO WE I MEAN.
WE INVESTED IN A LOT OF THESE
PLANTS AND THERE ARE ALL AND A
LOT OF I HAVE TO IN MY DISTRICT
RIGHT NOW --
AND WHILE DIDN'T KNOW BUT NOBODY
LIKES DIRTY AIR WE ALSO KNOW
THAT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS HAVE
GONE INTO THAT AND AND WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT RIPLE EFFECTS OF
THAT AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE
THIS CHAIR IS MOVING TOWARDS IS
LOOKING AT WHEN WE TAKE OUT A
PLANT WATER.
THE RIPPLE EFFECTS OF THAT WE'RE
MEASURING THESE THINGS AND WOULD
YOU ALSO BE OPEN TO LOOK AT
WHERE THE RIPPLE EFFECTS LIKE ON
COMMUNITIES OF CLOSING THESE
DOWN ALSO AS OPPOSED.
TO A GREATER --
THAT THE JOB FACTORS THAT GO
ALONG WITH THAT AND INVESTMENT
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE AND
PERHAPS NOT REALIZED.
THAT INVESTMENT YET WAS WHEN MY
QUESTIONS AND THEM [inaudible]
DE.
IF WE ARE NOW JUST EVALUATING
HOW WILL THAT BE USED IN WILL
THAT BE USED IN THE IN THE
CONSIDERATION OF OF A PERMIT
RENEWALS.
IT'S JUST IT'S NOT FOR A VALUE.
RIGHT IT'S NOT DIG IT IT DOESN'T
TAKE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
JUST SAYS YOU CAN EVALUATE IT.
I MEAN I THINK HOPEFULLY AT THE
AT ONE LEVEL IT'S GIVEN TO US TO
DECISION MAKERS YOU KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO GET WE'RE GONNA GET
INFORMATION ON A YEARLY BASIS ON
EMISSIONS AND THERE.
AB SIX SEVENTEEN RIGHTS WE'RE
GONNA GET THE YEARLY NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GET THIS MORE PRECISE
AYE.
INFORMATION ON POLLUTION BASED
ON THE THAT THE OPERATION OF THE
GREAT AND THIS CYCLING AND
INFORMATION WHAT WE CHOOSE TO DO
WITH THAT.
IS FOR ANOTHER DAY I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT I MEAN IT'S NOT
THAT.
MAYBE I HAVE FIVE SPEAK OUT.
I THINK THAT YOU GET YOUR PERMIT
YOU'RE RUNNING YOUR YOUR REP
OPERATING AS A PARENT WE JUST
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE CONSEQUENCES
ARE AT WHAT THIS WHAT THIS THAT
IS WE NEVER THOUGHT THAT.
WE THOUGHT THAT IF YOU'RE
RUNNING IT ALL THE TIME IT WOULD
BE AT THIS LEVEL POLLUTION THAT
WERE SAYING THE WAY IT'S BEING
OPERATED IT'S AT THAT LEVEL OF
POLLUTION IT'S UP TO US I'M FIX
YOUR CALL THE BOARD THE GOOD
REPORTED.
BUT IT'S UP TO US TO DETERMINE
WHAT THE PUBLIC POLICY SHOULD BE.
THOUGH I LET ME JUST DIDN'T SAY
THAT I THINK IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION AND AND SECTION DE WE
BELIEVE IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT.
IT MAKE SURE THAT THIS NEW
ACCESSIBLE INFORMATION THAT
WE'RE CREATING [inaudible]
IS.
EVALUATED IT DOESN'T JUST SIT
THERE IT'S PART OF THE PROCESS
THAT THE AIR DISTRICTS.
IT'S PART OF THE INFORMATION
THAT THE AIR DISTRICTS TAKEN
WHEN THEY EVALUATE.
THE PLANT IN A PERMITTING
PROCESS THE BILL EXPLICITLY DOES
NOT SPECIFY WHAT TO DO WITH THAT
INFORMATION OR WHETHER TO DO
ANYTHING WITH THAT INFORMATION.
IT JUST REQUIRES THAT THAT
INFORMATION BE PART OF THE
EVALUATION PROCESS.
I DON'T THINK YOU SO I GUESS MY
PART PARTLY MY CONFUSION IS
GENERALLY.
ON MR ALLISON'S VERY MUCH
ALIGNED WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT
SPONSORS OF THE GROUP THE
SPECIAL AIR QUALITY ISSUES SO.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDS HOW COME?
HOW COME THERE'S MISALIGNMENT
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE GOALS OF
MISTER HARRIS'S AGENCIES ARE
EXACTLY THE GOALS AS ESPOUSED IN
THE BILL?
I IS IT REALLY AN IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUE IS HERE.
ON NO IT'S IT'S IT'S SOMETHING
REGARDING.
THE MANAGEMENT OF THE STATE AND
THEN JUST TRY TO GET OF
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY THERE IS
THIS --
DISCONNECT WHEN THERE SEEMS TO
BE ALIGNED WITH THE OVERALL
GOALS OF THIS ISSUE.
MATTHEW MISTER ALLISON BUT
THAT'S OKAY MISTER CHAIR.
AND THEN THE SPONSORS TO OF
THEIR WORK AND THAT'S FINE.
WAS REYES WHO WANTED TO REPLY
AND THEN THE SITE IF YOU.
I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION WE
VERY MUCH DO WHAT TO CUT
EMISSIONS FROM POWER PLANTS.
AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT AS WE GET MORE
RENEWABLES THE EFFECTIVE CYCLING.
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE HAVE NO
PROBLEM THAT ARE SUPPORTIVE.
OF BE AND SEE THE PARTS THAT.
ARE AS WELL AS SECTION WHO THE
PARTS THAT YOU GET AT THAT ISSUE.
THE REASON THAT WE HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE D. IS THAT WE BELIEVE
THAT DATA IS GOING TO HAMPER OUR
ABILITY TO DO THE REGULATORY
PERMITTING WORK ON THESE
FACILITIES.
THAT WE NEED TOO TILL IT SETS UP
UP PARALLEL BUT DIFFERENT
PROCESS. FOR MORE THE POLL.
THINGS THAT ARE ALREADY REQUIRED
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE --
THERE ARE A VARIETY IS.
OF ISSUES WITH SOME FOR EXAMPLE.
WE WE BELIEVE THAT IT WILL BE
WERE GIVEN AN IMPOSSIBLE TASK IN
A THE JUDGE THE EFFECTIVE
DISPATCH.
ON THE STATE'S GOAL.
TO MINIMIZE THE MISSING FROM
THESE FACILITIES WHICH IS NEVER
DEFINED HER SAID ANYWHERE.
IN LAW CURRENTLY ARE IN THIS
BILL.
SO IT SETTING US UP TO FAIL AND
IT'S SETTING UP TO POWER LOW
PROPHECIES. FOUR THINGS THAT
ALREADY EXIST WHICH CORPORATE IF
THE PROBLEM.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
YES AND THANK YOU FOR I MIGHT
THIS IS A MISTER TING AN
EXCELLENT.
QUESTION WHY A WE ARE NOT IN ON
EXACTLY THE SAME PAGE AND SO THE
AYE AIR TOXICS.
RULE WHICH ON COMMUNITIES FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT WAS EXTREMELY
SUPPORTIVE OF ADDRESSES
DIFFERENT [inaudible]
POLLUTANTS THEN THE CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS THAT WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT FROM GAS FIRED
POWER PLANTS.
AND AND SO IT MAY BE SOMEWHAT IN
PARALLEL BUT IT'S DEFINITELY NOT
GOING TO ACCOMPLISH THE SAME
THING AND WE ARE NOT SEEING
THESE.
OBJECTIVES BEING ACCOMPLISHED
STATEWIDE AS I SAID IN MY
OPENING REMARKS SOME AIR
DISTRICTS ARE IN FACT LOOKING AT
CYCLING IMPACTS SOME ARE
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
AND SO --
YOU KNOW TO PURSUE YOU YOU KNOW
THE GOAL OF BREATHABLE AIR FOR
ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES
IS WHAT SB SIXTY FOUR BRINGS US.
AND THE NOT NO EXISTING --
LAWS OR RULES SEEM TO BE DOING
THAT AT THE MOMENT [inaudible]
TIA FOLLOW.
YEAH SO I I GUESS I'M I'M STILL --
HAS ALSO MATHIS QUESTIONS OF A
DIFFERENT --
I MEAN GENERALLY MY AIR QUALITY
DISTRICT WHICH IS BESET MISTRUST
REPRESENTS WERE SEEN AS THE MOST
AGGRESSIVE.
THE MOST PROGRESSIVE PALM
USUALLY WERE NOT SEEN AS THE
ONES WHO NEED TO BE DRAGGED
ALONG USUALLY WERE KIND OF
LEADING THE PACK.
SO HELP ME UNDER IS IS IT.
GEE IS IT YOUR FEELING THAT.
ARE YOU WANT TO MOVE IN THIS
AREA AND THE AIR QUALITY
DISTRICTS IN GENERAL OR EVEN
SPECIFICALLY THE BAY AREA ONCE.
ARE NOT INTERESTED IN MOVING
THIS DIRECTION WAS THERE SORT OF
BUREAUCRATIC RESISTANCE I'M JUST.
WE'LL TRY TO UNDERSTAND THE
SITUATION JUST WERE CLEAR THE
SOUTH COAST IS OKAY WITH THIS
LANGUAGE THERE THE LONGEST AT
LEAST THAT'S WHAT THE
INFORMATION THAT I'VE GOT THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE.
AN OBJECTION TO THIS SO WITHIN
THE YEAR THE REGIONAL DISTRICTS.
YOU KNOW I I CAN'T SPEAK FOR ALL
THIRTY EIGHT OF THEM I'VE GOT.
TWO OF THEM THEY'RE HERE.
BUT BILL FISCAL SENATOR WHAT WHY
IS OUR AIR QUALITY.
DISTRICT OPPOSED TO YOUR BILL.
USUALLY I GUESS THEIR THEIR JOY
SEEN AS THE MOST AGGRESSIVE.
ON GOING AFTER POLLUTANTS.
NOW IF AT MEAN.
IT'S A CONCERN TO ME TOO BUT I
YOU KNOW I'M TRYING TO CREATE
AND TRYING TO CREATE A SITUATION
WHERE WE GET THE BEST
INFORMATION.
ON HOW THE CITY'S THESE PLANTS
ARE OPERATING IN TODAY'S WORLD
BUT RECENT WITH CYCLING AND IF
IT [inaudible]
CREATES.
HEARTBURN BECAUSE WE HAVE NEW
CRITERIA THAT WERE ASKING THAT'S
MEANINGFUL TO US THAT I WANT TO
HAVE.
PUT IN THE FORM THAT'S OF
AVAILABLE TO THE PEOPLE CAN USE
AND ALSO WE GET A STEADY BEN.
I GUESS WE HAVE HARPER AND I'M
YOU KNOW.
I I KEEP I'VE READ THIS FOURTEEN
TIMES I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT EXACTLY IS THE LANGUAGE
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE THAT.
TRIPS EVERYBODY UP --
THAT REALLY IS WHERE YOUR CHOIR
SUMMERS.
AND MORE RESPONSIBILITY AND IF
IT DOES IF IT DOES THAT'S
PROBABLY A GOOD THING IT'S
PROBABLY A GOOD THING TO SAY HOW
WE OPERATE IN THE NEW WORLD THAT
WE LIVE IN THAT WERE.
RECYCLING ALL THE TIME WHAT IS
THE GOOD AND THEY AND LET THAT
LOOK THAT.
PLANTS FALL INTO THE BIG
CATEGORIES THAT THEY ARE.
BUT IT DOESN'T REQUIRE COMMUNITY
IT'S UP TO US TO STE PART TWO
COMES LATER WHEN WE LOOK AT ALL
THIS THIS DATA AND WE SAY WELL
MY GOD WE SHOULD CHANGE THE
RULES OR IRREGULAR --
THE REGULATIONS BUT I'M NOT
DOING THAT HERE RIGHT BECAUSE I
HAVE ENOUGH PROBLEMS.
MISTER TING YOUR YOU GOT YOUR
ANSWER IS GOOD AS AN ANSWER TO
GET BECAUSE I NEED TO TALK
GALLON I I GUESS I'M STILL.
CONFUSED AS TO WHAT THE ISSUE IS.
GROW ANYWAYS OKAY UP WHEN TO
GIVE DOCTOR QUIRK A GOOD CHANCE
TO ASK QUESTIONS BUT I'M
CERTAINLY.
I'M SURE YOU'VE YOU TELL ME WHO
YOU ARE AND WHAT IS.
THIS MONTH WITH THE SOUTH COAST
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
AYE I'VE ENJOYED THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION FROM THE BACK OF
THE ROOM.
AND I WELCOME TO THE FROM THANK
YOU SORRY SORRY TO BE LATE TO
THE PARTY.
I I WANTED --
TO JUST EXPRESSED FIRST OF ALL
THE SOUTH COAST --
BOARD IS NOT AUTHORIZED A
POSITION ON THE BILL WE ARE
WATCHING WE HAVE HAD
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR IN
WITH THE SPONSOR --
THAT SAID WITH SUBDIVISION DE WE
DO HAVE SOME TECHNICAL CONCERNS
AND WE'VE WE'VE LOVE THE CHANCE
TO CONTINUE BECAUSE AND THE
LANGUAGE CAN BE FIXED WE DON'T
HAVE AN IDEOLOGICAL OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL OR WHAT THE SPONSORS
ARE TRYING TO ACHIEVE THE
AUTHORS.
IS TRYING TO IT'S A PUT THE BELT
BUT EVERY TO CONTINUE TALKING
WOULD BE GREAT AT THE GROUND AND
COME TO SOME AGREEMENT WITH THAT
THAT'S HELPFUL --
SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATIONS SIX ARE GOING
AROUND THROUGHOUT DE SO LET'S
ISN'T DYNAMIC --
BUT ONLY NOT ARE.
ALRIGHT THAT WOULD BE THE LAST --
ONE DOCTOR QUIRK SO DOC I THINK
FIRST OF ALL IT'S GOTTEN A MAN
SO IT HASN'T BEEN OUT VERY LONG
AND THEN.
USUALLY THESE THINGS CAN BE
RESOLVED SO I ASK YOU SENATOR
WILL YOU WORK WITH THE AIR
QUALITY DISTRICTS. TO GET
SOMETHING THAT THEY FEEL THEY
CAN WORK WITH IF SO I CAN VOTE A
AYE ABSOLUTELY ALRIGHT THEN I
CAN VOTE I THANK YOU.
IT -- HAS
BEEN MOVED.
HOW MOVE IT?
AS OUR SECOND [inaudible]
ANY OTHER QUESTION SIR OR
COMMENTS ON THIS PARTICULAR.
ITEM.
JUST BRIEFLY I I WOULD
APPRECIATE --
TO MISTER QUIRK SICK A COMMENT
IN AND FOR THE PURPOSES OF
MOVING THIS TO RESOLVE THIS --
DISPUTES --
I WILL VOTE AND SUPPORT TODAY
BUT I RESERVE THE RIGHT.
TO VOTE AGAINST IT ON THE FLOOR
THANK YOU.
BUT EVEN IF I COULD SAY I JUST
EL ARE ALIGNED MY MY COMMENTS
AGAIN I THINK WE ALL WE ALL WANT
CLEAN AIR WE ALL KNOW I GUESS AT
SOME POINT YOU TO GO AWAY BUT WE
KNOW.
WE DON'T LIKE CREED AND ENERGY
CRISIS AS WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
AND WE'RE DOING A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS IN ISOLATION
AND I'VE BEEN ONE WHO KEEP
SAYING WE NEED A BIGGER HOLISTIC
PLAN TO REALLY SEE.
HOW WE'RE GOING FORWARD --
BUT IF THE AIR QUALITY FOLKS ARE
SAYING THEY CAN'T DO IT AND I
WAS GONNA ASK IF THIS DOESN'T
ONTO APPROPRIATION JET BUT WHAT
KIND OF PRICE TAG IS GOING TO BE
ON THAT BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE SAYING.
THEY HAVE TO START A WHOLE NEW
PROGRAM TO ANALYZE.
THAT DID IT THE DIFFERENT
POLLUTANTS SO AGAIN I ALSO WILL
SUPPORT TODAY WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AIR
QUALITY DISTRICT FORCED TO BE
ABLE THAT WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME
PAGE WITH THE SAME GOAL.
AND AGAIN AS WE TALK ABOUT A
MORE HOLISTIC ACTS OF LIMITING
PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO USE PLANTS
WHEN THEY NEED TO BE USED JUST
ON A THE INVESTMENTS AND THE
JOBS THAT ARE RELATED TO THE
SINKS.
SENATOR YOUR MOTION FOR DO PASS --
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I'VE LISTENED TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THE COMMENTS
OF THE OPPOSITION I'M I WILL.
I LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING THAT
AIRED.
REGIONAL AIR DISTRICTS TO A
PLACE WHERE THEY FEEL.
COMFORTABLE.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD URGE NAY
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A ROLL CALL ON THE MOTION.
HOLDEN HIGH HOLDEN I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I BURKE [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
CHEN NO [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO EGGMAN
[inaudible]
EGGMAN AYE [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES.
MAYES NO MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
REYES I SANTIAGO TING.
TING NOT VOTING [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible] FOR THAT.
SO HEALTH ON CALL WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OF A PERMIT RECESS
[inaudible]
MISTER BRADFORD --
ELEMENT HOLDEN WAS A SPEECH.
FOR YES ITEM.
EIGHT S. B..
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE SENATOR
BRADFORD ELECT SERVICE RATES
FAMILY ELECTRIC GREAT ASSISTANT
PROGRAM.
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR SIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSION I'M HERE
TO PRESENT.
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE ST MEASURE I
KNOW I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE IN THE CHAIR AND
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS ISSUE AND I'M EXCEPT IN THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AND THIS BILL THIS WILL SIMPLY
CODIFY FAMILY ELECTRIC
[inaudible]
RATE.
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OR PARA.
AND I. ENERGY SAVINGS PROGRAM
CONSUMER SIMILAR THE CARE WELL
FARAH ASSIST FAMILIES WITH A
HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF 210050% TO
TWO HUNDRED I'M A 210025% OF
POVERTY LEVEL.
AND WE WERE REYES DATA DISCOUNT
FROM EIGHTEEN ME 12% 18% AND I
RESPECT WEBSPHERE AYE VOTE.
OKAY IF THE MOTION IS SACKETT --
DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES THAT
HER TO TESTIFY IS THERE ANYONE
HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL.
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PUPS ARE.
RESEARCH THE DEFENSE COUNSEL IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
SAY NO OPPOSITION WE BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
HEARING NO COMMENTS.
SIR BROTHER CONTINUE TO FIGHT
FOR THE POOR I RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE AYE VOTE BAIKIE --
VOCAL IN THE MOST.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE
DEPRESSES A MINUTE
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN
AYE PATTERSON [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I BURKE [inaudible]
GEN.
CAN NOT VOTING CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I WORK TIME RECORD
AYE REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING.
ROBERT THERE FIVE VOTES A TIME
CALL THANK YOU.
MEMBERS AND SHARE.
OKAY --
CENTER STERN.
WILL WELCOME YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF BILLS --
WITH YOUR NAME ON THEM.
MOVIE AND FILE ORDER.
S. B. UP FILE ITEM NINE THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE PROGRAM THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
PHONE --
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE ADDRESSES.
WELL I FEEL AS A GOING TO BE AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ENERGY
RESOURCE FOR US IN THE FUTURE
AND IT'S NOT FROM ANYONE
PARTICULAR RESOURCE IT'S A
DIFFERENT WAY TO THINK ABOUT THE
GREAT IN ITS USEFULNESS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES IN THIS IS THE
NOTION OF MICRO GRADES WE'VE
SEEN --
VENTURA COUNTY AND THROUGH --
THE FIRES OUT THERE IN THE NORTH
BAY THE INCREDIBLE IMPACT OF
DISASTERS IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
WE NEED A MORE RESILIENT GRID --
AND WE THINK MICRO GRADS ARE
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THAT PUZZLE --
I DID WANT TO START OFF BY ITS
APPRECIATING THE COMMITTEE'S
WORK -- AND
ACCEPTING A THEM AMENDMENTS AS
WE DISCUSS MISTER CHAIR AND ON
THE POINT OF THE PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES I I WANT TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THAT AND HERE.
I KNOW THERE'S SOME ALTERNATIVE
PROPOSAL THAT PO USE ARE ALSO
PUTTING FORWARD SO I JUST WANT
TO FLAG THAT ONE IS AN ISSUE
THAT.
WOULD LOVE TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH YOU ON BUT YOU KNOW THESE
PRINCIPLES AND THE ROAD MAP
OUTLINED BY YOUR STAFF --
MAKE MAKES TOTAL SENSE AND
SENATOR I AM MY APOLOGIES FOR
INTERRUPTING YOUR FLAT BUT JUST
SO THAT THE COMMITTEE --
BECAUSE YOU AND I DID HAVE A
CONVERSATION YES OF TODAY SO I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE
ALERT -- TO
WHAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING IN TERMS
OF THE TWEAKING OF LANGUAGE ON
PAGE SIX IS THE THIRD BULLET
POINT DOWN --
WORD STARTS DETERMINE IF
SEPARATE UTILITIES AND WE STRUCK
AND DETERMINE IF AND HAVE
DEVELOPED.
AND THEN AS YOU MAKE YOUR AY
THROUGH THE SENTENCE --
WHERE WE HAVE TARIFF ARE WE
STRIKE ARE AND WOULD HAVE AS SO
READ DEVELOP?
SEPARATE UTILITY RATES AND
TERROR.
AS NECESSARY TO SUPPORT
MICROGRAPHS YES OKAY.
SO THANK YOU FOR ITERATING AND
WORKING THROUGH THIS AND YOU
KNOW.
WE'RE COGNIZANT OF RATE PAYER
IMPACT ISSUES --
WERE AWARE OF SOME TO SEE CA --
FACTORS BROUGHT UP IN THE
ANNOUNCES BUT WE THINK THAT
GETTING THE P. YOU SEE SOME OF
AFFIRMATION FROM THE LEGISLATURE
THAT WHAT THEY'RE PROPOSING IN
THIS ROADMAP THEY'RE DEVELOPING
MAKE SENSE.
AND THAT WE KNOW MICROGRAMS OF
IMPORTANT PLACE IN OUR FUTURE --
IT'S CRITICAL FOR THEM TO HEAR
FROM US SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE
[inaudible]
AND BOTH OF A CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DELANEY HUNTER ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCED MICRO GRID SOLUTIONS
THE CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE
ENERGY THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND
STORAGE ASSOCIATION.
AND THE SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ON STRUCK SUPPORT.
WITH THINK SENATOR STERN FIRST
DEDICATION TO THIS ISSUE ITS KEY
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
FUTURE OF THIS GREAT FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS ONE ENSURING
CUSTOMERS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TAKE THEIR ENERGY USAGE IN THEIR
OWN HANDS.
AND MAKE THAT NEED MORE
RESILIENT AS THEY MOVE FORWARD
FOR TWO FOR UTILITIES THAT MAY
WANT TO DO THE SAME THING.
TO HELP OUR COMMUNITIES FIGURE
OUT LAKE PORTION OF THEIR GRID
THAT'S CRITICAL HOSPITAL.
FIRE STATION POLICE STATIONS.
AND THREE AS AS CITIES AND OR
OTHER COMMUNITIES MAY WANT TO
WORK WITH UTILITIES TO DO THAT
WORK.
WE THINK THE DIRECTION OF THE
BILL IN SERVE SETTING OUT A
FRAMEWORK FOR THE PC TO DO THEIR
WORK IT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE SHOULD
BE DOING.
I'M AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE BILL AND
THANK THE CHAIRMAN AND HIS STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK AS WELL.
THAT JUNE MEMBERS MISTER CHAIR
LAURA BENNETT WITH TECH NET
WE'RE HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY
SUPPORT THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE IS
BUILDING PURGES THAT OF
DEPLOYMENT CALIFORNIA'S MOST
INNOVATIVE ENERGY TECHNOLOGIES.
TO THE BENEFIT OF CALIFORNIANS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TECHNOLOGY DEPENDENT SOCIETY.
TECH THAT REPRESENTS OVER EIGHTY
OF THE NATION'S LEADING
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES MAKE AND USE THE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT MAKE UP THE
BAKER GRAD.
DATA CENTERS MANUFACTURERS IN
TECH COMPANIES REQUIRE PREMIUM
RELIABLE POWER INTO PLAYMAKER
GRITS PROTECT AGAINST ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF GRID OUTAGES.
S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE WILL
ALLOW THE ADOPTION INMIGRANTES
FOR BUSINESS UNIVERSITIES
HOSPITALS AND CRITICAL
FACILITIES THAT THEY THAT CAN
USE MICRO GRADES FOR BACKUP
POWER DURING EMERGENCIES.
CALIFORNIA WILL NEED EVERY
TECHNOLOGY.
ADVANTAGE AVAILABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY MANAGE THE EFFECTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
MICHAEL GRAVES AND THEIR ABILITY
TO PROVIDE ENERGY WITH OR
WITHOUT THE GRADE WILL BE A
CRITICAL TOOL FOR THE STATE FOR
THESE REASONS WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU --
OTHER OTHERS HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF OF THIS BILL.
S. B..
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST ON A PRICE ON THE
HAVE TO CALIFORNIA LEAVE
CONSERVATION VOTERS WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS IT IS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED.
IN PRINT THANK YOU.
OBVIOUSLY SHAUN BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY IN
SUPPORT.
JANNA SLANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
I WENT OVER BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
AT THE MARIN ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SCOTT WHICH ON THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES
IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WERE --
IN BETWEEN IF I COULD HAVE A
SECOND TO ADDRESS WHY --
IT MANNING OF KP ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF WATER
AND POWER --
WE ARE THRILLED TO BE SELECTED
AS THE ONLY PEELING HIS SUBJECT
TO THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL --
AFTER THE MEMBERS --
WE ARE -- A
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR SEE
ANYWAY IT OFFERED AMENDMENTS FOR
A PATH. TO WORK WITH THE
SPONSOR'S TO INITIATE A PROCESS --
IT'S CRITICAL TO ALL THE PO USE
THAT IF THERE IS A PROCESS THAT
PROCESS BE LOCALLY DETERMINED --
AND THAT THERE BE A PROCESS
THROUGH WHICH OF SOMEONE'S.
WHO WON A MICRO GOOD WOULD
INITIATE ARM A PROCESS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL [inaudible] TO
ANALYZE.
OF THE TECHNOLOGY AND THE COST
SUCCESSOR AS SUGGESTED BY SOME
OF THE CRITERIA IN THE BILL.
SO -- WE
HOPE TO HAVE --
TIME TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR IN
THE COMMITTEE.
NOW THAT WHERE.
SINGLED OUT --
THROUGH JULY TO TRY TO GET TO A
PLACE WHERE WE'RE COMFORTABLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
WILL NOW RECEIVE --
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL
[inaudible]
PLACE PRECISION.
HELLO ARM MY NAME IS TED
REGULARLY AND I WORK FOR SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC AND THE
DIRECTOR RESPONSIBLE FOR BOTH
OUR MICRO GRAVITY AND ENERGY
STORAGE EFFORTS.
PRONE WE ARE CURRENTLY OPPOSED.
TO THE BILL.
BUT WE ARE VERY ENCOURAGED BY
THAT.
COMMITTEE --
AMENDMENTS AND WE GOT THE
COMMITTEE FOR THOSE AMENDMENTS.
THE WARREN --
IT GETS US ABOUT 90% OF THE WAY
THERE THE ONE ARE WHERE WE STILL
HAVE ISSUE IS HIS BULLET FOR
BULLET.
THREE ON PAGE [inaudible]
SIX WHICH ADDRESSES [inaudible]
TARIFFS --
THE MAIN CONCERN HERE IS AROUND.
A WHAT WE CALL NET ENERGY MAY
METERING OR ANY M. TARA AND
CURRENTLY THE WAY THAT WORKS IS.
YOUR CONSUMPTION IS NETTED
AGAINST YOUR USE [inaudible]
AND OUR YOU GET CREDIT FOR THAT
WHERE WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT.
IS IF ANY ACCESS GENERATION.
GETS CREDITED AT THE RETAIL RATE.
THAT IS A BIG COST SHIFT FOR OUR
CUSTOMERS [inaudible]
THOSE THAT.
WOULD HAVE A MICROCLIMATE FIGHT
FOR THEM WITH YET.
ON THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
PRICE OF ENERGY IS ALMOST
TENFOLD.
SO IT WOULD BE A COST SHIFT FOR
OUR CUSTOMERS.
AND SO THAT THAT IS OUR MAJOR.
OUR CONCERN AND WITHOUT THAT
ENDS MY COMMENTS.
BUT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE VALOR TELEFON
HOST SPECIFIC GAS ELECTRIC
COMPANY --
THE POSSESSIVE AT PTT HAVE
SIMILAR CONCERNS --
THE THE ANALYSIS --
MENTIONS THAT THE BILL HAS SOME --
ANTI COST SHIFTING LANGUAGE
ANAHIT FOR LACK OF BETTER TERM
BUT IN THE BEEN THE BULLETS AND
THEN ALICE'S THOSE WEREN'T
SPECIFICALLY --
LAID OUT SO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT IF A IF A TARIFF IS IS
DEVELOPED.
IT WOULD BE WITHOUT I'M SHIFTING
COSTS TO THE NON PARTICIPATING --
CUSTOMERS --
WE ALSO LIKE TO JUST CLARIFY IT
IT'S JUST NOT COMPLETELY IMPLIED --
IN IN THE WRITE UP THAT --
THE SPECIFIC --
AS A REFERENCE TO THE NET ENERGY
METERING PROCEEDING --
AS THE HOUSE TO HOUSE THIS
DISCUSSION WOULD BE OUT WE DON'T
THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE --
AND AND THE SPECIFIC --
LANGUAGE SAYS THAT --
DISCUSSES --
UP IN THE BILL ABOUT IT A NET
ENERGY METERING TYPE TARIFF--
WOULD BE OUT --
AND THERE'S IT'S NOT CLEAR IF
THIS THE RIGHT UP IS A JUST A
COMPLETE --
SORT OF RE WRITE OF THE LANGUAGE
BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR IF --
THE IMAGE THE LANGUAGE IMPACTING --
FOSSEL.
BACKUP GENERATION WOULD BE OUT
WE WROTE IN OUR LETTER OF
OPPOSITION THAT.
WE FELT LIKE THAT WAS A BIG
IMPEDIMENT --
TO COMPLETELY CREATING A
RELIABLE SOURCE FOR CUSTOMER.
IN THE SITUATION WHERE THE
MICROCREDIT HAS TO ISLAND --
THOSE TYPES OF BACKUP GENERATION
DO RECEIVE LOCAL AIR PERMITS --
AND WE WE DIDN'T THINK THAT THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN STRUCK AND IN
THE SENATE.
I'M WE THINK THAT THE ANALYSIS
TAKES GREAT STRIDES IN ON
IMPROVING THE BELT DEFTLY.
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU.
YOU'VE YOU'VE MADE A GOOD POINT
AS IT RELATES TO THE COST
SHIFTING SO WE'RE THINKING
PROCESSING THAT IS THE TESTIMONY
CONTINUES.
CENTER WILL LOOK FOR YOUR SPEAR
COMMENTS ON THAT AS WELL --
WILL NOW RECEIVE OTHERS WHO ARE
HERE TO STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
PATRICK WELCH FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
A WE OPPOSE THE PRIOR VERSION
THE BILL WE HAVEN'T HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DIGEST AMENDMENTS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD.
TO A TALK WITH THE AUTHOR MOVING
FORWARD THINKING [inaudible]
THANK.
NOT CLUB THE SUIT ON BEHALF OF
SMUD HOW LONG MISTER MANNING IS
CORRECT THAT THE ONLY CURE YOU
CURRENTLY IN THE BILL I WILL BE
LADWP.
US MONIES NOT FAR BELOW THE
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND NUMBER
AND NOW WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
WITH THE GREAT ECONOMIC GROWTH
HAPPENING IN SACRAMENTO --
WE WILL SOON BE INCLUDED --
WE ARE TAKING A LOOK TO SEE HOW
SOON THAT WILL HAPPEN HERE --
AND WILL CONTINUE --
TO I HAVE OPPOSED US IN A
POSITION AND WORK WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE [inaudible]
PERFECT.
OKAY WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DICE AND TO ME DOCTOR PAUL.
FOR SO.
ON PAGE FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS
[inaudible]
SECTION.
FOUR ARE ALL OF THOSE YOU MEANT
IT ALL OF THOSE AMENDMENTS THIS.
THE COURT SICK CRITERION THE
VOLATILITY BEING TAKEN.
YES WITH THE THE MODIFICATION
THAT THAT --
MISTER CHAIR MENTIONED --
ON THAT.
THIRD BULLET ON THE SIXTH PAGE.
OKAY WHICH IT AND LET ME JUST
LOOK AT THAT THAT'S SO THAT'S
THAT I THINK HE USED THE WORDS
DEVELOP INSTEAD OF DETERMINE IF
AND THEN --
INSTEAD OF ARE NECESSARY AS
NEXUS.
OKAY.
AND THEN YOU'RE GOING TO ADDRESS
THAT COST SHIFTING ISSUES IF
THERE ARE ANY YET SO THERE THERE
WAS PROVISIONAL ALREADY.
I CAN I CAN I SPEAK TO THAT AND
THEN THEM QUESTION ACTUALLY IF
YOU DON'T MIND SO.
WE WE THERE'S A ROOM.
THERE'S A REASON --
WHERE WHERE'D WHERE NOT WHERE
THE COMMITTEE AND HOUSE I GUESS
WASN'T SPECIFIC ABOUT CALLING
OUT NAM I THINK THAT WOULD BE
THIS WOULD STE THE AMENDMENTS
WOULD STRIKE THE NAM REQUIREMENT
IN THE CURRENT BILL ENTIRELY?
THAT THAT'S HOW I UNDERSTAND
IT'S OKAY I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
BEEN STRICKEN AND THEN --
AS TO YOUR YOUR QUESTION THE
COST SHIFTING.
I'M I'M I'M OPEN AT YOU KNOW
THERE'S THERE'S SOME LANGUAGE
YOU'VE ALREADY GOT ON PAGE
SEVENTY EXISTING BILL ABOUT
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
MINIMIZING COSTS MAXIMIZING
BENEFITS ALL RATEPAYERS AS AYE
AYE HE'LL WORK ON THE I'M OPEN
TO WORK OKAY.
NOT ALL MOVE THE BILL.
YEAH MY WAS SOMEWHAT.
AGAIN ALONG THE SAME LINES AND
ALSO ON THE ISSUE OF OUR OUR
OVER ARCHING TRY TO LOOK AT THIS
COMPREHENSIVELY LAST WEEK WE
PASSED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
SB SEVEN HUNDRED WHICH ALSO
TALKED ABOUT STORAGE THE AT SOME
BAR.
CARVE OUT FOR LOW INCOME TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE.
M. -- AT THE
INVESTMENTS WHEN INTO THOSE
COMMUNITIES BUT THEN THAT.
COSTA SHIFTED AROUND THERE SO I
JUST.
AS WE KEEP DEVELOPING NEW
PROGRAMS AND WE KEEP SAYING
LET'S LOOK OUT FOR THOSE WHO ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM
THIS HAVING TO PAY FOR IT --
LAST WEEK WE DID ONE THIS WEEK
WE'RE DOING ONE AB.
BUT DOES NEED TO BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WOULD LOOK AT
WHO PAYS FOR THE SENATE AND WHO
BENEFITS YES ABSOLUTELY --
I'M COMMITTED TO THAT AND AND
POTENTIAL EXPORT YOURSELF EVER
IT JUST HOW.
TO ENSURE NO IMPACT ON THIS
ADVANCED REASON ACTUALLY THERE
MAY BE SOME GOOD PROSPECTS IN
THOSE COMMITTEES BUT I AGREEMENT
ON A BILL THAT AND THEN HEARD
OTHER FOLKS AROUND SO
[inaudible]
APPRECIATE THAT --
SO THANK YOU I'M HAPPY TO
ADDRESS THAT THAT.
PO YOU I SEE ANYWAY ISSUE TOO
BUT THAT'S YOUR MATE LET ME JUST
QUICKLY ACTUALLY HAVE A SECOND
YEAH DON'T AGREE TO HAVE A
SECOND OKAY PLEASE --
SO TO THE CONCERNED --
FROM DWP ABOUT SORT OF BEING THE
THE LAST MUNY LEFT STANDING HERE.
I'M I'M OPEN TO THAT THE THE
CONCEPT THAT SEE ANYWAY PUT
FORWARD THAT SORT OF OP DIDN'T
FRAMEWORK.
BUT I YOU KNOW I DEFER TO YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN TERMS OF HOW HOW
YOU WANT TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
GOING FORWARD AYE AYE.
WE DON'T WANT TO FORCE ANY
MUNICIPAL A MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
INTO THIS FRAMEWORK UNLESS THEY
ACTUALLY WANT TO BE THERE AND
THEY'RE GETTING THOSE REQUESTS
AND THEY THEY WANT TO BE IN THE
MIX SO IF.
IF THEY DON'T WANT IN ARE GOING
TO REJECT THOSE THINGS WERE
WILLING TO COMMENT THAT SO
ANYHOW I JUST WANT TO FLAG THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT.
I'M OPEN TO WORKING THROUGH AND
TRYING.
TO REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION OR AT
LEAST WORK THROUGH THEIR
OUTSTANDING TONE I I THINK
THAT'S FAIR OF WELL AS I SAID WE
THIS BEING A COMPRESSED PERIOD
OF TIME --
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE
MOVING FOR THE THOUGHTFUL WAY
BUT AS I MENTIONED TO I THINK
THAT WEAVES PRESCRIBE IT PRETTY
GOOD BUT I AM.
OPEN TO HAVING CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS WITH ON THE SET UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OKAY THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A
SECOND --
DID YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS THIS THE MOTION IS DO --
DO PASS --
TO APPROPRIATIONS AS AMENDED.
AND I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT OF
FOR THE RECORD THAT YOU ARE A
SECOND TO NONE IN THIS AREA IN
EUROPE AND ENERGY INTEREST IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO ADDRESS.
THESE --
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCE --
TECHNOLOGIES AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT KIND OF LEADERSHIP --
AND I WE APPRECIATE THIS BILL
AND WHAT IT DOES TO SORT OF
ALLOW THE PROCESS TO CONTINUE
MOVE ON BE CLEARER --
FOR DEVELOPERS TO BE OUT THERE
AND START.
MAKING THEIR WAY EFFICIENTLY
THROUGH THIS PROCESS SO.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
THAT THIS BILL REPRESENTS AND
APPRECIATE LOS I I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS AND ACTUALLY
SHAPING THIS IN TO AYE EVEN
CLEAR FRAMEWORK AND YOU KNOW.
WHETHER IT'S HOSPITAL IN YOUR
COMMUNITY A SENSITIVE SCHOOL
SITE.
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS ARE
LOOKING THIS.
SCHOOLS OTHER PLACES WHERE
SENIOR USER ARE AT RISK WE THINK
THAT THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
CLEAN DISTRIBUTED ENERGY THIS IS
ABOUT.
PUBLIC SAFETY AND A MORE
RESILIENT CREATE SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
OKAY.
A ROLL CALL THE MOTION.
HOLDEN BY.
PULLING AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
GEN AYE BUT CUNNINGHAM.
I AM NOT VOTING EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA MAYES.
MAYES AYE.
MURATSUCHI AYE MURATSUCHI AYE
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE REYES
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
TELL YOUR BILL IS OUT WILL KEEP
THEIR OPEN FANGRAPHS INVENTORS
THINK.
I WILL NOW MOVE --
TO I'D OF FILE ITEM TEN SP.
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN SENATE
HEARING GOOD OR IS YOUR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I LIKE TO
BEGIN BY.
A ACCEPTING THAT COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS --
AND THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVEN'T
SEEN IT YOU CAN GO TO PAGE SEVEN
IT'S ALL STILL LITTLE.
NEW FOR ME TOO SO I'M I'M
GETTING THROUGH ITS A IT'S A
PARED DOWN BILL BUT I THINK YOU
CAN STILL ACCOMPLISH THE OVERALL
OBJECTIVES OF OF OUR OF OUR BILL
HERE WHICH IS. TO PUSH THE PEACE%
YOU SEE TO REALLY CONSIDER THE
THE POTENTIAL THAT ENERGY
STORAGE HAS TO IMPROVING THE
RESILIENCY OF OUR GREAT IN THAT.
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL WAY NO WAY
THAT DOES IT YOU KNOW THAT THAT
GOES -- BOTH
WITH THIRD PARTY DEVELOPERS AND
WITH UTILITY OWNERSHIP I THINK
WE'RE PUTTING OUT AN IMPORTANT
MARKER HERE. TO TO REALLY ALLOW
UTILITIES --
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
MARKETPLACE BUT AT THE SAME TIME
KEEPING --
THOSE THIRD PARTY DEVELOPERS OF
THE TABLE TO AND I'M REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE COALITION
THAT'S BEEN BUILT HERE IT'S IT'S
UNIQUE TO SEE --
BOATS BOTH SIDES SORT OF PLAYING
TOGETHER AND I THINK IT'S
BECAUSE THERE SHOULD BE ENOUGH
ROOM FOR EVERYBODY IN THE FUTURE
OF ENERGY STORAGE --
SO -- I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
OPINIONS IN STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
OUT THERE AND I JUST INITIALLY
WANTED EXPRESS MY OPENNESS. TO
TO WORKING WITH THOSE WHO STILL
HAVE OUTSTANDING CONCERN NEW BUT
I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD AND AND NOT IN A WAY
THAT --
PREEMPTS OR IN ANY WAY --
AND AROUND THE EXISTING CPU SEE --
FRAMEWORK ON THE IRP PROCESS --
WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO SORT OF?
KEEP THAT MOVING BUT WE THINK
THE LEGISLATURE OUGHT TO SPEAK
UP AND AND LET THEM KNOW THAT
ENERGY STORAGE BE APART THAT MIX.
I WITH THAT [inaudible]
S. RIVAL [inaudible]
IF YOU [inaudible]
AWARENESS. OH YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME'S KALIKA SONOMA VICE
PRESIDENT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR
ENERGY PROCUREMENT AND A
WHOLESALE MARKET OPERATIONS --
THIS BILL IS IS FIRST ABOUT
RELIANCE ON ENERGY STORAGE UNITS
CRITICAL OPERATIONAL FLEXIBILITY --
TO HELP US TO INSURE A RELIABLE
GRAD --
SECOND THIS BILLS ALSO ABOUT --
DETERMINE WHO SHOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DEVELOPING AND
OPERATING A RELIABILITY BASED
ENERGY STORAGE FOR THE BENEFIT
OF ALL CUSTOMERS --
AS BE --
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN WAS
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR BOTH A
CONTRACTED ENERGY STORAGE AND
COMPETITIVE UTILITY SCALE.
OR ENERGY STORAGE ARE AND IT'S
ALL DESIGNED TO BE LOCATED ON
STRATEGIC LOCATIONS ON OUR
ELECTRIC RED.
LOBSTER THAT UTILITIES HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TOOLS THEY NEED TO
SAFELY RELIABLY OPERATOR
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEMS.
A PARTICULAR AS WE REDUCE OUR
RELIANCE ON GAS FIRED A
GENERATION AS WE HEARD EARLIER
HERE TODAY.
AND OUT WE HAVE A AND M.
EMERGING NEED TO INTEGRATE VERY
LARGE LEVELS OF RENEWABLES --
THAT YES PIECE AND CA'S ARE
GONNA NEED TO DEVELOP IN THE
NEXT THREE YEARS. OH IS THEY
BEGIN TO MEET THEIR LONG TERM
OUR PS REQUIREMENTS SET PURSUANT
TO S. B. --
THREE FIFTY TWENTY CLEAR WHAT
THIS BILL IS NOT INTENDED DO ITS
ITS NOT INTENDED TO ADDRESS THE
NON RELIABILITY USES OF ENERGY
STORAGE CUSTOMERS --
SHOULD STILL UP YOUR STORAGE FOR
BEHIND THE METER USES SO WHETHER
THEY BE AYE ACTUAL DEMAND SIDE
CUSTOMERS ARE GENERATORS THAT
USE ENERGY STORED BY THE METER --
WE WOULD STILL --
LOOK TO AND ENTITIES TO USE
ENERGY STORAGE FOR OTHER
PURPOSES SUCH AS THAT DEFERRING
OUT TRADITIONAL WIRES UPGRADES
AND PILOT PROGRAMS IT WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED --
THAT THAT BILL HAD A REQUIREMENT
THAT THE UTILITIES WOULD
CONTRACT FOR THE INITIAL TWO
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS AND
POTENTIALLY OWN UP 250%.
OF THE BILL SINCE BEEN AMENDED
THAT THAT'S THEIR RELIABILITY
BASED ENERGY STORAGE REQUIRE A
REQUIREMENT BE ALLOCATED TO ALL
CCA'S DIRECT ACCESS PROVIDERS
AND UTILITIES.
ARE I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT ALSO
HAS A CONCERN WITH THIS
DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE IT'S THE IT
IS THE OPERATION OF THE ENERGY
STORED ITSELF THAT'S CRITICAL TO
MAINTAINING A RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE GREAT OPERATIONS.
AND IT IS ONLY THE UTILITIES
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO OVERSIGHT BY
THE CPC IN FEDERAL REGULATORS --
CCA'S AND YES PEAS ARE NOT
DIRECTLY REGULATED BY THE CPC
AND IF WE REQUIRE THEM TO
PROCURE THIS RELIABILITY BASED
ENERGY STORAGE.
OF DEL OPERATED FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THEIR CUSTOMERS AND
SHAREHOLDERS --
IN CASE OF A OF A DIRECT ACCESS
PROVIDER AND THEY SHOULD.
ALL UTILITIES ON THE OTHER HAND
IS YOU MAY BE AWARE DON'T MAKE
MONEY AND IN THE ENERGY
PROCUREMENT BUSINESS A WE ARE
REQUIRED BY COMMISSION RULE TO
BETTER RESOURCES AT THEIR ACTUAL
COSTS.
SO THAT THE GRID CAN OPERATE
EFFICIENTLY AND AFFORDABLY AND
RELIABLY FOR ALL CUSTOMERS.
BUT THE OTHER THING TO CONSIDER
ABOUT ALLOCATION ALL CUSTOMERS
IS IT'S JUST NOT ALTS USING ALL
A LOAD SERVING AS IT'S JUST NOT
PRACTICAL.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT A SITUATION
WHERE IF WE HAD A HUNDRED
MEGAWATT REQUIREMENT INPALM
SPRINGS WOULD YOU REALLY WANT
SOMEBODY LIKE LANCASTER OR
PEOPLE RIVERA. TO HAVE TO DO A
HALF OF MEG A LOT PROCUREMENT
ENERGY STORAGE AND PALM SPRINGS
OR DOES IT MAKE SENSE TO HAVE
THE UTILITY DO IT.
ARE AND HAVE IT TAKE ADVANTAGE
ECONOMY OF SCALES AND
IMPORTANTLY BE ABLE DETERMINE
THE OPTIMAL LOCATION FOR THAT
STORAGE AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
ITS USE BEST MEETS THE GRAD
AGAIN UNDER THE FULL OVERSIGHT
OF THE CPUC.
AND THEN --
FINALLY JUST WANT --
TO A REMIND EVERYONE THAT HOW WE
DON'T KNOW HOW THE CCA MODELS
GOING TO TURN OUT AND WE DON'T
KNOW HOW THE S. P. MODELS GOING
TO TURN OUT --
IT MAY BE SUBSTANTIAL IT THEY
MAY NOT BE EVER IF.
IF IT DOES CHANGE OVER TIME AND
WE'VE ALLOCATED ENERGY STORAGE
REQUIREMENTS TO THEM HOW DO WE
AS A STATE ENSURE THAT THAT
ENERGY STORAGE IS THEN AVAILABLE
TO THE UTILITIES UNDER THE CPU
SEES OVERSIGHT.
FERRETTE MEETING CRITICAL GREAT
DATA --
OPERATIONS --
ALT RESPECTFULLY REMIND THIS
COMMITTEE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
INFAMOUS AT ENERGY CRISIS WAS
THE RESULT OF CRITICALLY NEEDED
RESOURCES NOT BEING OPERATED.
BY ENTITIES --
THAT RESPONSIBLE FOR RELIABILITY --
AND THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT OUR SB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN IT'S
INTENDED.
TO TREAT ENERGY STORAGE NO
DIFFERENT THAN POLES AND WIRES
IT DELIVERS ELECTRICITY WHEN
CUSTOMERS NEED IT WHERE THEY
NEED IT.
AND AND THAT IS A UTILITY
FUNCTION.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED --
EXPLICIT WITNESS.
OKAY GIVEN BIRTH GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JANICE LYNN.
ON THE CO FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
STORAGE ALLIANCE.
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF.
WE'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH
CALIFORNIA'S STUCK IT'S GREAT
EXPORT WE HAVE AND ONE THING'S
CLEAR AND I THINK ONE THING WE
CAN ALL AGREE ON IS THE DOC IS
GETTING STUCK HERE IN FACT IT'S
LOOKING MORE AND MORE LIKE AN
OSTRICH.
IN TWENTY AND THE REASON IS IS
THE NECK BONNAT LOAD RAMP IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN THAT NET LOAD
RAMP WAS ABOUT TEN THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS.
ACCORDING TO THE CASE SO BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THAT KNACK THAT
MAXIMUM THREE OUR NET LOAD RAMP
WILL EXCEED SIXTEEN THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS.
THAT'S JUST TWO YEARS FROM NOW.
TO MEET THIS NEED WE NEED TO
CONTRACT FOR FLEXIBILITY NOW.
AND THAT'S WHAT SB THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN DIRECTS.
SO JUST REALLY BRIEFLY ONE I
WANTED TO SAY ABOUT ENERGY
STORAGE IS IT IT IS THE ULTIMATE
FLEXIBILITY TOOL.
IT REPRESENTS A VERY BROAD ASSET
CLASS EVERYTHING FROM THERMAL
STORAGE CAN BE LIKE CITED
ANYWHERE AROUND THE CURRENT TO
VERY LARGE PULP TIGHTROPE.
IT COULDN'T --
OUT.
PERFORM MULTIPLE SERVICES EVEN
FROM THE SAME ASSET IT CAN BE
REPROGRAMMED AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY AND THIS WILL AND
THEN I'LL WRAP UP.
ENERGY STORAGE CAN BE DEPLOYED
WITH THE ASSETS WE ALREADY HAVE.
SO IT YOU KNOW IT'S IN THE
DISCUSSION EARLIER.
FOSSIL PLANTS WHEN THEY RAN UP
AND THEIR GOAL THEIR RAMPING UP
AND DOWN THEY'RE NOT VERY
EFFICIENT THEY PRODUCE A LOT OF
POLLUTION.
INTEGRATING STORAGE WITH A
FOSSIL PLAN CAN ABSORB THAT LOAD
FOLLOWING THAT FLEXIBILITY AND
ALLOW THE UNDERLYING ASSET TO
OPERATE MORE EFFICIENTLY MORE
AFFORDABLY AND CLEANER.
SO IN SUMMARY S. B. THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN REPRESENTS A SMART
NO REGRETS INSURANCE FOR A
CLEANER MORE AFFORDABLE
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR MEMBRANE WHITE
HERE ON BEHALF OF RECURRENT
ENERGY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF BILL
READ RECOGNIZE THE BENEFITS THEY
ENERGY STORAGE CAN HAPPEN
BUILDING MORE PROJECTS.
AND SO WITH THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL LIKE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT
WHICH IN BEHALF OF THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS IN THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES
WELL WERE DISAPPOINTED WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN WE
BUT WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
CHAIR MEMBERS TWENTY HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF ADVANCED MICRO GOOD
SOLUTIONS AND THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION INSTRUCTS
SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRING COMMITTEE TERESA
BURKE* ON BEHALF OF CERES
AND SUPPORT.
A MAN ON THE OFFICE YOUR CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU --
WILL NOW RECEIVE.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
TO BILL [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
ROOM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JASON I COULD WITH
EDELSTEIN GILBERT WROTE ROBESON
AND SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CHOICE
ASSOCIATION.
CALCI CA WHICH REPRESENTS THE
OPERATIONAL COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS IN CALIFORNIA COME
AND AND I'M JUSTICE OF
PREVARICATION YOU'RE ADDRESSING
THE BILL AS AMENDED.
ADDRESSING THE BILL AS AMENDED
SIR AND I AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AND AND WILL CONFINE MY COMMENTS
TO THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL --
WHICH DOESN'T AS FAR AS I CAN
TELL --
RELATE TO RESILIENCY RELIABILITY
IS SUPPOSED TO BE AMENDED --
KELSEY CA DE.
DOES NOT HAVE A A A A PROJECTION
TO THE FRAMEWORK IN THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS.
BOB BUT THEIR CONCERN GOES TO
THEIR PROCUREMENT AUTONOMY THERE
WAS SOME DISCUSSION OF THIS A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER BUT COMMITTEE
CHOICE AGGREGATORS ARE.
LOCAL WE GOVERNED AT PUBLIC
BODIES AND AS SUCH THEY ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THE SAME.
CHAIRMAN OVERSIGHT RULES AND
REQUIRE.
MANDATES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
INSTEAD THERE.
CHAIRMAN IS GOVERNED LOCALLY AND
THE LOCALS GET TO SET THE TAR
AND THE THE THE THE MEANS BY
WHICH THEY ARE GONNA THE TARGETS
INCLUDING THE ONES THAT ARE
CONTEMPLATED IN THIS BILL --
ARE ISSUES AT THIS POINT I ARE
ARE REALLY CONFINED TO THE
LANGUAGE PROPOSED UNSUB DE.
UM IT RELATES TO AGAIN WHETHER
OR NOT WE GET TO MAINTAIN OUR
PROCUREMENT ECONOMY.
IT'S A LITTLE UNCLEAR GIVEN THAT
THE LANGUAGE IS REQUIRING THAT A
C. C. A. OR OTHER LOAD SERVING
ANY MAKE A SHOWING --
THAT -- A
RESOURCE IS COST EFFECTIVE AND
VIABLE WHO THAT SHOWING IS GOING
TO BE MADE.
TO IF IT'S THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION THAT WOULD
BE OUTSIDE OF HOW WE'VE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN TREATED AS
LOAD SERVING ENTITIES AGAIN
BECAUSE THE CPUC DOES NOT.
HAVE THE AUTHORITY RIGHT NOW TO
SET PROCUREMENT FOR US AND
THERE'S ALSO A LITTLE BIT OF
CONFUSION THAT WHEN WE START
TALKING ABOUT UTILITY OWN
GENERATION FOR THE 50% --
CCA'S OUR LOAD SERVING ENTITIES
THAT ARE COVERED BY THE
AMENDMENTS HOWEVER WE ARE.
UTILITIES SO IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT
THAT WOULD MEAN.
TIME WE BELIEVE THAT.
PLEASE CONCERNS COULD BE EASILY
ADDRESSED BY BY SIMPLY
CLARIFYING THAT THAT CCA'S LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES CONTINUE TO
HAVE.
CHAIRMAN AUTONOMY THAT THEY
ALWAYS HAVE UNDER EXISTING
STATUTE --
BUT ABSENT THAT AMENDMENT WE
CONTINUE TO BE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TED REGULARLY GROUPS.
TED REGULARLY WITH S. T. GENIE
AGAIN ARM AS THE BILL AS AMENDED
BY COMMITTEE ON WE STILL ARE
OPPOSED BUT AS I STATED IN THE
LAST BILL.
IT IT GETS US QUITE OF A WAY
THERE.
THE ONE ISSUE WE HAVE IS WITH
ITEM DE.
THE TALKS ABOUT.
OUR OWNERSHIP --
WE ARE TOTALLY SUPPORT --
VARIOUS ENTITIES.
UP ENERGY ARE OWNING ENERGY
STORAGE BUT IT REALLY IS DRIVEN
BY USE CASE AND HOW THE ENERGY.
A STORAGE IS BEING UTILIZED SO
FOR THAT REASON WE DON'T THINK
THAT OWNERSHIP COULD BE CUT
SHOULD BE CODIFIED IN THE BILL.
AND WITHOUT THEM ALSO THAT THAT
SAID IN CLOSING IN THEN CANCER
ANY HARD QUESTIONS.
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE OKAY --
WILL RECEIVE ANYONE ELSE WHO'S
HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
NAME AND ORGANIZATION PLEASE
DOCTOR JEAN NELSON CALIFORNIA'S
REGAIN NUCLEAR POWER
INCORPORATED ARM IF YOU
CAREFULLY STUDY OF FOR TO FORM
ONE DAVIS ARE YOU SIR.
ASSURE SAID ONLY NAME AND
ORGANIZATION OKAY WELL.
WERE REALLY WORRIED ABOUT WHAT
IT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH ENERGY
STORAGE IN CALIFORNIA IS NOT
BEING USED RIGHT.
WORKING CARVE ALTERNATIVE
STRATEGY GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS ARE
TAKEN TODAY I'M AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE OTHERS
OFFICE ON JUST ONE OR TWO TWO
WEEKS IN CONCERT THAT WAS TO
HAVE.
PERFECT --
WILL TURN OUT TO MEMBERS DOCTOR
QUIRK.
YES SO --
THE OPPOSITION OF CCA'S IS A
PERFECT OUR EXAMPLE.
OF WHY IT IS BEEN FOOLISH
FRANKLY TOO BALKANIZED OUR
SYSTEM.
THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS BILL.
IS YOU CAN'T GET.
ECONOMIES OF SCALE UNLESS YOU
CAN ALSO CAUSE THE CCA'S.
OUGHT TO BUY YEN AND THAT'S THE
POINT OF THE BILL WITH ITS
AMENDMENTS.
AND SO IF THE CCA'S TRYING GET
OUT OF THIS I WILL BE.
ARE VERY UPSET BECAUSE THERE
WILL BE NO WAY TO GET LARGE
SCALE SO STORAGE UNLESS THEY'RE
PART OF THIS.
AND BALKANIZED IN THE SYSTEMS
WITH MANY CCA'S HAS NOT HELPED
US OUT WILL NOT GIVE US RELIABLE
ENERGY -- I
THINK I'VE SAID ENOUGH I'M
VOTING FOR THE BILL AS AMENDED
THANK YOU.
IF I COULD CLARIFY MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
WE DON'T NEED YOUR ANSWER AT
THIS -- BUT
WITH ALL RESPECT TO MEMBERS
SATISFIED.
ARE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
AS CHAIR I I'D LIKE TO HEAR IT'S
HIS USERS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUSTIN
TO RESPECTFULLY CLARIFY WOULDN'T.
KELSEY CA AND THE COMMITTEE
TRUSTS AGGREGATOR COMMUNITY IS
NOT LOOKING TO BE.
EXEMPT FROM THE BILL ARE NOT
HAVE A MANDATE PLACE US IN FACT
THE EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS GOING TO APPROVE ANY KIND OF
A PROCUREMENT MANDATE WE WOULD.
PREFER TO SEE IT ON US BECAUSE
WE EXIST. TO SERVE OUR CUSTOMERS
AND MEET THOSE REQUIREMENTS.
IT TO CLARIFY THE MINUTE WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IS JUST TO STIPULATE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO HARPER
CHAIRMAN AUTONOMY.
ON HOW WE MEET THAT MANDATE
WHERE WE MEET THAT MANDATE.
AND THAT'S THE DIFFICULTY
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET
LARGE SCALE STORAGE IF EVERYONE
OF THE CCA'S DECIDES HOW THEY
CAN DO IT.
AND THAT'S MY CONCERN AND I I
DON'T NEED A RESPONSE THANK YOU.
OKAY -- IF
THERE ARE NO OTHER.
I KNOW THE COMETS --
YEAH.
FIRST SO SENATOR RIGHT YOU DON'T
APPLY PRESET YOU WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS --
AGAIN ONE OF THOSE BILLS AND A
PACKAGE OF BILLS IT'S ADDRESSING
AN IMPORTANT AREA ISSUE A
RECOGNIZE THE THE DYNAMICS THE
ROUTE WITH CCA'S AND YET I
APPRECIATE THE FLEXIBILITY THAT.
IS BUILT AND SO THIS BILL AND
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
IN THE NEED TO FOCUS ON STORAGE
BUT IT YET.
CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR OTHER
PROJECTS TO BE.
ARE RECOGNIZED --
AND WITHIN THAT TWO THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS SO I THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT --
THIS IS A DO PASS --
AS AMENDED TO APPROACH.
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU MEMBERS FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION --
ENERGY STORAGE IS.
THE FUTURE OF OUR GREAT AND WITH
ALL THE RENEWABLES TARGETS AND
ALL THE OTHER --
CHALLENGES WE HAVE AHEAD I THINK
THIS IS A AYE NO REGRETS TARGET
IN THE BILL --
AND I APPRECIATE THE FLEXIBILITY
BECAUSE WITH THE KIND OF SCALE
WERE LOOKING AT IT PROJECTS ALL
OVER THE STATE IT MAY BE MUCH
MORE THAT'S NEEDED AND THAT'S
WHY -- THEM
PRODUCTS IF THE AMENDMENTS AND
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND LOOK
FOR TO WORK WITH THE GOING FOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AT THE BANK
EUROCOPA.
HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE PATTERSON AYE.
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
GEN AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
THE BILL AS OUT A HE PICKED THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
ADD ON THANK YOU AND YOUR LAST
BILL BEFORE US TODAY IS S. B..
FOURTEEN SEVEN SEVEN HERE.
AND THIS --
DOES ALSO ENJOY DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
GIVE A QUICK SICK TO MY
WITNESSES SURE.
SO THIS IS THIS PART OF THE TRI
FACTOR OF OF BECAUSE YOU'RE
SEEING TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE [inaudible]
I THINK COLLECTIVELY THEY'RE
GOING.
TO PLEASE MAKE MY COMMUNITY BACK
HOME.
IMPORTER RANCH FEEL SAFER
KNOWING THAT --
WE'RE LOOKING TO THE FUTURE AND
WE'RE NOT JUST GOING TO RELY ON
THE THE SYSTEMS OF THE PAST AND
AND THIS BILL REALLY LOOKS AT
THE BUILDING SECTOR AND AND WHAT
MORE WE CAN DO. TO ADVANCE NEW
TECHNOLOGY TO REDUCE COSTS TO
HOMEOWNERS AND TO ADVANCE
ALTERNATIVES --
LIKE ELECTRIC HEAT PUMPS AND
OTHER --
ALTERNATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
REDUCING BOTH THE EMISSIONS
PROFILE OF OUR BUILDINGS BUT
ALSO MAKE THEM --
EASIER TO OPERATE AND AND LOWER
COSTS WE ARE IN A HOUSING CRISIS
AND SO THE THAT THE SHAME WOULD
BE IS IF WE CHARGED AHEAD IN
THIS HOUSING CRISIS.
BUILT A WHOLE NEW SET A HOUSING
STOCK.
STUCK IN THE TWENTY CENTURY SO
WE NEED TO OF ALL HERE IN THIS
BILL IS A BIG PART OF THAT --
I I APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THEM --
AND AS WE DISCUSSED I'M ALSO
THERE WAS A COMMENT --
ON PAGE EIGHT ARE CONCERNED
REYES THAT I ALSO THINKWE CAN
ADDRESS HERE --
THE CONCERN WAS THAT THIS THAT
IF WE RAN OUT OF FUNDING --
FOR THIS THESE TWO PROGRAMS THE
BILL PROGRAM A TECH PROGRAM THAT
YOU'D BE DIPPING IN TWO NEW
AUTOMATICALLY NEW PUBLIC PURPOSE
CHARGES THAT'S NOT THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING --
TO ADD ADDITIONAL COSTS ON TO
RATE PAYERS ARE OR TREAT THIS IS
A BLANK CHECK AND SO THE CAP ON
FUNDING IS IS WELCOME AND AS
WELL AS THE SUN SET.
UP BUT I DID ONE OFFER THAT IF
IF THERE'S OPEN THIS YEAR
INTEREST --
NOT JUST LIMITING IT --
TO THAT --
THE GREENHOUSE GAS --
GAS ALLOWANCES --
BUT STILL MAINTAINING SOME
FLEXIBILITY WHETHER IT'S TRYING
FROM BOTH THE ELECTRIC SECTOR --
THERE'S STILL FUNDING IN NEW
SOLAR HOMES PARTNERSHIP OR OTHER
EXISTING FUNDING SOURCES BUT BUT
NOT -- I'D
BE OPEN ALL SAID ADDING SOME
KIND A SAVINGS OR OR OR
ASSURANCE THAT THIS THERE WOULD
BE NO NO LOOK IT AUTOMATICALLY
FUNDING THROUGH A NEW PUBLIC
PURPOSE CHARGE THAT.
THERE REALLY IS NOT SUPPOSED TO
BE A BACK DOOR HER NEW RATE
PAYER FUNDED PROGRAMS --BUT I WILL BE ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS AND LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I HAVE A VERY UNIQUE
COALITION HERE WHEN YOU HAVE
ENTERED THE SEA AND THE
DEVELOPERS ON BOARD ON THE SAME
BILL -- I
THINK YOU'VE GOT SOMETHING THEY
ARE OFTEN AT ODDS BUT I THINK.
BOTH SIDES SEE A REAL FUTURE
HERE NOW IN A MORE ADVANCED
BUILDING SECTOR WITH WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WRAP UP
[inaudible]
SECOND.
IF THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND --
IS THERE IN ORDER.
TO THE WITNESSES THAT YOU LIKE
TO DON'T JUST BE REAL BRIEF
BECAUSE I THINK OTHER STEPS.
UP.
ANTI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SCOTT
SHELL THE PRINCIPLE WITH E. HPD
ARCHITECTS IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE ABOUT SIXTY PEOPLE THE
PROJECT SOME PEOPLE KNOW OF OURS
IS THE MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM --
WE'VE DESIGNED ABOUT OF A DOZEN
ALL ELECTRIC ZERO ENERGY
BUILDINGS IN THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS. FOR WE STARTED IT WAS
HARD AND THEY WERE MORE
EXPENSIVE AND I'M PLEASED TO
FEEL SB HERE TODAY AND SAY.
OF THERE'S NOT A COST PREMIUM
RIGHT NOW WE'RE DESIGNING THESE
WITHIN OUR CLIENTS CONVENTIONAL
BUDGETS --
WE COMPARE RANGE OF DIFFERENT
HEATING SYSTEMS WE HAVE THE
CONTRACTOR'S PRICE THEM AND THE
PRICES ARE COMING AN EQUAL TO
THE GAS SYSTEM.
IF WE CAN ELIMINATE THE GAS
SERVICE WE CAN SAVE MONEY WE
JUST DID THAT ON A SCHOOL AND
SAVE SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS --
WE THINK IT'S THE RIGHT THINGTO
DO I WENT OUT TO SEVEN OF OUR
LEADING MECHANICAL ENGINEERS AND
ASK THEM THEY AGREED THAT WERE
READY TO GO ALL ELECTRIC.
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE IS
THAT THE INDUSTRY HAS JUST SLOW
TO CHANGE IT NEEDS A PUSH.
MOST OF THE INDUSTRY WANTS TO DO
WHAT THEY'VE ALWAYS DONE AND
THEY NEED A LITTLE PUSH TO GET
MOVING AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S IVY
HUMANIST ATTITUDE IF RATTLING
DEFENSE.
A PUBLIC POLICY ORGANIZATION ARE
DEDICATED TO EMPOWERING LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES ADVANCING
VIOLENCE OF JUSTICE AND ASSURING
JOB CREATION PARTICULARLY GREEN
SECTOR.
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT THIS BILL
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE 30% --
SET ASIDE THAT HAS FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSING AND OTHER NEW
BUILDINGS LOCATED IN LOW INCOME
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THIS COURT I WILL ENSURE THAT
NEWLY CONSTRUCTED OF LOW INCOME
HOUSING --
AND OTHER QUALIFYING BUILDINGS
ARE BUILT WITH NEAR ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY FROM THE
ONSET INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON
RENOVATIONS WE H. YOU KNOW TEND
TO BE COSTLIER IN THE LONG RUN.
ALSO HAS BEFORE TWO SEVEN SEVEN
TARGET DEPLOYMENT OF LOW.
EMISSION SPACE AND WATER HEATING
TECHNOLOGY THOUGH INCREASE THE
AFFORDABILITY OF ENERGY FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
WHILE ALSO IMPROVING THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY.
AND THIS WILL ENSURE EQUITABLE
DEPLOYMENT OF EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES WHICH LOW LOW
INCOME HOUSING --
HOUSEHOLD OFTEN CANNOT AFFORD
AND THUS MUST WAIT UNTIL
TECHNOLOGY BECOMES AFFORDABLE TO
REAP ITS BENEFITS WHILE
WEALTHIER HOUSEHOLDS ENJOY THE
BENEFITS MUCH OLD MUCH EARLIER --
LASTLY --
DID OF THIS BILL PRIDE JOB
TRAINING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES.
WORK FOR DEVELOPERS HE'S ARE
NEEDED IN THE GREEN SECTOR TO
ENSURE THAT CUSTOMERS RECEIVE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS.
BOTH IN THE FORM OF UTILITY
SAVINGS PLAN IMPLEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES SO THAT OF JUST
RESPECTFULLY URGE AIR AYE VOTE
TODAY AND THINK --
THIS YOU KNOW THE AUTHOR FAIRIES
EFFORTLESS --
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE NOT
EFFORTLESS.
AND THE PURPOSE TO PLAY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CASSIE
GILSON ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY AND SO STRONG
SUPPORT AND I THINK THAT AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS FOR THEIR
TREMENDOUS WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
I'M AS WE LOOK TO DRIVE DOWN --
RESIDENTIAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS WE NEED PROGRAMS LIKE
THIS TO DO THAT AT ANY SCALE
YOU'RE ALL VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THE NEW SOLAR HOMES PARTNERSHIP.
AND WE FOUND THAT THAT PROGRAM
WAS PRETTY.
THE LEVEL OF MYERS SAIDTHAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO MAKE THEIR
HOMES MORE ENERGY EFFICIENT
COMFORTABLE AND LIVABLE.
I'M WE THINK THIS PROGRAM WILL
BE SIMILARLY SUCCESSFUL AND FOR
THAT REASON STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU ARE OTHERS HERE TO
LEND THEIR VOICE IN SUPPORT.
NAME AND ORGANIZATION PLACE
ERICA MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF
EARTH JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
A MAN ON THE OFFICE HERE OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
REX W. HIGH MUMMY HAVE
CALIFORNIA'S PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT TOOLS
LIKE THIS HELP PROPERTY OWNERS
UNDERSTAND NOT ONLY THE
REQUIREMENTS BUT WASTE FINANCES
REQUIREMENTS AND MAKE A LOT
EASIER.
CURSING THE TERRACE OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION AND
SUPPORT.
EILEEN TOVAR BEHALF THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
AIR NEW LA BEHALF OF THE
EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL AND SUPPORT.
IF YOU ARE CROWDED WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT ALSO
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS THINK.
PIRELLI ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
IN SUPPORT.
CHRISTIAN MILLAR RETICENT REGS
THINGS SUPPORT FAR TERRIFIC THE
BAY AREA. THREE SEPARATE
BETJEMAN HALF A SERIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DO ANY HUNTER FOR THE CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY IN SUPPORT
MACLEOD STAY ON BEHALF OF SMART
IN SUPPORT.
ON A FOR AIR WITH THE SCHOOL
ENERGY COALITION IN SUPPORT.
HAD GO TO THE CALIFORNIA SPEED
TO THE CESSATION IN SUPPORT.
OKAY WILL ENTERTAIN A COMMENTS
FROM THOSE WHO WERE IN.
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
[inaudible]
YOU OFFER [inaudible]
IT'S I HAVEN'T GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE VALERIE TRAIL OF
LAJOS PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY --
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL --
HAVING -- IF
EV AT SOME PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH --
OF THE AUTHOR AND SOME OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS.
ON THE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES DOES --
GO A LONG WAY TO IMPROVE THE
BELL RECOGNIZING THE NEED FOR
CPUC ADMINISTRATION SO THAT THE
IF MONIES ARE COLLECTED FROM A
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY CUSTOMERS.
THE DOES THE BENEFIT STATE --
SETS IT YEAH I AM A TAP ON THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING THAT.
AND THEN SOME SORT OF SOME
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT --
IT WITH WITH THE SUNSET DATE I
TESTIFIED SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE
BEEN THERE FOR AND NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE --
I AND YOU KNOW THE LITANY OF
IDEA.
AND REALLY RELATING THE BILL
KIND OF TO THE NEW SOUL HOMES
PARTNERSHIP BEEN AND HOW WE CAN
LEARN FROM FROM OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE ON ON THE
BOOKS THAT ARE.
REGULATORS ARE ARE HELPING US
EMPLOYMENT IN IT IN ADMINISTER --
AND THE REASON IT'S OF SOME MY
TESTIMONY TODAY IS MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT SPECIFIC IS BECAUSE
PETER.
IS REALLY TRYING TO SOME OF THE
WORDS I'VE USED WITH SOME OF THE
FOLKS ON THAT HAVE HEARD ME TALK
ABOUT THIS BILL IT'S WE REALLY
ARE TRYING TO DIG DEEP.
AND ARE THINKING IN THIS
COMPRESSED PERIOD OF TIME AND
THINK UP A PRODUCTIVE WAY TO
SHAPE THE SPELL --
AND SO -- IN
TERMS OF THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR CAP WE THINK ACTUAL LEAVE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IS
I'M GOING TO BE A BETTER WAY TO
GO -- WE
THINK FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EXAMPLE COULD BE IS IT ANNUALLY
COULD BE USED FOR THE ATTACK
PROGRAM THAT'S A PROMISING
PROGRAM THAT WE SEE --
TO LOOK AT UPSTREAM --
WAYS TO WORK WITH OUR
MANUFACTURERS ARE DISTRIBUTORS
POSSIBLY SOME THAT THE
DEVELOPERS DIRECTLY.
ON DEAL WITH WE KNOW THAT THE
CDC IS ALREADY GONNA REQUIRING
TWENTY TWENTY ZERO NET ENERGY
BUILDINGS WHICH THEN WE HEARD
TESTIMONY THAT THEIR BASIC ON
PAR WITH THE MARKET.
BUT NEVERTHELESS --
THERE'S GONNA BE A REQUIREMENT
ON THE BUILDING ENVELOPE ARE
READY.
AND WE THINK THAT IF WE
ENCOURAGE MANUFACTURERS YOU KNOW.
ATTITUDE TO WORK WITH DEVELOPERS
AND GIVES PUT SOMETHING OUT
THERE ON THE SHELVES THAT
WOULDN'T THAT WOULD ENCOURAGE
THAT OUT WE THINK THAT THAT
SHOULD BE I THINK WHAT THE BILL
SAYS THAT'S NEW BUILT --
AND ALSO WE SHOULD CONSIDER THAT
THAT ACTUALLY IS BEYOND TITLE.
TWENTY FOUR IF THAT'S POSSIBLE --
WE ALSO THINK THAT ABOUT SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS COULD BE IN THE
BILL PROGRAM AND THIS IS WHERE
WE'VE REALLY JUST HOT OFF THE
PRESSES COME OFF OF WORK A
DISCUSSION THIS MORNING --
WHERE WE THINK THAT --
THAT BACK OF THE ENVELOPE COULD
GO INTO OVER --
THIRTY THOUSAND UNITS OF HOUSING
TO COVER THE COSTS --
THAT THE DIFFERENTIAL THAT WE
SEE BETWEEN CHOOSING THE
TRADITIONAL TECHNOLOGY OR NOW
GOING -- FOR
MAINLY OUR CALCULATIONS FOR THE
HEAT PUMP ELECTRIC HEAT PUMP
FIVE FOR WATER HEATING AND SPACE
HEATING --
WE ALSO THINK THAT --
YOU COULD STRICTLY FOCUS THAT ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING LOW INCOME
AREAS --
BECAUSE THIS LEGISLATORS JUST
HAD RECENTLY HAD A BIG DEBATE ON
THAT AND THERE'S A LOT OF
PROGRAMS OUT THERE THAT WE CAN
COMPLEMENT LIKE.
THE SET ASIDE IN S. CHIP THAT'S
FOR LOW INCOME --
MISS EGGMAN'S --
PROGRAM --
THREE AND MAYBE --
OTHER THE OTHER PROGRAM
REFERENCE IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
THE EP YOU SEE --
HAS -- HAS
RECENTLY ADOPTED I'M A FEW
MILLION DOLLARS FOR MEASUREMENT
EVALUATION ETCETERA.
WHERE P. GENIE CANNOT ACCEPT --
LANGUAGE IS HAVE OUR GAS
CUSTOMERS PAID FOR THE FUEL
SWITCH TO ELECTRIFICATION --
IT AND TO TELL YOU WHY WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THAT IS BECAUSE THINK
OF THE DYNAMIC RETAIL MARKET
THAT WE HAVE NOW.
AND BUNDLED CUSTOMERS ARE
LEAVING AND OTHERS ARE LEFT
BEHIND AND THERE'S FEWER
CUSTOMERS TO PAY FOR FIXED COSTS
[inaudible]
SO.
WE DO NOT WANT A SCENARIO WHERE
WE ARE HAVING GAS CUSTOMERS THAT
PAID FOR OTHER PEOPLE TO LEAVE
THE SYSTEM.
AND OTHERS ARE LEFT BEHIND WITH
FIXED COSTS SO WE DO NOT WANT TO
SEE -- GAS
CUSTOMERS --
PAPER PAPER THIS PROGRAM --
AND SO I'M AS YOU CAN SEE I HOPE
YOU AGREE THAT WE'VE REALLY
THOUGHT HARD --
ABOUT THE FRAMEWORK FOR THIS
PROGRAM.
I'M WE HAVEN'T --
COMPLETELY FINISHED PROPOSING --
AMENDMENTS TO THE ALL --
BUT THOSE ARE ALONG THE LINES --
OF WHAT WE'RE THINKING SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
ALLOWING ME THE TIME AS THE SOLE
WITNESS ON THIS OPPOSITION SIDE
OF THE BILL.
YOU'RE MORE THAN WELCOME --
IS THERE ANY IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO IS.
NOT TO TESTIFY BUT JUST.
TO VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
OKAY WELL I GUESS YOU WERE THE
LONE VOICE OF OPPOSITION.
THAT BATTLE --
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
[inaudible]
BEYOND IT [inaudible]
EXETER DOT.
SELECT A QUIRK ASK HER MOM I
THOUGHT I THINK IT IS SARAH
REALLY IMPORTANT.
IF WE FIND A WAY TO GET OFF
NATURAL GAS IF WE ARE GOING TO
NEED OUR CLIMATE GOALS --
SHOW I AM CERTAINLY ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORTER IT FELL THANK YOU.
OKAY -- JUST
SPREADS AT THINGS CHAIR THEM. TO
SEE A SENATOR YOU TOO SIR --
SO ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS --
IN REGARDS TO FUNDING YEAH --
NOW THIS READ THIS HERE IT SAYS
CONSEQUENTLY OTHER NOT INTENDED
BY THE AUTHOR THE FUNDING OF
BUILDING TECH FROM ELECTRIC GIGI
LANCE'S RESULT IN A NEW POT
PURPOSE PROGRAM CHARGE ELECTRIC
CUSTOMERS. TO INSURE THAT THIS
BILL A PUBLIC PURPOSE CHARGES
DOES NOT OCCUR THE COMMITTEE MAY
WISH TO CONSIDER LIMITING THE
FUNDING.
THE BILL THE TEXT NO MORE THAN
FIFTY MILLION A YEAR FROM.
CHICHI GAS ANNOUNCES I'M
ACTUALLY STRUGGLE BUT WITH AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT.
AT THAT POINT CAN YOU JUST THAT
YEAHSENATE AYE I WAS PRO TOO
QUICK IN MY OPENING STATEMENT
BUT I I DON'T WANT THIS TO HAVE
A SPILLOVER AFFECTED TRIGGER AN
AUTOMATIC NEW PUBLIC PURPOSE
CHARGE THAT WAS NEVER THE GOAL.
BUT I'M SORT OF STUCK HERE
BECAUSE NOW I'M HERE FROM THE
OPPOSITION THEY DON'T WANT IT TO
COME FROM.
THE GAS SIDE OF THE UTILITY AYE
AYE USING THIS STATE --
PURCHASE ALLOWANCES FOR THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM AND THOSE ARE
CONSIGNED BACK IN THAT REVENUES
PLACE THE P. YOU SEE TO DELIVER
REPAIR BENEFITS OF THE ELECTRIC
SIDE HAS SOME THAT'S CARVED OUT
THAT.
SOME WHICH FUNDS MISS SEGMENTS
PROGRAMMING LOW INCOME SOLAR AND
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WAS A
GASP RIGHT NOW IF WE LEAVE IT ON
TOUCH TO GOES RIGHT BACK TO
RATEPAYERS.
JUST ONE BIG CHUNK BUT NOT.
THE ORIGINAL CONCEPT WAS BECAUSE
WHAT WE WANT TO SEE IN THE
BUILDING SECTOR IS A MIX OF
INNOVATIVE GAS TECHNOLOGY
INNOVATIVE ELECTRIC TECHNOLOGY
RIGHT AN ELECTRIC HEAT PUMP NEW
WAYS TO INTEGRATE ARE IN G. THE
BILL WAS.
DESIGNED TO BE TECHNO TRY
APPRECIATE FOLKS WANT TO SEE
LESS GAS IN THE SYSTEM BUT IT
ACTUALLY WASN'T HERE TO EXCLUDE
GAS.
THAT'S WHY WE ORIGINALLY HAD IT
WITH ELECTRIC AND GAS A BUT I'M
I'M I'M DEFERRING TIP TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THAT FRONT IN TERMS
OF HOW TO CONSTRAIN THIS BUT I I
WOULD.
I AM OPEN.
TO A ADDING THAT SAVINGS BECAUSE
THE STATE THIS WON'T TRIGGER ANY
NEW PUBLIC PURPOSE CHARGES.
AND BE.
ARE THERE OTHER POTS S. CHIP WAS
MENTIONED I KNOW THE COMMITTEE
MOVE SOMETHING ALONG ON THAT
FRONT --
THERE'S EPIC FUNDS IN SOME C. E.
C. PROGRAMS THERE'S ACTUALLY
LEFT OVER DOLLARS IN THE NEW
SOLAR HOMES PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
SO I'M OPEN TO THOSE FUNDING
SOURCES I DON'T WANT TO PUT.
THIS WHOLE BURDEN NECESSARILY ON
GAS CUSTOMERS BUT YEAH
[inaudible]
THAT'S THAT'S MY COMMENT ON INTO
THEIR MEN'S WOULD WOULD WOULD
STAY WITHIN JUST THAT GASOLINE
BUT I'M I'M UP.
SO IS THIS SPENDING.
SOME OF THAT CLIMATE CREDIT OR
IS THIS A NEW CHARGE ON RATE
PAYERS TO BE ABLE TO US THAT
THAT'S THE PART I'M.
NOT IN CHARGE OF WITHIN THE
CRIME OCCURRED.
WITHIN YEAH SO SO TO BE CLEAR
THAT IT IT WOULD.
BE I GUESS IT'S A 5% I MEAN IT'S
A FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR CAP SO
WE ORIGINALLY CARD THAT IT 5%
BUT THAT MEANS 95% THEN IT GOES
BACK TO THE CLIMATE CREDIT AND
ENDS UP AS A STRAIGHT DIVIDEND
ON YOUR BILL ALTHOUGH TO MY
KNOWLEDGE AND MAY MISS SURE.
YOU COULD CORRECT ME IF I'M NOT
WRITER MY WITNESS BUT I DON'T
THINK ANY OF THAT HAS YET COME
BACK TO CUSTOMERS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S BEEN SO THAT
IT'S A REDUCTION IN WHAT THEIR
THEIR CREDIT IS GOING TO BE ON
THEIR BILL.
YES IT I MEAN SOURCE SPENDING IT
FOR THEM IN ESSENCE WORK THAT'S
RIGHT I MEAN I THINK AND I THINK
HE YOU'VE GOTTA GET COMFORTABLE
WITH.
THE FACT THAT.
SO WITH THE WAY THE ELECTRIC
SIDE WORKS IS I THINK IT'S 15%
FOR RATE PAYER BENEFIT.
AND WE'RE SAYING YES THE PC
PROGRAMS WE THINK CAN DO A LOT
MORE TO ADVANCE THAT REPAIR
BENEFIT KNOWING STACK UP THE
REMAINING EIGHTY FIVE BUT THAT
IS A PUBLIC POLICY CHOICE YOU
GOTTA MAKE LIKE.
WOULD IT WE JUST BE BETTER OFF
GIVEN ALL THESE DOLLARS BACK.
I I JUST I THINK ESPECIALLY FOR
HOMEOWNERS.
WE'VE GOT HELP THEM GET ALONG
BECAUSE THAT INITIAL CAPITAL
COSTS OF GETTING THAT ELECTRIC
HEAT PUMP HIM AT THAT DECISION
THAT'S GONNA SAVE YOU MONEY IN
THE LONG TERM.
IT'S NOT IT'S IT'S I MEAN I
PRISON THE MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM
COULD DO IT.
BUT MIDDLE CLASS HOMEOWNERS --
THEY'RE NOT DO IT AND THOSE THE
PEOPLE OR LOOK AT THIS CHAIR OF
I CAN JUST TO ADD A COMMENT THEN
YOU BACK ON YOUR THAT.
BEGINNING THE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT CAP AND TRADE ON THE
ASSEMBLY REPUBLICANS OF THE TIME
PUT OUR PRINCIPLES TOGETHER AND
OF THOSE PRINCIPLES --
BY ALMOST EVERYTHING BACK WE GOT
EVERYTHING EXCEPT FOR THE ONE
THING AND THE ONE THING IS WE
WERE TO TAKE THE ENTIRETY.
OF OF THE THAT THE AUCTION
REVENUES --
TO CONSUMERS AND THE ONE THING
WE SORT OF HUNGER HAD AT LEAST
IS A LITTLE BIT --
THAT WE'RE GIVING BACK TO
CONSUMERS IT SEEMS LIKE NOW
WE'RE DECIDING THAT WE'RE GONNA
MAKE THE DECISION ON HOW THAT
MONIES SPENT AND SAID ABOUT
MONEY.
GOING BACK CONSUMER SO I LIKE
THE PROGRAM --
I CAN'T SUPPORT IT TODAY BECAUSE
IT OF THAT I GET IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY THAT FIRST OF ALL LET ME
JUST SAY CENTER I APPRECIATE
YOUR WORKING WITH US ON THIS END
UP TO THIS POINT IT HAS BEEN.
CERTAINLY VERY THE COMMITTEE'S
POSITION THAT --
RECOGNIZING ON ELECTRIC SIDE
THERE WAS WITH DECISIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE THERE WAS NOTHING
LEFT AND SO.
WE DIDN'T WANT.
TO OVER COMMIT OR CERTAINLY
COMMIT IN AN AREA WHERE THERE
WOULD BE PRESSURE POINTS AND
THEN POTENTIALLY HAVE IMPACT ON
REPAIRS SO WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHERE THERE WAS
RESOURCES THAT WE COULD DRAW
UPON THEM EFFECTIVELY.
AND YES THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT OPTIONS OUT THERE BUT
THEN OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT INTERESTS THAT.
ARE ABSOLUTE TARGETED TO THOSE
THEIR DOLLARS AS WELL YEAH --
BUT WE DO --
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH US
AND THE DESIRE TO SEE THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD AND THE GOOD WORK
AGAIN THAT YOU'RE DOING AND WILL
WRECK PROCEDURE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL --
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THIS OVERALL HOLDEN PIKE HOLDEN
AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE REYES.
REYES AYE SANTIAGO.
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT BELIEVE THE
BRELO.
WELL LET'S SEE I SEE --
SENATOR MINING.
YOU ARE HERE AND WE ARE READY
FOR YOU.
MOVE THIS WONDERFUL TERRIFIC
[inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
OKAY SENATOR WE ARE --
HERE TO YOUR FILE ITEM SIX SP.
TEN NINETY THIS IS THE DO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY I WANT TO START BY
THANKING YOUR STAFF FOR THE
EXCELLENT COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES
THAT I THINK CAPTURES THE
ESSENCE OF WHY WE'RE HERE WITH
THIS LEGISLATION --
I'M JOINED AS YOU KNOW BY YOUR
MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM THERE'S A CO AUTHOR
WITH ME AND OFFER A BRIEF
OPENING STATEMENT AND HE
FOLLOWED BY HIM AND THEN WITH
PERMISSION XANDER WITNESSES --
MEMBERS ON JANUARY ELEVENTH OF
THIS YEAR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION APPROVED P.
JANIE'S REQUEST TO RETIRE DIABLO
CANYON BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE I TOWARD
DISAPPOINTMENT THEY DID NOT
APPROVE THE COMMUNITY IMPACT
MITIGATION PROGRAM POOR FULLY
FUND THE EMPLOYEE RETENTION
PROGRAM THAT ARE VITAL
COMPONENTS TO THE SUCCESS OF THE
PLANTS RETIREMENT.
IN THE CONTINUED PUBLIC SAFETY
OF THE REGION.
BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS WILL
PROVIDE A BRIDGE TO OUR REGION
AS THE TRANSITION.
A CLOSURE OF THE APPLE CANYON
MOVES FORWARD.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW.
THE DECISION TO CLOSE THE PLAN
HAS BEEN MADE THIS BILL IS NOT
ABOUT THAT DECISION.
S. B. TEN NINETY AUTHORIZES THE
P. YOU SEE TO APPROVE ELEMENTS
OF THE JOINT PROPOSAL.
THAT WAS SUBMITTED AS PART OF
THE RETIREMENT APPLICATION
INCLUDING EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE COMMUNITY IMPACT
MITIGATION PROGRAM REQUIRES FULL
FUNDING IN THE EMPLOYEE
RETENTION PROGRAM.
AND DIRECTS THE PC TO MANAGE ITS
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLAN TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS NO INCREASE
OF GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AS A
RESULT OF THE RETIREMENT OF THE
PLANT.
COMMUNITY HAS ASSUMED THE PUBLIC
RISK FOR THE PAST THIRTY THREE
YEARS WHILE ALL P. JEANNINE
CUSTOMERS HAVE REALIZED THE
BENEFITS OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
DECADES AND WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE ENERGY.
OVER THE NEXT SEVEN YEARS --
UNTIL FINAL DECOMMISSIONING.
ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY RISK IF I
COULD JUST HOLD THIS UP AND SHOW
MEMBERS.
EVERY YEAR P. JEANNIE HANDS OUT
THIS CALENDAR TO ALL THE
RESIDENTS OF SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY NORTHERN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY [inaudible]
THE BACK.
FAMILY EVACUATION PLAN EVERYONE
WHO LIVES IN THE REGION HAS TO
HAVE AN EVACUATION PLAN LOCAL
PUBLIC SAFETY RUN ROUTINE.
EVACUATION DRILLS FIRE POLICE
HIGHWAY PATROL NATIONAL GUARD.
THERE'S ALSO AN INSERT.
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO MAIL IN. FOUR
YEAR ALLOCATION.
IT'S HASSIUM IODIDE.
MOST FAMILIES IN SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY SINCE FUKUSHIMA NOW STOCK
POTASSIUM IODIDE IN THEIR
MEDICINE CABINETS IN THE EVENT
OF A LEAK.
SINCE THE COMMISSIONING OF
DIABLO CANYON ABOUT ALL THE
SPENT RODS ARE KEPT ON SITE IN
CASKETS.
AND WILL POSE AN ONGOING
SECURITY RESPONSIBILITY.
P. GENIE IN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
AND WHILE THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
HAS ASSUME THESE RISKS.
ALL PEACHY ANY CUSTOMERS HAVE
RECEIVED THE OUTPUT FROM DIABLO
AND WILL CONTINUE TO OVER THE
NEXT SEVEN YEARS.
SO MEMBERS THE COMMUNITY
INCLUDING STAKEHOLDERS THAT
REPRESENT LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SCHOOLS IMPEACHING HAVE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME NEGOTIATING THE
JOINT PROPOSAL.
I PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR
ASSEMBLYMAN JORDAN CUNNINGHAM
WILL NOW VOICE HIS SUPPORT AND
SHARE A FEW COMMENTS WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
AND THEN LAST THE CHAIR FOR
PERMISSION TO PRESENT OUR
WITNESSES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE
I'D ECHO EVERYTHING THE SENATOR
SAID.
AND I WANT TO COME A MOMENT TO
FOCUS A LITTLE BIT ON THAT THE
WORK FORCE AND THE WORKERS THE
DIABLO CANYON.
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF THEM TO
NOT JUST OUR COMMUNITY BUT TO TO
OUR STATE AS A WHOLE.
THIS IS.
A FACILITY THAT OPERATES WITH
THE STRICTEST POSSIBLE SECURITY
YOU CAN IMAGINE I'VE TOURED IT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A BACKGROUND
CHECK. TO EVEN ENTER THE
FACILITY.
THE WORKERS THAT WORK THERE.
WORK THAT YOU CANNOT FIND A MORE
SKILLED.
HIGHLY TRAINED COMPETENT.
S. THEY WORK. TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
THREE SIXTY FIVE THEY KEEP THIS
FACILITY RUNNING.
SAFELY AND SECURELY THE SECURITY
FORCE.
IT'S MILITARY GRADE SECURITY
THAT PROTECTS IT.
FROM ANY KIND OF ATTACK OR
ANYBODY THAT WOULD ENGAGE IN
FOUL PLAY.
THESE FOLKS HAVE BEEN DOING THIS
FLAWLESSLY FOR DECADES.
THEY'RE ALSO THE FIRST
RESPONDERS IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT
OF SOME SORT INCIDENT.
SOME SORT OF WEEK SOME SORT OF
EVENT ATTACK WHAT HAVE YOU.
THEY'RE THE FIRST PEOPLE THERE.
DEAD PEOPLE BEAR THAT RISK EVERY
SINGLE DAY THEY'RE NOT PLAN.
AND THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THAT TO
THE STATE CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED
THIS ONE FACILITY IS 10% OF OUR
STATE'S ELECTRICITY. 10% CARBON
FREE THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
DAYS A YEAR.
AND IF I COULD SAY WHAT I THINK
HAPPENED TO THOSE WORKERS.
BEING PROMISED A CERTAIN THING.
AND HAVING THAT REDUCED WAS
UNFAIR.
I THINK IT'S UNFAIR TO BE TOLD
IF YOU STATE YOU'RE GONNA GET
BONUS ACTS.
SO THAT YOU COMMIT TO STAYING TO
KEEP THIS FACILITY RUNNING.
YOU CAN'T RUN NUCLEAR FACILITY
PERHAPS.
THERE'S NO WAY.
AND YOU CAN GET WORKERS FROM OUT
OF STATE TO MOVE SOMEWHERE
THAT'S GONNA CLOSE.
THAT'S A DIFFICULT THING TO DO.
AND THEY WERE PROMISED ACTS AND
THEY GOT REDUCED I THINK THAT
WAS UNFAIR I THINK IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE IT RIGHT
IT'S GOOD FOR THE ENTIRE STATE
BECAUSE WE NEED THE FOR THIS
FACILITY. TO OPERATE THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE NEED IT
FOR THE ENERGY WE NEED FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT NEED FOR WORKFORCE.
WE NEED THE THE POWER.
AT THIS POINT PROVIDES FOR SEVEN
YEARS GIVES US A CHANCE A RUNWAY
[inaudible]
AN OPPORTUNITY.
FIGURE OUT HOW TO REPLACE. 10%
OF CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRICITY.
WITH CARBON FREE [inaudible]
GENERATION.
I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER TO HOW DO
THAT TODAY.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM. TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THAT I I
WANT TO SEE IT HAPPEN.
BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT IF WE
DON'T HAVE A SECURE AND RELIABLE
WORKFORCE [inaudible]
PAT DIABLO.
ON SITE AT THE POST.
INTEL TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE'VE
GOT BIG PROBLEMS.
SO ON BEHALF OF THE WORKERS IN
OUR COMMUNITY I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
AND PLEASE SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND SOME A MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM AND SIR MONEY WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA AND YOU'RE A
COMMUNITIES WILL REPRESENT --
YOUR WITNESS MISTER CHAIRMAN THE
MEMBER SCOTT WHICH OF IF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES I HAVE WITH ME A
WITNESS.
TO TALK OF SPECIFICALLY TO SOME
OF THE ISSUES I HAVE STATEMENT I
WAS GOING TO SAY.
AND I CAN'T ADD A SINGLE THING
TO WHAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUTTING
HIM JUST SAID INSTALLED FOR MY
COMMENTS.
OF A SIMILAR CUNNINGHAM WILL
HAVE TO BRING YOU BACK MORE
OFTEN.
TO I PRAISE HIM.
ABOUT DAVE IV EVERY TWELVE FORTY
FIVE AND I ECHO THE COMMENTS AND
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS.
FROM THE ASSEMBLYMAN.
SO THE WORKERS THAT DABBLE
CANYON.
REPRESENTED BY.
TWELVE FORTY FIVE ARE RUNNING
THE MOST SAFE NUCLEAR POWER
PLANT IN THE NATION.
NAY DO THAT BY MASSIVE AMOUNTS
OF TIME AND EFFORT SPENT ON
TRAINING THE ABSOLUTELY CANNOT
BE REPLACED WITH THE TEMPORARY
WORKFORCE.
THERE PROMISED THAT IF THE STATE
THOSE WHO WOULD RETIRE NOW. TO
FURTHER RETIREMENT TO KEEP THE
PLANT THE PLANT RUNNING THOSE
WHO ARE YOUNG WOULD NOT LEAVE
BECAUSE OF THE STRUCTURE THAT WE
NEGOTIATED WITH PGE.
THERE WAS STATE RETAIN THE BONUS
SO WE WOULD LOOK FOR THEM JOBS.
IN THE FUTURE.
THE STRUCTURE OF THIS IN THE
PROMISE OF THIS WE BELIEVE.
IT WAS DONE IN GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATION OF PIGEON ANY TOM
DOES ALL OF MYSELF.
THEY WOULD KEEP THE PLANT
RUNNING AT THE SAME QUALITY THAT
IS RUNNING TODAY THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE KEEP THAT
JEANETTE GHG FREE ENERGY THAT
SAFETY THAT LEVEL OF SAFETY FOR
THAT COMMUNITY.
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE
BELIEVE THAT IT WAS.
DEFINITELY UNFAIR PRICE STRONGER
THAN UNFAIR TO REDUCE THAT --
WHEN WAS BARGAINING GOOD FAITH?
WE HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE TO KEEP
PEOPLE WHO ARE GONNA RETIRE
THERE WE HAVE A PLAN TO KEEP
YOUNGER WORKERS WHO ARE ALSO
VITAL BOTH TO THE COMMUNITY AND
TO DIE WE CAN.
KEEP THEM THERE ALL AT THE PLAN
AND TO THEN RETAIN THEM GOING
FORWARD.
WE SPELL LOT OF TIME WITH BOTH
OF THESE GROUPS IN ADVANCE OF
THIS NEGOTIATION. TO FIND OUT
WHAT IS IT GONNA TAKE WHAT IS
GOING TO TAKE TO KEEP YOU HERE
WHAT IS GOING TO TAKE YOU TO RUN
OTHER NUCLEAR POWER PLANTS ARE
OFFERING HUGE BONUSES FOR YOU TO
COME THERE.
WHAT'S IT GONNA TAKE YOU FROM
LEAVING THE INDUSTRY OR TO GO
OTHER PLACES THESE ARE HIGHLY
QUALIFIED WORKERS.
WHO HAVE OTHER PLACES THEY CAN
EASILY GO INSIDE THE INDUSTRY?
THE PROBLEM IS THAT PLANT CANNOT
RUN WITH THE WITHOUT THESE VITAL
PEOPLE DOING VERY SPECIFIC TASKS.
THAT THEY THAT THEY'VE BEEN
TRAINED SOMETIMES FOR HALF A
DECADE TO BECOME JOURNEYMAN. TO
RUN THAT PLAN SO IT IS VITAL AYE
THE FOR THAT.
PLAN AND FOR THE STATE TO KEEP
THOSE PEOPLE THERE IN THE
PROMISES THAT THEY WERE MADE.
AND ACTUALLY AND I THINK WITH
THAT AGAIN I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS IN THE LOCAL.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN
PER SHAUN ON THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY.
A SENATE BILL TEN NINETY HAS
BEEN CONSTRUCTED AS A THREE
LEGGED STOOL TO MAINTAIN THE
SAFE AND SECURE OPERATION OF THE
PLANT.
THROUGH TO ITS RETIREMENT.
THE BRIDGE FUNDING PROVIDED BY
THE COMMUNITY IMPACT MITIGATION
PROGRAM.
IS AT LEAST AS IMPORTANT AS THE
TWO OTHER LEGS.
P. JEANNIE AND I DON'T STE IN
JUNE OF TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT IT
WOULD NOT SEEK TO RENEW THE
FEDERAL LICENSE OF DIABLO CANYON
UNITS ONE AND TWO WHEN THOSE
LICENSES EXPIRE 242-024-2020.
FIVE ALTHOUGH PGP JEANNIE HAS
NEGOTIATED CLOSURE TERMS TO SOME
OF THE PARTIES AND HAVE INCLUDED
COMMUNITY MITIGATION FUNDING THE
FORTY NINE MILLION IN THAT
SETTLEMENT --
IT SOON BECAME CLEAR THAT THE
FORTY NINE MILLION WASN'T AN
ADEQUATE NUMBER TO MAINTAIN
SERVICES DURING THE NINE YOUR
CLOSURE PERIOD.
SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY SAN LUIS
OBISPO A COASTAL UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE SEVEN CITIES
BEGAN MEETING WITH P. GENIE IN
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION. TO
TRY AND DETERMINE.
THE TRUE EFFECT OF THE DECISION
TO SET THE PLANT RETIREMENT DATE
IN THE END WE ARRIVE AT A FIGURE
OF EIGHTY FIVE MILLION TO BE
COLLECTED AS PART OF THE RATES
OVER A NINE YEAR PERIOD.
THE COMMUNITY IMPACT MITIGATION
FUND HAS TWO COMPONENTS THE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES MITIGATION
FUND WILL CONSIST OF SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
AND A DOES IT IS DESIGNED TO
SUSTAIN ESSENTIAL SERVICES AT
CURRENT LEVELS.
THE SERVICES TO BE FUNDED
INCLUDE THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROGRAMS FIRE DISTRICTS WATER
AND FLOOD CONTROL DISTRICT'S.
INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTENANCE AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND SCHOOL
STAFF.
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT FUND OF
TEN MILLION DOLLARS DOLLARS IS
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE SEED FUNDING
FOR EARLY IN TARGETED LOCAL
ECONOMIC REDEVELOPMENT BY THE
COUNTY FOURTH SEVEN CITIES.
AND IT'S CRITICAL THAT THE
PLANTS HOST COMMUNITY BEGIN
RESTRUCTURING ITS ECONOMY BEFORE
THE PLANT IS CLOSE.
TO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE
COMMUNITY IMPACT MITIGATION FUND
IS BRIDGE FUNDING TO ALLOW SAFE
PLANT OPERATION BY EXPERIENCED
AND YOU AS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY
VERY EXPERIENCE DIABLO EMPLOYEES
UNTIL PLANNED RETIREMENT.
EMPLOYEE RETENTION IS ESSENTIAL
FOR DIABLO CANYON BECAUSE EACH
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT HAS UNIQUE
OPERATING [inaudible]
REQUIREMENTS OUR PLAN ALLOWS THE
EXISTING EXPERIENCED WORKFORCE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO AVOID LEAVING
FOR BETTER JOBS OF PLANTS THAT
ARE NOT PLAYING TO CLOSE.
THESE EMPLOYEES WILL BE ASSISTED
WITH THE EMPLOYEE RETENTION
COMPONENTS OF THIS BILL BUT THEY
NEED TO BE ASSURED.
THAT THE COMMUNITY WILL CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE THEIR FAMILIES WITH
DECENT EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
AND NECESSARY PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE RATE PAYERS WILL SEE A SMALL
INCREASE IN THEIR ENERGY BILLS A
FEW CENTS PER MONTH BUT THE
PROGRAM DOES NOT GO INTO
PERPETUITY.
THE RATE INCREASE WILL BE IN
EFFECT FOR ABOUT EIGHT YEARS
THIS ISN'T EQUITABLE BRIDGE
FUNDING SUPPORT PROVISION FOR
THE COMMUNITY THAT HAS SUPPORTED
THE PLANT THROUGH ITS ENTIRE
OPERATING LIFE.
AND WILL SUPPORT THE SPENT FUEL%
FACILITY OF THE PLANT FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
BUT WILL ENTERTAIN THE NEXT
SPEAKERS A NAME AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TELLING THE HUNTER ON BEHALF OF
THE ST LOUIS COASTAL UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT THANK YOU TO OUR
CHAMPIONS [inaudible]
SECURE SUPPORT.
SURE MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT THINK.
A MARIN AMBIANCE HERE COULD
CALIFORNIANS WORK.
CHAU BECKER LINESMAN NUCLEAR
RESPONSIBILITY WHO IS BASED IN
SANTA CPAS BUT THE FALL OUTS ARE.
AT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
SALAS LIKE ON BEHALF P. JIMMY
AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
RICHARD ONLY HALF THE CITY OF
PERSONAL BEACH IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PLUG INS OFFICE HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ATASCADERO AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BUT YOU ARE IS THERE ANYONE HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSAL
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MATT FRIEDMAN REPRESENTING
THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK WE
WERE AN ACTIVE PARTY IN THE
PRECEDING CONSIDERING P. GENIES
PROPOSAL.
TO CLOSE DIABLO CANYON AT THE
END OF ITS CURRENT LICENSE.
AND WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT S. B.
TEN NINETY WHICH WOULD FORCE THE
PEA YOU SEE TO REYES PGD
CUSTOMER RATES BY. TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
TO COLLECT FUNDS FOR ADDITIONAL
EMPLOYEERETENTION PAYMENTS AND
SUPPLEMENTAL CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
IN THE RECENT PROCEEDING
CONSIDERING P. GENIES
APPLICATION THE P. DID AUTHORIZE
TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EMPLOYEE RETENTION
PAYMENTS OUT OF THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY TWO MILLION THAT WAS
REQUESTED BY P. GENIE.
AND AFTER CONSIDERING THE
EVIDENCE THE COMMISSION FOUND
THAT QUOTE P. GENIUS PROPOSAL
APPEARS TO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
FREE RIDER PROBLEM THAT P.
JEANNIE DOES NOT ADDRESS AND AS
SUCH.
PROPOSAL IS OVERLY GENEROUS WITH
REPAIR FUNDING.
ON THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY
DOESN'T ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS
AND WOULD REQUIRE A HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN NEW
RATE INCREASES WITHOUT ANY
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE COMMISSION
TO CONSIDER.
THE REASONABLENESS OF THESE
PAYMENTS.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO FORCE THE PC
TO INCREASE PEKINGESE CUSTOMER
RATES BY EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A SERIES OF NEW
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT WERE NEGOTIATED
BETWEEN P. JEANNIE AND THOSE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THE CONTRIBUTIONS INCLUDE SIXTY
FIVE MILLION FOR LOCAL CITIES
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR AN EDUCATIONAL
FOUNDATION THAT DOESN'T HAVE ANY
DETAILED DESCRIPTION OF THE
SETTLEMENT.
AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR AN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPMENT
FUND THAT ALSO LACKS ANY
SPECIFICITY.
I'M TURN DOESN'T BELIEVE THAT
REPAIRS HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
MAKE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT PAYMENTS
TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES EVERY TIME
A MAJOR UTILITY ASSET IS REMOVED
FROM SERVICE.
SINCE THE PLANT WAS FIRST
COMMISSION IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
AWARE THAT DIABLO CANYON WAS
SCHEDULED TO CLOSE AT THE END OF
ITS CURRENT LICENSE.
THE RECENT PEW SEE DECISION ONLY
REINFORCES THIS PRE EXISTING
EXPECTATION.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT S. B. TEN
NINETY WOULD OPEN THE DOOR TO
EVERY OTHER COMMUNITY AFFECTED
BY A PLANT CLOSURE TO SEEKS
SIMILAR SUPPORT PAYMENTS.
THAT WOULD BE FINANCED THROUGH
RATE INCREASES ON ALL CUSTOMERS.
WE HAVE OFFERED TO ALTERNATIVES
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
ABOUT ONE WE WOULD PROPOSE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
AUTHORIZING MONEY FROM THE
STATE'S GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
THE COMMUNITY PAYMENTS IF IT IS
INDEED A STATEWIDE OBLIGATION
IT'S WE PAID BY ALL THE
TAXPAYERS [inaudible]
SECOND THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
CONDITION ANY RATE PAIR FUNDING
ON EQUIVALENT CONTRIBUTION FOR
P. GENIES OWN SHAREHOLDERS THAT
HAVE REALIZE SUBSTANTIAL PROFITS
FROM THE OWNERSHIP OF THE
FACILITY OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
DECADES.
SO WHILE WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
RETIREMENT OF THIS PLANT WILL
HAVE IMPACTS IN THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES.
THE LEGISLATURE MUST RECOGNIZE
THAT THE LOCAL ECONOMIC BENEFITS
OF DIABLO CANYON WILL NOT END
WHEN THE FACILITY SHUTS DOWN IN.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AT THAT POINT
B. GENIE WILL BEGIN A DECADES
LONG EFFORT TO DECOMMISSION THE
PLANT AT AN ESTIMATED COST OF
OVER TWO AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS INCLUDING.
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN EMPLOYEE SEVERANCE
BENEFITS WE BELIEVE THAT THAT
PROJECT IS GOING TO REQUIRE A
SIGNIFICANT LOCAL WORKFORCE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE JOBS
AND ECONOMIC ACTIVITY TO THE
REGION. FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE AND FOR THAT REASON WE
EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
I'M MY NAME IS SET DOCTOR JEAN
NELSON FROM SAN LUIS OBISPO IVA
PITCHING RADIATION BIOPHYSICS
AND I'M SPEAKING FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR GREEN NUCLEAR
POWER.
INCORRECTLY LISTED AS A
SUPPORTER IN THE ANALYSIS AS OUR
NAME SUGGEST CGMP IS A NONPROFIT
COMPOSED OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
APPRECIATE THE ADVANTAGES OF
NUCLEAR POWER PROVIDED FOR
RATEPAYERS AND THE ENVIRONMENT
CGMP INCLUDE SCIENTISTS AND
ENGINEERS.
WHO ARE SPECIALISTS IN THEIR
FIELD EACH WITH DECADES OF
EXPERIENCE CGMP TIMELY FILED A
CPUC APPLICATION FOR REHEARING A
PEACHY MEANS CONTROVERSIAL
APPLICATION TO ABANDON DIABLO
CANYON FOR THAT REASON THE CPUC
WEBSITE?
NOW SHOWS THAT THE P. GENIE
APPLICATION IS RE OPENED.
ANTICIPATE PREVAILING ON THE
MERITS OF OUR CASE OUR LEAD
ATTORNEY IS UP OF FORMER
ASSEMBLYMAN MIKE GADO.
OUT WERE NEW LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
BUT WE STEPPED FORWARD TO HELP
POLICY MAKERS MAKE WISE
DECISIONS BASED ON SCIENCE AND
FACT NOT FEAR MONGERING.
OUR DECISIONS THAT OUR
DESCENDANTS WILL RESPECT WE MUST
OPPOSE SB TEN NINETY UNLESS
AMENDED FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASONS.
ON APRIL ELEVENTH HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH SENATE EQ SEE
CONSULTANT DOCTOR DAVID GARCIA
AND HE AGREED BASED ON MY
ANALYSIS THAT REPLACING TABLE
CAN WITH OTHER CARBON FREE
ENERGY.
WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE IT IS
SCIENTIFICALLY IMPOSSIBLE.
SO I'M GONNA KIND OF SKIPPED
GROUP BECAUSE WE HAVE TAPPED
HAVE A LITTLE LESS TIME MARTY
COULD YOU TAKE OVER --
S. B. S. SO I'M I'M DOCTOR
MICHAEL MERRIMACK VOLUNTEERING
MY TIME ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD BE NUCLEAR
POWER AND I'M NOT REPRESENTING
MY EMPLOYER.
S. B. TEN NINETY CONTAINS AN
OPERATIVE LEGISLATIVE FINDINGS
WHICH HAVE NO EFFECT IS LA.
THE LANGUAGE IN THOSE FINDINGS
IF IS A FIG LEAF FOR THE WEEKEND
VERY MENTAL LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL'S ONLY OPERATIVE SECTION
THAT'S ACT LANGUAGE IN SECTION.
TWO ONLY MANDATES THAT THE CPUC
PLANS REQUIRES PLANS THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO AVOID INCREASED
EMISSIONS.
IT DOES NOT REQUIRE ANYONE TO
SHOW THE DIABOLO WILL BE
REPLACED WITH CLEAN POWER.
AND POSSIBLE COMPANIES STORAGE
NUCLEAR POWER IS ALREADY SAFE
CLEAN STORAGE EMPOWER.
AND CAL OR AYE AYE SOONER
CITIZENS DEPEND UPON THESE FACTS
NOT ILLUSORY PLANS.
SP TEN NINETY FORCES RATE PAYERS
TO FOOT THE BILLS FOR PRIVATE
COMPANIES BUSINESS DECISIONS.
WHAT REASON WILL YOU GIVE YOUR
CONSTITUENTS FOR VOTING FOR THIS
GIVEAWAY PREPARE SHOULD NOT PUT
THE BILL FOR P. JEANNIE'S
DECISION TO ABANDON A RESOURCE
WITH AN EXEMPLARY SAFETY RECORD?
AND DECADES OF REMINDING EVER
MADE IN LIFE.
THE CLOSURE OF DABBLE CAN IT IS
NOT SOMETHING THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD ENDORSE.
GIVENCALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE THE
WISDOM OF ABANDONING
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST CARBON FREE
ENERGY SOURCE CONTINUES TO BE
CHALLENGED.
BY ENGINEERS CLIMATOLOGIST
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND LOCAL
RESIDENTS THEIR BOOK CANON
PRODUCES ONE TENTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S TOTAL ANNUAL
ELECTRICITY NEEDS ECONOMICALLY.
AND GREENHOUSE GAS FREE.
NOTED CLIMATE SCIENTIST DR JAMES
HANSEN IS PUBLISHED ESTIMATE
THAT ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
LIVES HAVE BEEN SAVED.
BY THE REDUCTION IN AIR
POLLUTION ACHIEVED BY NUCLEAR
PLANTS WORLDWIDE.
SP TEN NINETY WILL JUST RESULT
IN SHUFFLING EXISTING GREENHOUSE
GAS RESOURCES AND IMPROPER
RELIANCE UPON CCA'S.
UNLIKE SOLAR AND WIND PREAMBLE
CANYON IS A RELIABLE SUPPLY OF
ESSENTIAL BASELOAD POWER.
TAKING GAVEL OFFLINE WOULD
RESULT IN BURNING MORE FOSSIL
FUELS TO MEET THAT NEED THIS
WOULD RESULT IN SEVEN MILLION
TIMES MORE CO TWO EMISSIONS
ANNUALLY.
AND HAVE TO HAVE A LOOK
CONTINUED OPERATING THAT'S ONE
HUNDRED MILLION TONS OVER THE
TWENTY YEAR RELICENSING PERIOD.
PJ ANY TESTIFIED THAT MUCH OF
THE REPLACEMENT POWER FOR DIABLO
CANYON WOULD BE GENERATED BY
UNREGULATED COMMUNITY CHURCH
AGGREGATORS.
BUT THERE IS NO WAY FOR CPUC TO
ENFORCE THAT THEY WOULD NEED THE
ENORMOUS CHALLENGE.
GAS
AND SINCE THE SERIES ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO AUDIT THEIR SOURCES
THERE'S NO MECHANISM TO VERIFY
ANY CLAIM REGARDING THE KIND YOU
CAN YOU BRING YOUR COMMENTS SO I
WE HAVE IN STOCK EVERY
AMENDMENTS.
WEEK IF WE COULD THAT YOU SHOULD
A SAID THAT AT THE EARLY PART
TEN SECONDS.
SO IT PAGE ANY TRULY BELIEVES
THAT HAVE A CAN AND TO BE
RELEASED WITH REPLACEMENT PRE
LAST POWER PRE POWER.
THEY SHOULD HAVE NO REQUIRE LOW
ISSUE WITH LEGISLATIVE WRITTEN
LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES KEEP YOU
SEE TO DETERMINE THIS CAN BE
DONE CONCLUSIVELY.
BEFORE PROVING THAT THE PLANT
CLOSED [inaudible]
HERE TO HAVE A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL SAY NINE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO DIE ARE
THERE ANY COMMENTS FROM.
MISTER MASON DOCTOR QUIRK.
YOU KNOW YOU GO [inaudible]
GREAT JOB --
BY YOU GUYS ARE TO BE APPLAUDED
FOR THIS WORK --
THIS IS --
WHAT GOVERNING IS ALL ABOUT --
ON A PERSONAL NOTE I'VE ACTUALLY
VISITED AT THAT FACILITY I THINK
IT'S A FANTASTIC FACILITY I WAS
INCREDIBLY DISAPPOINTED WHEN I
HEARD.
THAT IT WAS GOING TO BE SHUT
DOWN I WISH THAT IT WASN'T GOING
TO BE SHUT DOWN BUT THAT'S NOT A
DECISION.
THAT WE'RE MAKING HERE TODAY
THAT DECISION HAS ALREADY.
BEEN MADE OF IF WE COULD KEEP IT
OPEN WE WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
KEEP IT OPEN UP THAT DECISIONS
ALREADY.
HAVE BEEN MADE I DON'T KNOW OF
ANY OTHER WAY TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THIS SOMBER TALK ABOUT A
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT AND YOU GOT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU GOT
WORKERS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
THERE.
THIS IS THE BEST WAY BY THING TO
DO THAT DUH COULD JUST YOU GUYS
FOR FOR YOUR HARD WORK WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY.
DUCT WORK.
THAT THAT DECISION TO SHUT DOWN
THE NUCLEAR PLANT WAS A BUSINESS
DECISION ON THE PART OF PGA NEED
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT A VERY
DIFFICULT RENEWAL.
IN ADDITION THEY DON'T REALLY
NEED POWER BECAUSE THE CCA'S
HAVE TAKEN OVER SO MUCH SO I DO
AGREE WITH THE COMMENT FROM ONE
OF THE EXPERTS THAT.
IN FACT IT'LL BE THE CCA CIVIL
BE LOOKING FOR REPLACEMENT POWER
AND THAT THERE'S NO GUARANTEE.
ARE OF WHAT TYPE OF ENERGY THAT
WILL COME OUT WITH HOWEVER --
KNOWING ALL THE CCA'S THERE
GONNA TRY AND AND AND MAXIMIZE
THE AMOUNT OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
DAY YEAH --
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO BALANCE
THEIR LOAD SO THEY WILL ALSO BE
DOING THAT SO I THINK THERE IS A
UNANSWERED WHAT WILL HAPPEN --
IN EFFECT IT MAY NOT BE ENTIRELY
REPLACEMENT BY RENEWABLES BUT OF
THE CCA SWELL.
THAT'LL BE ACTUALLY THE ONES
TRYING TO PROCURE THE NEW POWER.
AS THAT PLANT GOES DOWN OUT WILL
A LARGE MAN [inaudible]
RENEWABLES THANK YOU
[inaudible]
IT'S MERCER'S.
CEREMONY GOT PROCEED --
TO YOU ARE REACHING OUT TO ME TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS I
JUST WANTED --
TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER THERE.
MAYBE ANY OTHER ALTERNATIVE AND
AND AND YOU MENTIONED THAT ON
THE WHITE NOT THE SHAREHOLDERS
Y. THE RATEPAYERS.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
TAKING.
THE TIME TO MEET WITH ME EARLIER.
SO SIMPLY STATED --
I THINK I'LL.
A NUMBER OF US IF WE HAD THE
OPTION OF ASKING SHAREHOLDERS TO
PAY FOR THIS THAT MIGHT BE A
MORE ATTRACTIVE OPTION.
FACT OF THE MATTER IS ALL COURT
PRECEDENT.
SHAREHOLDERS NEVER GET ASKED TO
CONTRIBUTE TO A SOLUTION IF YOU
DON'T HAVE PROOF OF NEGLIGENCE
MALFEASANCE MISMANAGEMENT.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE IT'S A
BUSINESS DECISION TO CLOSE THE
FACILITY WITH THE LOCAL IMPACTS
HAS DISCUSSED.
BUT IT DOES THEN RAISED THE
QUESTION THAT WE DISCUSSED IS
THAT APPROPRIATE FOR RATEPAYERS.
TO BE ASKED SHOULDER THE COST OF
OF THE DECOMMISSIONING AND
SUPPORT THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
THAT'S BEEN REACHED UP BY THE
PARTIES.
AND A WHILE I RESPECT THE WORK
THAT TURNED US IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIAN THEIR ADVOCACY FOR
RATEPAYERS.
THIS IS A UNIQUE SITUATION THIS
IS THE LAST OPERATING NUCLEAR
FACILITY IN THE STATE.
UNLIKE SANTA NO FREE THAT WAS ON
A MILITARY INSTALLATION AND AND
AMOUNTED TO A MUCH SMALLER PART
OF THE ECONOMY OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
THIS IS THE NUMBER ONE EMPLOYER
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY.
PEOPLE OF SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY
NORTHERN SANTA BARBARA HAVE
SHOULDERED THE RISK AND EVERY P.
JEANNIE RATE PAIR.
HAS BEEN THE BENEFICIARY OF THE
ENERGY PRODUCED AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE. FOR A FINITE
PERIOD OF TIME OVER THERE EIGHT
YEARS WITH AN AVERAGE FAMILY
INCREASE OF TWENTY THREE CENTS
[inaudible]
PER MONTH IT'S A DE MINIMUS BE
SHARED BY ALL BENEFICIARIES OF
P. GENIE --
ENERGY PRODUCTION IT WILL HAVE
THE DESIRED EFFECT OF MINIMIZING
CREATING A GLIDE PATH FOR THE
RECONVERSION OF THE ECONOMY IN
SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY.
AND PRIMARILY IN FOREMOST BY
RETAINING SKILLED WORKERS
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
NOT JUST TO THAT REGION.
BUT REALLY THE WHOLE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
THANK.
THANK YOU CENTER MY NAME AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM THIS
IS --
CLEARLY A VERY IMPORTANT BILL TO
THE PEOPLE OF SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY AND OF BRING STABILITY TO
THE AREA. TO THE JOBS AND
EMPLOYMENT IN THAT IN THAT AREA
AROUND DIABLO. FOR THE COMMUNITY
AT LARGE SO WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE THEIR GOOD WORK
AND THERE NO OTHER.
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
I WILL TURN TWO ONE OF YOU WERE
BOTH OF YOU FOR CLOTHES YEAH HA
STARTIN IN MY COLLEAGUE MAIN
ALSO I SHARE SOME COMMENTS VERY
BRIEFLY I PREACH I THINK WE'VE
HAD A COMPREHENSIVE.
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE ISSUES --
I WOULD SUBMIT THAT WHILE.
WE BRING THIS SOME FOR THE
PROTECTION IMMEDIATELY OF THE
PEOPLE OF SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY.
IT'S REALLY TO PROTECT THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND A
FINAL COMMENT ON THE REPLACEMENT
ENERGY.
WELL WE UNDERSTAND NUCLEAR
ENERGY TO BE CLEAN ENERGY IN
TERMS OF GREENHOUSE GAS IMPACTS.
IT'S NOT CLEAN IN TERMS OF THE
WASTE THAT'S LEFT BEHIND AND
THAT'S PART OF THE HIGH COST OF
CONTINUING TO OPERATE A NUCLEAR.
PLANT IT'S ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
FOR RELICENSING WHAT DO YOU DO
WITH THE SPENT RODS THIS CAN
MEAN ONGOING SECURITY OBLIGATION
IN COST WHAT THIS BILL LOOKS AT
IS THE DECOMMISSIONING PROCESS.
AND A FINITE PERIOD OF TIME OF A
DE MINIMIS RATE INCREASE.
AND WITH THE COMMITMENT OF THESE
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
RTC ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
THE ALLIANCE --
FOR FOR NUCLEAR --
FOR NUCLEAR RESPONSE.
ALL OF THEM.
AS PARTIES TO THE NEGOTIATIONS
ARE CONFIDENT THAT PGD PART OF
THEIR BUSINESS DECISIONS THAT
WHAT'S LOST ON THE GRID WITH
RENEWABLE ENERGY CLEAN LESS
EXPENSIVE.
THAT'S WHERE NEW JOBS ARE IN
THIS STATE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
NEW JOBS SOLAR IS GETTING LESS
EXPENSIVE WERE WORKING ON WIND
ENERGY OFF THAT SAME COAST WE
MAY EVEN BILL TO USE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN THE FUTURE FOR WIND ENERGY SO
THIS IS THE RIGHT REMEDY AND
I'LL JUST CLOSE ON THIS WHEN IT
WENT BEFORE THE P. YOU SEE.
THEY WERE P. YOU SEE
COMMISSIONERS WHO APPLAUDED.
THE NEGOTIATED SETTLEMENT.
AND EXPRESSED THEIR REGRET.
THAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY IN THEIR MIND TO
APPROVE THE AGREED TO SETTLEMENT
AND IT WOULD REQUIRE LEGISLATION.
WE'RE HERE WITH THAT LEGISLATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
I'D LIKE TO SEE IF MY COAUTHOR.
I WOULD LIKE TO OFFER SOME
COMMENTS I WOULD TO SAID
[inaudible]
FOR FINAL CONSIDERATION.
I DON'T THINK IT'S BEEN
ADDRESSED THAT THE NRC THE
NUCLEAR REGULATORY COMMISSION
DOES HAVE MINIMUM STAFFING
STAFFING THRESHOLDS.
BUT EVERY NUCLEAR FACILITY.
AND IF YOU FALL BELOW THOSE
THRESHOLDS ARE THAT THRESHOLD.
IN TERMS OF YOUR CERTIFICATED
WORKFORCE.
AND THEY CAN CHECK IT OUT.
SO WHILE THERE IS A COST THIS
THAT'S UNDENIABLE.
I IT'S AN INSURANCE POLICY OF
SORTS TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AND WE CONTINUE
TO OPERATE THIS FACILITY SAFELY
AND SECURELY.
A THROUGH THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
CLOSER.
TO AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY THE THE BILL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
A BUT WE PROCESS YOUR ENTHUSIASM --
WE WE WE DO HAVE A MOTION TO DO
PASS SYSTEM MENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS APPRECIATE AGAIN
YOUR PRESENTATION ROLL CALL.
I'M SORRY TO ESTIMATE OMEGA
[inaudible] TO PASS
[inaudible]
APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN HIGH HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON
PATTERSON AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE BURKE.
BURKE I CHEN.
CHEN AYE.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES.
MAYES AYE MURATSUCHI AYE AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE REYES.
REYES I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
THOSE THAT GRADUATION THINK
AGREEMENT RULERS PRECIADO THANK
YOU -- WE
WILL PUT THE CALL OUT FOR
SENATOR HERTZBERG AND IN THE
MEANTIME WE HAVE THREE BILLS
THAT ARE ON CALL --
LET'S MOVE --
TO AS A FILE ITEM ONE S. B.
SIXTY FOUR Y. KOWSKI.
S. B. SIXTY FOUR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE.
BURKE.
BURKE I EDUARDO GARCIA.
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
HEY THAT BILL IS OUT COOLEY THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS SAID
ON NEXT ITEM FILE ITEM THREE SB.
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO S. EVEN HAVE SB
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE BURKE AYE AYE.
BURKE AYE.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
QUIRK FIVE QUIRK AYE REYES.
REYES AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN -- FILE
ITEM EIGHT SB ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE
BRADFORD.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE WITH
THE CHAIR MONNING AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING. ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE IF WE LOOK TO THE
PATTERSON NOT VOTING BURKE
[inaudible]
BURKE I GALLAGHER [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
REYES I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE TING. ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE WITH THE GERMAN I TING AYE.
A THAT BILL IS OUT AS WELL.
BELIEVE IT OPEN.%
AND WE WILL MOVE TO CONSENT FOR
THOSE TO ADD ONTO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE REYES.
REYES I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
OF WE WILL TAKE UP THE STERN
BILLS NOW FOR YOU TO ADD ON FOR
OTHER MEMBERS SAID ON AS WELL.
S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA REYES A AYE REYES
AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN BUT
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
REYES.
REYES AYE.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
YOU'RE ALREADY ON THE S. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE CHEN
[inaudible]
CHEN NO.
THAT WATER GARCIA [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
CORRECT [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
PERFECT TIMING SENATOR.
YOU THINK YOU.
SO WE WILL.
TURN OUR ATTENTION TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO S. B. [inaudible]
TWO THIRTY SEVEN HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PHOTOS OF HER.
THE ISSUE IS [inaudible]
DIRECT ACCESS.
CERTAINLY WE DEALT WITH THIS IN
THE ENERGY CRISIS MANY YEARS AGO.
BUT CENTER KEOGH IF MY
RECOLLECTION SERVES ME CORRECTLY --
WITH GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER
[inaudible]
LIFTED A CAP [inaudible]
AND WE'VE GOT THIS CHALLENGE.
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
REGIONALIZATION OF THE GREATER
[inaudible]
RE THINKING.
HOW WE DELIVER ENERGY?
THE OLD BUSINESS MODEL THE DEAL
THAT WAS MADE YEARS AGO WHEN
SOCIETY BEGAN TO RELY MORE
HEAVILY.
ON ELECTRICITY.
AND BECAUSE IT WAS SO IMPORTANT
TO THE FUNCTIONING OF SOCIETY WE
BASICALLY SAID.
WE'RE GONNA GRANT A MONOPOLY TO
GOVERNMENT.
AND WERE GONNA SAY OR DON'T
BEASTIES UNIQUE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES IF YOU ARE LOW INCOME
GOVERNMENT WE KEEP THIS
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE WHERE
EVERYBODY DECIDES.
HOW MUCH THE COSTS ARE WE CAN
HAVE RATE TERRACE IN WE'RE GONNA
TERMINATE RATE SO WE CAN
GUARANTEE INVESTORS ARE RATE OF
RETURN?
AND IT WORKED PRETTY
INTELLIGENTLY FOR A LONG TIME.
WE HAD AN EXPERIMENT WITH MISTER
BOLTON MR PIECE IN.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR EIGHTEEN
NINETY WAS THE ISSUE OF WE
DEREGULATED BOTH THE WHOLESALE
AND RETAIL MARKET.
AT A TIME WHEN TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES WEREN'T AVAILABLE AND
IT WAS EARLY.
AND IT WE ALL KNOW THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT ME IN
PARTICULAR.
AND NOW WHAT'S HAPPENED HAS BEEN
WE HAVE AS WE GRAPPLE WITH SO
MANY OF THESE ISSUES.
WE'VE COME ALONG AND SAID WE
WANT TO START.
PUTTING IN RENEWABLES AND WE
WANT TO CHANGE FOR SERIES OF
REASONS.
HOW WE RELY ON ENERGY?
WILL THAT CHANGE HAS
FUNDAMENTALLY.
ARM IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT WHEN I
WASN'T WORKING IN THE ENERGY
CRISIS EVERY LAW THAT WAS
WRITTEN IN THE WHOLE STATE WAS
IN THE WRITTEN BY MUNICIPAL OR
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY.
AND IT WAS IMPOSSIBLE FOR
ANYTHING TO HAPPEN THEY HAD
REALLY MONOPOLISTIC POWER
JURISPRUDENTIAL IF YOU WILL.
AND SOON WE STARTED SAYING WELL
WE WANTED TO START HAVING A
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
WHATEVER YOU THAT WAS TWO
THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND THE U. S..
WITHOUT BYRON SHEER.
ALL OF A SUDDEN ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WITH RESPECT TO THAT
WAS WELL.
IT DOESN'T PERFORM IN THE SAME
MANNER AS OTHER ENERGY IT'S NOT
THE EXACT SAME BASES LOADED WITH
BASED LOADS IN PICKERS AND THE
LIKE AND WE HAD ALL PRICING
SCHEDULE.
YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN WE DID
FLEXURE POWER PROGRAM IS ALL
ABOUT.
TRIP SHUT YOUR YOUR YOUR WASHING
MACHINE OFTEN YOUR LIGHTS OFF IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE DAY IN AUGUST
NOW WE CAN THE MIDDLE THE DAY IN
AUGUST SOMETIMES WE HAVE IT ALL
A SURPLUS IN JUNE WE ACTUALLY
HAVE THE AYE IS SO WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO WITH REGIONALIZATION.
TO DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE OF
ALMIGHTY GOD.
WE HAVE TO PAY PEOPLE TO TAKE
THE EXTRA POWER.
SO PART OF THAT DIAGNOSTIC WHEN
I FIRST CAME BACK TO GOVERNMENT
HOW MANY YEARS OF FOUR YEARS AGO
WHATEVER I DID A DIRECT ACCESS
BILL.
AND NOW I'M SITTING WITH THAT
GUY KILLED JEFF DEXTER NO.
BACK THEN I THINK IT WAS IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
ARM TRYING TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
ON THE RETAIL SIDE FOR
COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL
ESTABLISHMENTS CHOICE.
WHY IS IT IN SUPPORT FOR A LOT
OF REASONS AND WE THINK THAT
THEN I'LL LET TURN OVER TO
MISTER WELCH?
BUT IT'S GOING TO GIVE THE
LARGER CONTEXT OF WHAT I'M DOING
OF LIFTING THAT CAP THAT WE HAD
WAS SENATOR KEYHOE --
WHAT YEARS AT NINE TO THE?
HE IS TWO THOUSAND NINE THERE'S
TWO THOUSAND I AS IS ALWAYS AS
WE SEE I CAN NEVER BILL NUMBERS
ON AROUND GOLDMEMBER.
BUT THE THE POINT IS IS THAT.
ARM TO TRY TO CREATE THOSE
RETAIL MARKETS IN A WAY THAT
GIVES CHOICE BECAUSE OF A CUT
BUSINESSES LOOK EVERY BUSINESS
HAS THREATENED FIXED COSTS WHAT
BUSINESS IS TRYING TO DO IS TO
BE GREAT CREATIVE TO MANAGE
THOSE FIXED COSTS.
AND TRY TO PUT TOGETHER VARIOUS
CONFIGURATIONS TO REDUCE THEIR
COSTS AND BY LIFTING THIS CAP.
THERE'S JUST AN EXTRAORDINARY
MISTER WHICH CAN TALK ABOUT THE
NUMBERS BECAUSE OF EXTRAORDINARY
BACKLOG OF COMPANIES THAT ARE
PRETTY CREATIVE IN THAT WANT TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE TO REDUCE COSTS.
ONE I CHAIRED THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION.
IN 200-042-00011 WE DID SURVEYS
ON BUSINESS CLIMATE AND
EVERYBODY ALWAYS TALKS ABOUT
REGULATION AND ALL THAT STUFF.
PART NUMBER ONE OF OUR TOP THE
TOP TWO ISSUES WHICH ENERGY
COSTS ENERGY COSTS.
AND SO WHEN WE LOOK TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS.
WILL WE CAN HARMONIZE PUBLIC
POLICY TO REDUCE ENERGY COSTS
THAT ARE CONSISTENT WITH OUR
VALUES ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE ON
THE ONE HAND.
YET GIVE SMART COMPANIES THE
ABILITY TO ACTUALLY REDUCE THEIR
ENERGY COSTS IN WAYS THAT ARE
MORAL AT A CONSISTENT WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY BECAUSE
THEY'RE GONNA GET DIRECT ACCESS
THEY'RE GONNA BY DIFFERENT
SOURCES.
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO REDUCE
THEIR COSTS I THINK IT'S TIME
FOR THIS BILL THAT LOST IN THIS
COMMITTEE. FOUR YEARS AGO TO
BRING IT BACK TODAY.
BUT WITH DIRECT ACCESS TO TURN
OVER TO MR WHICH GERMAN MEMBER
SCOTT WHICH CAN BE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES.
I THINK FOR FOLKS WHO'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN ENERGY POLICY --
SINCE -- THE
EARLY NINETIES --
AND CERTAINLY SINCE A
DEREGULATION THEY WILL BE
SHOCKED SEE ME UP HERE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TO LIFT THE
CAP DIRECT ACCESS I'M THE FIRST
ONE BY THE WAY.
THE JUST.
JUST ABOUT EVERY SINGLE BILL
OVER -- MANY
MANY MANY YEARS TO HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED WE WE HAVE A POST.
AND SO SO WHAT HAS CHANGED WHAT
WHAT WE'VE COME TO REALIZE IS
THAT [inaudible]
A AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
POINTED OUT WE'VE BALKANIZED THE
ENERGY MARKETS IN.
AND UNDER THE GUISE OF
COMPETITION WE HOPE WE WE WE
HAVE ALLOWED CERTAIN.
TYPES OF OF OF WHAT I WOULD CALL
FAKE COMPETITION TO OCCUR WE'VE
ALLOWED --
CUTIE CHORES AGGREGATORS TO TO
FORM INTO JUST SWEEP CUSTOMERS.
AND THEN THE CUSTOMERS HAVE TO
BE SAVVY ENOUGH --
TO OPT OUT IF THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE SERVED BY THAT INTO TV LONGER
THAT'S NOT COMPETITION.
SO WE'VE COME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT IF YOU GET A DO COMPETITION
AND YOU'RE GONNA CLAIM THAT YOU
WANT TO HAVE COMPETITION.
THE LET'S OPEN IT UP AND ALLOW.
TRUE COMPETITION TO TAKE PLACE.
AND THIS IS REALLY A HISTORIC
MOMENT BECAUSE OF WHEATON DIS
THE VARIOUS GROUPS HERE THAT ARE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL HAVE NEVER
STOOD TOGETHER ON THIS ISSUE.
EVER YEAH AND TO TO QUOTE A TO
QUOTE [inaudible]
ALANIS MORISSETTE.
I HAVE TO SAY.
ISN'T IT IRONIC [inaudible]
NOT.
DON'T YOU THINK.
A LITTLE TOO IRONIC.
THAT THE FOLKS WHO ARE OPPOSING
THIS BILL.
ARE THE FOLKS WHO ARE THE WHO
CALL THEMSELVES THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER CHOICE ASSOCIATION AND
THEY'RE GONNA COME UP AND OPPOSE
CHOICE.
I THINK THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE CHOICE LET'S LET THE
CONSUMERS CHOOSE LET'S OPEN UP
THE MARKETS.
AND WE WOULD URGE AYE VOTE FOR
THAT REASON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS EQUITY MICHAEL SAW
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION --
I HAVE NOT HEARD LANCE MORE SET
COULDN'T TESTIMONY BEFORE THAT --
AS THE FIRST BUT I I DO THINK IS
VERY FASTENING THAT WE ARE HERE
TOGETHER MANUFACTURERS AND LABOR
WORKING TOGETHER TO PROMOTE.
A OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE
AFFORDABLE ENERGY. FOR
MANUFACTURERS THAT EMPLOYEE --
VIENEN VALUED HIGHLY SKILLED
WORKERS ON THROUGHOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY --
TO CREATE GOOD PAYING MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS THAT HELP RAISE UP
OUR OUR COMMUNITIES.
IMPORTANT CONTEXT TO NOTE OUR
RATES ARE 80% EIGHTY SIX FOR
NATIONAL RATE PAYERS ARE.
EIGHTY SIX HIGHER THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE WERE A HUNDRED
AND 13% HIGHER.
THAN OUR NEIGHBORING WESTERN
STATES.
NOW WE'RE TWO TIMES --
THE THE PRICE IN THE VALLEY THAT
ARIZONA OR AGAIN WERE NEARLY
THREE TIMES THE PRICE OF THE
ELECTRICITY WASHINGTON STATE.
I WON'T MENTION THAT YOU KNOW
STATE WITH A SOUTHWESTERN STATE --
THAT FREQUENTLY IS CITED IN
CALIFORNIA --
BUT IT SIGNIFICANTLY LESS AS
WELL -- EVEN
STATES LIKE IDAHO --
WHICH ARE STARTING TO DRAW MORE
MANUFACTURING ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
LOWER PRICE ELECTRICITY AND IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
ELECTRICITY.
IN THE MANUFACTURING PROCESS IN
SOME CASES EVEN MORE A HOUSE
SOMEWHERE SIGNIFICANT SHARE OF
THE COSTS.
THEN THE LABOR IS FOR THAT
MATTER.
ODD THAT WE NEED TO FIND WAYS TO
MAKE THAT MORE AFFORDABLE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THEY
AT UNDER THIS BILL --
WITH THE LIFTING OF THE CAP IT
ELECTRIC SERVICE PROVIDERS WILL
STILL HAVE TO MEET THE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY --
RELIABILITY REQUIREMENTS WILL
HAVE TO MEET --
THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL --
BUT WHAT INDUSTRIAL CUSTOMERS
WANT WHAT THEY NEED IS ANOTHER
CHOICE IS ANOTHER OPTION FOR
MORE AFFORDABLE ELECTRICITY.
I GOES TO THE HEART OF THEIR
COMPETITIVENESS THIS BILL WE
BELIEVE GETS US A GOOD WAYS
TOWARDS THAT.
IS THAT THE ENTIRE SOLUTION NO
ARE THERE OTHER ISSUES THAT WE
NEED TO DEAL WITH IN THE
ELECTRICITY SECTOR DID TO HELP
BRING THOSE COSTS DOWN.
ABSOLUTELY AND THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBVIOUSLY IT'S HERE MUCH
SAKE SHE MAY HAS ON YET
UNDERTAKEN EFFORTS TO DEAL
WITHOUT AS WELL AS OTHERS ON THE
COMMITTEE.
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE AS ELL
FAST FOR SUPPORT ON S. B..
TWO THIRTY SEVEN A GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MICHAEL ROCKS WHEN I AM THE
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF THE SCHOOL
PROJECT FOR UTILITY RATE
REDUCTION WHICH IS SO CALLED
SPUR.
WERE GROUP OF OVER.
TWO HUNDRED COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS COUNTY OFFICES OF IT.
BEEN AROUND SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE WE DO AGGREGATED
PROCUREMENTS IN THE UTILITY
FIELD INCLUDING NATURAL GAS LED
LIGHTS AND CONTROL SOLAR ENERGY.
AT DIRECT AXIS ELECTRICITY
UNLIMITED BASIS AS TO THE EXTENT
IT'S BEEN ALLOWED.
ADAM AND WE'RE HERE TO URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR REMOVING THESE VERY
ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS ON OUR
ABILITY TO SHOP FOR ELECTRICITY.
WHAT WE WANT TO DO WHAT SOME OF
OUR SCHOOLS ON A LIMITED BASIS
DUE TO THE THE THE CURRENT
CONSTRAINTS ON DIRECT ACTORS
HAVE BEEN DOING FOR MANY YEARS?
IS GETTING SUPPLIERS TO COMPETE
TO SERVICE COMPETE ON PRICE
COMPETE ON TERMS COMPETE ON
SERVICE --
WE CAN DE WEEKEND IT DEPLOY
VARIOUS TACTICS TO PROTECT OUR
BUDGETS TO GET THE LOWEST COST
TO GET THE SERVICES THAT WE WANT.
THIS IS THE SAME THING THAT
WE'RE REQUIRED TO DO AND
BASICALLY EVERY OTHER ASPECT OF
OUR PROCUREMENT SYSTEM COMPETE.
AND THAT'S WE WANT TO DO WILL
HELP WHICH ALLOW US TO DO THAT
WITHOUT THE CONTINUING
ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS THAT IMPOSED
ON US RIGHT NOW.
WITH THE 15% CAP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SHARE A MEMBERS I'M DAVID
PHILLIPS AND THE ASSOCIATE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR ENERGY AND
SUSTAINABILITY WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT --
I'M HERE TODAY TO STATE --
ARE YOU KNOW THE UNIVERSITY
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THAT WOULD
EXPAND DIRECT ACCESS.
ON THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IS ALREADY IN THE DIRECT ACCESS
BUSINESS --
WE SET A GOAL TO BECOME ENTIRELY
CARBON NEUTRAL BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND DIRECT
AXIS IS ONE OF OUR KEY
STRATEGIES TO DO THAT --
WE CURRENTLY SUPPLY ALL. SEVEN
OF OUR CAMPUSES AND THE PROGRAM
HAS BEEN WILDLY SUCCESSFUL FOR
THE UNIVERSITY --
IN TERMS OF REDUCING EMISSIONS
AND CUTTING COSTS FOR OUR
CAMPUSES AND EXPANSION OF THIS
PROGRAM WOULD ALLOW THE
REMAINING CAMPUSES TO JOIN WITH
THIS PROGRAM.
AND SHARE IN THAT SUCCESS SO WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR EXPANSION
OF DIRECT ACCESS TO DISPEL.
THANK YOU OTHERS TO LEND THEIR
VOICES IN SUPPORT.
BUT IF YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
DEPENDS ON BEHALF OF TECHNET
WE'RE IN SUPPORT AND ALSO I
THINK MISTER WEST FROM PUTTING A
SONG IN MY HEAD THAT I HAVEN'T.
HAD STUCK THERE IN MANY MANY
YEARS TOPICS.
JUDY HE IS A THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE FOOD PRODUCERS
REPRESENTING THE FOOD PROCESSING
INDUSTRY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
IN USING THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THEO
PALE SERBS IN THE ALLIANCE FOR
RETAIL ENERGY MARKETS --
WE SUPPLY THE ELECTRICITY FOR
THESE CUSTOMERS POT AS WELL AS
DIRECT ACCESS CUSTOMER COALITION
WHICH REPRESENTS THE BUSINESSES
THAT TAKE THAT'S JUST ONE LET
THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE ABOUT EIGHT THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS SIXTEEN HUNDRED
CUSTOMERS.
THERE WAITING TO EXPAND WRECKED
ACCESS AND AND EXPAND THEIR
OPERATIONS IN CALIFORNIA BE GOOD
FOR THE ECONOMY GOOD FOR WORKERS
THANK YOU.
SURELY NOT ASK ABOUT HAVE
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE IN SPORT.
REX EVERY TIME ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S PROP DISSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
GAVIN MCCUE SHELL ENERGY NORTH
AMERICA IN SUPPORT.
SILVIO FOR I AM TO HAVE A
CARGILL IN SUPPORT.
IT'LL BE A SILLY SHAUN BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY WE ARE
IN THE PROCESS OF FORMALIZING
OUR SUPPORT POSITION LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS IN THE FORWARD.
SCOTT SAT ON BEHALF OF JUST
ENERGY IN SUPPORT.
AMY BROWN ON BEHALF OF
ALBERTSON'S SAFEWAY IN SUPPORT.
ERIN MORAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
MARY WHILE WITH THIS YES YOU
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND WE URGE ARRIVE VOTE.
MARGOT PARKS THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS DON
GILBERT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY CHOICES SATIATION JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY IN CASE ANYONE
WAS CONFUSED BY MISTER WHITE IS
TESTIMONY THAT COUNTY CA DOES
NOT HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL
I KNOW HE WAS REFERRING TO
SOMEONE ELSE.
BUT JUST TO MAKE IT CLEAR ALSO
HAVE TO SAY THAT I WAS AROUND A
LOT IN THESE ISSUES WHEN --
WHEN THAT THE AUTHOR WAS SPEAKER
IN DEALING WITH THEM AND I HAVE
UTMOST RESPECT FOR HIS VIEW OF
OUR ENERGY ISSUES THANKS A LOT?
AND SO NOW WILL OF WELCOME. ONE
TO BE A WITNESS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ARE
THAT FRIEDMAN AGAIN WITH THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK I'M NOT
REPRESENTING COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS I'M REPRESENTING
RATEPAYERS AND SPECIFICALLY
RESIDENTIAL RATEPAYERS.
AND I BELIEVE THAT SENATOR
HERTZBERG DID IDENTIFY A NUMBER
OF VERY SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
THAT THE STATE IS CURRENTLY
FACING IN ACHIEVING MANY OF ITS
POLICY GOALS BUT THIS BILL
DOESN'T ACTUALLY RESOLVE ANY OF
THEM.
I'M IN FACT WE BELIEVE THAT WILL
MAKE ACHIEVEMENT OF THE STATE'S
POLICY GOALS MUCH MORE DIFFICULT.
AND THIS IS THE MOST.
BOB MAJOR AND FUNDAMENTAL
PROPOSED CHANGE TWO THE STATE'S
ELECTRICITY MARKETS SINCE THE
ADOPTION OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
EIGHTEEN NINETY AND THIS WOULD.
THIS IS A THIS REPRESENTS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT SHIFT.
AND IT SHOULD RECEIVE
SIGNIFICANT ATTENTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND ARGUE IT WOULD
UNDERMINE STATE POLICY GOALS AND
DESTABILIZE ELECTRICITY MARKETS.
ARMED WITH RESPECT THE CCA'S WE
EXPECT THIS WOULD CREATE A
CRISIS FOR THEM ESPECIALLY THE
CCA STRUGGLING TO OBTAIN CREDIT
RATINGS AND TO ENTER INTO
FINANCE CIVIL COMMITMENTS FOR
NUCLEAR ENERGY RESOURCES.
ON DIRECT ACCESS SUPPLIERS HAVE
NO OBLIGATION TO SERVE AND
INSTEAD THEY OPERATE UNDER
ESSENTIALLY A CHERRY PICKING
MODEL WERE ONLY THE MOST
LUCRATIVE CUSTOMERS ARE OFFERED
CONTRACTS.
THIS APPROACH CONTRASTS SHARPLY
WITH THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES THE PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES AND EVEN THE CCA'S
THAT PROVIDE UNIVERSAL SERVICE
ON NON DISCRIMINATORY PRICES AND
TERMS.
I WOULD REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT DURING THE TO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND ONE ENERGY CRISIS
DIRECT ACCESS PROVIDERS DUMPED
MOST OF THEIR CUSTOMERS BACK TO
THE UTILITIES IN ACTION THAT
EXACERBATED COST PRESSURES ON
CUSTOMERS WHO NEVER CHOSE TO
SWITCH. FOR EXAMPLE ENRON
PERHAPS THE LARGEST DIRECT
ACCESS SUPPLIER AT THE TIME.
ON DUMP THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BACK TO UTILITY
SERVICE BECAUSE IT'S ON
OPPORTUNITY TO RESELL THE POWER
IT HAD BOUGHT FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA INTO THE WHOLESALE
MARKET AND MAKE A LARGE PROFIT.
THIS WAS CONSIDERED EFFICIENT
ECONOMIC BREACH WE COULD SEE A
SIMILAR RESULT IF THERE'S
ANOTHER PROBLEM WITH ENERGY
MARKETS.
DIRECT ACCESS IS DOMINATED BY
SHORT TERM CUSTOMERS AND SHORT
TERM WHOLESALE COMMITMENTS.
IT'S SATISFYING RESOURCE
PLANNING AND STATE POLICY
OBJECTIVES REQUIRES LONG TERM
COMMITMENTS TO DRIVE NEW
INVESTMENT.
BECAUSE THE ELECTRICITY SYSTEM
INVOLVES DEEP INTERDEPENDENCE
CHOICES MADE BY SOME CUSTOMERS
TO GO SHORT CAN AFFECT ALL
CUSTOMERS.
SO WHO IS GOING TO BE LEFT TO
MAKE THE LONG TERM COMMITMENTS
ON BEHALF OF THE SYSTEM.
WE BELIEVE THE STATE NEEDS TO
FIGURE THIS OUT BEFORE
CONSIDERING AN UNLIMITED
EXPANSION OF DIRECT ACCESS.
AND THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IS STRUGGLING TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM THEY HAVEN'T
FIGURED OUT AN ANSWER.
THEY HAVEN'T DEMONSTRATED THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DIRECT LONG
TERM CORE PROCUREMENT AND
RESOURCE PLANNING IN A
FRAGMENTED RETAIL MARKET.
THEY'VE IDENTIFIED MANY GAPS IN
THE FRAMEWORK AS PART OF THEIR
GREEN BOOK PROCESS.
AND AS REFERENCED IN THE
ANALYSIS DOWN THIS BILL PRODUCED
BY THE COMMITTEE.
THERE LITERALLY IS NO PLAN TO
COORDINATE THE ACTIVITIES OF
VARIOUS RETAIL PROVIDERS.
AND WE WOULD NOTE THAT PRIOR
BILLS THAT WERE CONSIDERING
EXPANSIONS OF DIRECT ACCESS THAT
WERE ENACTED RECEIVED
SUBSTANTIAL DEBATE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE HERE WE ARE IN THE
SECOND HOUSE IN THE FIRST POLICY
COMMITTEE.
THIS APPEARS TO BE THE ONLY
CHANCE TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
AND WHILE THE AUTHORS PRIOR BILL
TO EXPAND DIRECT ACCESS ON WOULD
HAVE INCLUDED GUARANTEES THAT
DIRECT ACCESS CUSTOMERS WOULD
ACHIEVE 1100% RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIOS.
NO SUCH REQUIREMENTS ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL.
AS A RESULT.
ON THE DIRECT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD EXPECT THE DIRECT ACCESS
PROVIDERS WILL ENGAGE IN MINIMUM
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
REQUIREMENTS.
AND I WOULD DISCOURAGE YOU FROM
IMAGINING THAT THE ANECDOTES YOU
HEAR ABOUT CUSTOMERS SEEKING TO
OBTAIN HIGHER RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIOS ARE INDICATIVE OF THE
TYPICAL DIRECT ACCESS CUSTOMER
WHO SIMPLY IS LOOKING TO GET THE
CHEAPEST ENERGY.
AS A PRACTITIONER I CAN TELL YOU
THAT ELECTRIC SERVICE PROVIDERS
THAT PROVIDE DIRECT ACCESS SERVE
ACT SERVICE.
ROUTINELY CLAIM CONFIDENTIALITY
PROTECTIONS FOR BASIC
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR RETAIL
SALES IN ABOUT THE RESOURCE
PORTFOLIOS AND AS A RESULT WE
KNOW SO MUCH LESS ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING THAN WE DO ABOUT
WHAT THAT I'LL USE.
P. O. USE AND CCA'S ARE DOING.
SO MORE DIRECT ACCESS IN EFFECT
MEANS LESS TRANSPARENCY AND
GREATER DIFFICULTY IN PROVIDING
MEANINGFUL PUBLIC OVERSIGHT THIS
BILL DOES NOT PROPOSE A FIX THAT
PROBLEM. FOR THESE REASONS WE
URGE YOU NOT TO GO DOWN THE ROAD
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CHOSE IN
THE MID NINETEEN NINETIES AND TO
NOT APPROVE THIS BILL TODAY
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
HEARING NONE WILL WILL BRING IT
BACK -- TO
THE DIES --
SENATOR YOUR YOUR YOUR ALL YOUR
ONE WHO ALWAYS THINKS OUTSIDE
THE BOX AND PUSHES THE ENVELOPE
AND AS TIME.
LOOKING FOR WAYS OF CONTINUING
TO FIND WAYS OF INCREASING
CHOICE AS YOU POINTED OUT.
OUR AND ALSO BRINGING DOWN THE
COST NEVER EXPECT AND
APPRECIATED --
I HAVE NO RECOMMENDATION ON THIS
BILL A TODAY --
BUT I MUST AT GIVEN VP UC'S
VALUATION OF THE MARKETPLACE AND
REALLY MOVE IN THE CAP.
I AT THIS TIME THE INSTABILITY
THAT WOULD CREATE IN THE
MARKETPLACE --
I DO RECOGNIZE THAT AND HAVE
SOME CONCERN OF WHAT THAT
REPRESENTS.
OF SO WITH THAT I WOULD NOT BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
BUT AGAIN THERE'S NO
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR AS
TO HOW THIS MIGHT OF VIEW THIS
PARTICULAR BILL.
BUT I DO I'M ALWAYS RESPECT YOU
AND AND YOUR POSITIONS.
A DOCTOR EGGMAN --
THANK YOU AND AND THINK IF
CENTER BETHESDA ON THE CHAIR
SAID YOU.
ALWAYS COME AT THINGS VERY
THOUGHTFULLY AND I APPRECIATE
AND AND YOU LIKE TO DO BIG
THINGS --
I'M ALSO REMINDED OF A OF A THE
SONGWRITER AND BUT JANICE JOPLIN.
FREEDOM'S JUST ANOTHER WORD FOR
NOTHING LEFT TO LOSE --
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M A LITTLE
WORRIED ABOUT --
RIGHT THIS IS BEEN DESCRIBED BY
IDENTIFIED IN IN THE GREEN BOOK
AS SOMETHING THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY CRITIC CRISIS
WITHOUT SOME KIND OF CAP --
I THINK I CERTAINLY HEAR FROM --
A LOT OF INDUSTRY LOUD AND CLEAR
THAT THAT THAT COSTS ARE TOO
HIGH.
RIGHT AND IT'S VERY HARD TO DO
BUSINESS IN THE IN THE CURRENT
MARKET THAT WE LIVE IN WITH
INCREDIBLY HIGH.
I'M A COST OF OF OF ENERGY AND
AYE I AGAIN I APPLAUD YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO CUT IT TO HAVE TO
GET IN HERE.
SO BUT NO WE DID THIS WITH
TURKEY O. THERE WERE SOME CAPS
IN PLACE.
AND NOW WE'RE TALKING AND THAT
WAS ON AN INDIVIDUAL MARKET NOR
TALK ABOUT GOING LARGER.
WHY NO CAPS [inaudible]
AND AND IF AND BUT AND AGAIN.
EVERY EVERY WEEK WE SAID THIS
COMMITTEE WE KEEP TALKING WE
NEED A LARGER ORGANIZING MODEL
TO BE ABLE LOOK AT OUR ENERGY
GOING FORWARD AND WE KEEP JUST.
CREW DOING MORE BILLS.
I DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND I
THINK THE IMPACT OF HOW THEY
INTERSECT WITH EACH OTHER
[inaudible]
AND HAVE.
THE IMPACT ON ON ON ON THE
CONSUMER RIGHT WHICH IS THE
BUDGET THE BOTTOM LINE THAT
[inaudible]
I THINK.
POLICY MAKERS HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT IS THE BOTTOM LINE
FOR THE CONSUMER HOW DOES THAT
AFFECT THEM.
SO CAN YOU ANSWERS LIKE Y. NO
CAP.
WOULD YOU SEE THIS GOING THIS IS
THE BEGINNING OF THE
CONVERSATION OR IS THIS YOUR END
PRODUCT.
RIGHT SHOULD BE MOVING ON TODAY
BECAUSE YOU WON'T BECAUSE IT CAN
USE THAT OR IS THIS IT.
AND I WONDER WHY THE UTILITIES
ARE SILENT.
TALKED ABOUT THAT TAPE OKAY SO
TANACH I I'M NOT SO IS MUSICALLY
INCLINED BUT I WANT TO BE
INSPIRED BY JACK KENNEDY IN
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE WHEN HE
TALKED ABOUT.
PUTTING SOMEBODY ON THE MOMENT
AND IT A PERSON A HUMAN BEING ON
THE MONET SAYS WE'RE NOT DOING
IT BECAUSE IT'S EASY WOODLAND
BECAUSE IT'S HARD.
WELL THAT WAS NINETEEN SIXTY ONE
TODAY PUTTING SOMEBODY ON THE
MOAN IS A LOT EASIER WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT.
AND EVEN FROM THE TIME WHEN IT
IS TO SPILL FOUR YEARS AGO
THERE'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
THAT.
I THINK INFORMED THE REASON WHY
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
WHICH WORK THEIR CASH BECAUSE
OUT TO COME OUT AGAINST ME LAST
TIME AROUND FOR YEARS AGO
HAVEN'T SHOWN UP.
AND HERE'S THE REASON.
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
TO ADVANCE THE BALL.
IT IS EASY TO COME UP AND SAY
THE SKY IS FALLING IN THE SCARE
POLICYMAKERS.
THAT WAS DONE IN SO MANY ISSUES
THROUGHOUT HUMAN HISTORY ALWAYS
THE WAY TO KILL SOMETHING BUT WE
HAVE ENGAGE IN EXTRAORDINARILY
THOUGHTFUL DELIBERATION AND
CONSIDERATION.
IN TRYING TO CHANGE THIS MARKET
WHAT HAVE WE DONE FIRST.
IT S. B. THREE FIFTY WE SAID
THAT THIS OUR PS STANDARD OF THE
TIME I DID THIS WE DIDN'T HAVE
S. B. THREE FIFTY IS 50% IF S.
B. BEST BE ONE HUNDRED PASSES.
IT'S GOING TO BE A 100% IN TERMS
OF THE OUR PS IN MAKING SURE
THAT WHATEVER THAT CHOICES IS
APPROPRIATELY ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE [inaudible] TO THE
WHOLE COST SHIFTING ARGUMENT
WHICH NO ONE MADE AND THAT'S THE
ARGUMENT THAT THE UTILITIES
ARGUED LAST TIME THAT SOMEHOW.
WE'RE NOT A WOULD HAVE A COST
SHIFTING THAT THAT'S JUST ABOUT
RIGHT THAT THAT QUITE FRANKLY
WAS THE CORE OF THE OPPOSITION
LAST TIME THERE'S A VAPID Y..
BECAUSE THE L. BECAUSE THINK
MATURITY OF THE PROCESS AND THE
CONFIDENCE THAT PEOPLE HAVE HAD
HAS SHIFTED AWAY.
ARM.
UNION YOU KNOW I THINK THAT.
IT AND THE RELIANCE ON THE OUR
PS IS CREATED IN MY JUDGMENT A
DIFFERENT MARKET THAT WE DIDN'T
HAVE BEFORE.
THE OTHER ARGUMENT THAT WAS MADE
THAT TRIED TO TANK THIS WAS WELL
THERE'S NO LONG TERM CONTRACTS
WELL S. B. THREE FIFTY DID THAT.
TO SO THE READ THE REASON THIS
IS COULD YOU KNOW SEE OLD SCHOOL
OF OLIVE WOULD GO HOME SAYS WHEN
THE REASON BUT NO WHICH AT THAT
WITH THE ART WHEN THE REASON FOR
THE RULE SEIZE THE RULE SEIZE I
CAN'T REMEMBER LATIN.
THE POINT IS THAT.
THERE'S IMPORTANT REASONS TO DO
STUFF AND THAT HAS FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGED WE ARE NOW IS THE
CHAIRMAN WAS TRYING TO DO
REGIONALIZATION.
CLEARLY MUST TO PASS OF THIS
COMMITTEE BECAUSE IN OUR HOUSE.
WHAT'S HE DOING WE'RE LITERALLY
IN THIS SITUATION DID PASSED
BETTER KNOW WHATEVER WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS WHOLE.
PARA.
OF WAS BUT BILL A VAGUE MEAN
LIKE THIS ONE HERE YOU MEAN OKAY
BUT ANY INNOCENT GETS WATERY BUT
IN ANY EVENT THE POINT IS THAT.
WE LITERALLY PAYING PEOPLE TO
TAKE ENERGY THINGS THAT WE JUST
COULDN'T IMAGINE BEFORE SO THAT
THAT THE COST PROTECTIONS ARE
THERE.
THE AND THEN ALSO YOU CAN HEAR
FROM US OR YOU MAY HAVE ALREADY
HEARD YOU HEAR THE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY BILL THE OTHER
COMPONENT PIECE WAS WHICH WE PUT
IN.
WAY BACK IN THE STONE AGE WAS
THIS NOTION OF RESOURCE ADEQUACY
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO AS A
COMPANION BILL TO DO A DIRECT
ACCESS IS RESOURCE ADEQUACY.
SO THIS IS LITERALLY A BUT TO
GET TO YOUR POINT ABOUT BEING
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THIS I'M NOT
TRYING TO JUST WING IT IT'S IT
IS BELTS AND SUSPENDERS IT IS
THE EVOLUTION OF THE IDEA.
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE INVESTOR
OWNS HERE WHO WERE KILLING ME
LAST TIME BECAUSE WE'VE SOLVED
THAT PROBLEM.
THIS CCA'S I'M A PIXIE CA I
BELIEVE IN THAT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THEY GIVE OPPORTUNITIES TO
COMMUNITIES TO DO ALL SORTS OF
STUFF.
YOU CAN'T HAVE ONLY ONE GROUP
THAT GETS IT.
WE HAVE THESE UNDERLYING
CHALLENGES THE WHOLE MORE HIGH
RIVER WOULD DUKE ENERGY CAME TO
LOS ANGELES AND THEY START TO
SELL YOUR SOUL THE WORLD AND
STUFF.
AND THE LAST ARGUMENT THAT WAS
MADE WHEN YOU USE THE WORD AND
RON RIGHT IT'S LIKE OLD MY GOD
THAT'S JUST A BUZZ WORD FOR BAD
STUFF.
WELL GUESS WHAT.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
MANAGERZONE SYSTEM I THINK SAN
DIEGO LAST TIME I TESTIFIED NO
ONE IS NOW AT 88%.
WHAT WHAT IT WAS SEVEN CAMPUSES
THE ALL MANAGE THEIR OWN STUFF
THE VOTE THAT THERE WERE
INTERNAL PEOPLE THEY'RE
CLAMORING FOR THIS STUFF BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO REDUCE COSTS WHICH
HAS ALL SORTS OF IMPACTS ON
VARIOUS THINGS?
IT SO WHAT YOU HAVE IS TWENTY
YEARS LATER.
EXTRAORDINARY LEVEL OF OF
ACTIVITY GOING ON EXTRAORDINARY
NUMBERS OF A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT UNDERLYING
SOLVES THE ARCHITECTURE AND I
MARRY THIS THIS DIRECT ACCESS
WITH RESOURCE ADEQUACY WHICH
BASICALLY IMPOSES THE OBLIGATION
FOR EVERYBODY HAVE A PLAN IN ONE
OF THE REASONS WE HAVE THE PLAN
LAST BUT THE PROBLEM.
LAST TIME AND PLACES LIKE ENRON
DUMPING.
THE UC IT CAN'T HAPPEN NOW RIGHT
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF
CONSEQUENCES TO ALL THAT SO
WE'VE LITERALLY RE STRUCTURED
THE PLAYING FIELD THAT ACTUALLY
NOW I WOULD SUGGEST.
BEFORE I DIDN'T HAVE A CAP
BECAUSE I WAS JUST TRYING TO
MOVE IT UP A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE
THAT WAS SUCH A HUGE COMPRESSION
A HUGE DEMAND. FOR THE
MARKETPLACE THOSE TRY TO GIVE A
LITTLE BUT I HAD ROOM I THINK IT
TOOK ABOUT FORTY FIVE MINUTES TO
FILL UP THE MARKET LAST TIME.
AND JUST WE DO SOME OF THAT
COMPRESSION NOW WHAT I'M DOING
IS TAKING IN THE MARKET IS
SAYING LOOK WE HAVE MATURED OUR
POLICY IT IS NOW TIME TO CHANGE.
I HOPE THAT HELPS YEAH SO YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY.
CONCERNED WITH THE CPU SEE
SAYING [inaudible]
THEY'RE CONCERNED.
ABOUT AN ENERGY CRISIS YEAH I'M
ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT THE I'M
ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT THAT YOU
KNOW THE EACH IT'S IT LOOK I
LIVE THROUGH IT YOU KNOW IT IT
WAS JUST MONEY DEMING WELL
BALANCED.
THE THROUGH IT THE POINT OF
DEFAULT YES.
HIT DIFFERENT SEAT TO SAY THE
LEAST APOLOGIZE I DON'T MEAN TO
ME THAT BUT WE JUST AYE I'M
STILL FEELING OKAY I HAVE STILL
PERSONALLY FEEL IT SO.
BUT IN ANY EVENT --
THAT THE POINT IS THAT THAT.
THERE ARE ENOUGH OUR CONSTRAINTS
IN MY JUDGMENT THAT WE'VE DONE
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE BEFORE ME
I'M SCREAMIN ON THE WHOLE THING
WITH RESPECT TO THE FIRES IN THE
LIABILITIES.
THAT I LOOK AT THAT AS A MUCH
BIGGER RISK PERSONALLY ON ENERGY
CRISIS BECAUSE IT A CRISIS HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH ENERGY ALL
HAD TO DO WITH.
PRICING AND THE ABILITY OF OF
THE MARKETS TO TANK US AND NOT
THESE THINGS OUT AND HAVE THESE
INVESTOR CHOOSE GO BANKRUPT WE
PICKED UP THE TAB FORTY THREE
BILLION BUCKS IT WAS A FINANCIAL
NOT AN ENERGY CRISIS.
AND I SEE THE SAME THING THAT
SCARES ME MUCH WORSE THAN WHAT
WE'RE FACING NOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR
[inaudible]
BUT OKAY --
BUT FORGIVE ME I'M JUST A SUB
HERE NEW AROUND HERE AND SO FAST.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS FIRST SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT WERE BROUGHT UP
BY THE ARM OPPONENT.
ABOUT THE CUSTOMER DUMPING ABOUT
LACK OF I'M OVERSIGHT AND PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU.
ARE WILLING TO ADDRESSES THE
BILL GOES FORWARD IT SEEMS THAT
YOU HAVE THAT OPEN A DOCUMENT IN
WHICH YOU CAN.
EXTEND SOME OF THE SAME TYPES OF
PROTECTIONS --
SAME TYPES OF REGULATIONS RIGHT
ON THIS FAIR I THINK ANY OF
THOSE KINDS OF LIKE WHEN YOU
ARGUE THE AND ONE ARGUMENT TO ME
THAT SINCE INTO RESTOCK THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA I JUST
WENT BACK AND ASKED THEM AGAIN
TO MAKE SURE I WAS RIGHT.
DID THEY RUN THEIR OWN PROGRAM
THAT UNDER CONTRA I UNDERSTAND
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS YOU YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT EXPANDING IT TO A
GROUP THAT DOESN'T HAVE MAYBE
THE SAME KIND OF PURCHASE POWER
SO I'M ALL I'M ASKING IS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD ON
TIGHTER RESIDENTIAL.
SOME REPLIES TO COMMERCIAL
INDUSTRIAL OKAY I'M SORRY ZERO
BUTTON BUT IT'S STILL POINT IS
ARE YOU WILLING TO OF COURSE
TAKE A LOOK AT MAYBE ADDING SOME
OF THAT LANGUAGE.
AND SECOND WE JUST BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THIS IS A NEW AREA FOR ME.
YEAH UNDER THIS BILL ARE UNDER
CURRENT LAW REMEMBER BAKER
GLYNDEBOURNE.
I THINK OUT OF THE UTILITY NO WE
ONLY UTILITY OF WHAT THE SHOW SO
HAPPENS WITH --
SO -- SO
DOES THIS AND TO DO THESE
ENTITIES CREATE THEIR OWN
TRANSMISSION CHU THIS OR ARE THE
UTILITIES OBLIGATED TO ALLOW
TRANSMISSION ACROSS THEIR LINES
TO ACCOMPLISH THIS IS.
OUR MISTER CHAIRMAN THEO PAY US
FOR THE LINES FOR RETAIL ENERGY
MARKETS.
KNOW IT THIS WORKS LIKE IT'S THE
CHAU ALL ALL THESE ENTITIES ARE
DOING -- ALL
OF ALL THESE ALL THAT WE'RE
DOING IS.
CURING THE ENERGY THEY ARE
ACTUALLY STILL CUSTOMERS OF THE
UTILITY BECAUSE A PLAN FOR THE
TRANSMISSION DISTRIBUTION COSTS
AND ALSO.
AFFORD BEFORE THEIR A. HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BUY.
ACCESS DIRECT ACCESS ENERGY THEY
HAVE TO PAY A DEPARTING LOW
CHARGE OF AFTER PAVE UTILITY
BACK FOR ALL THE INVESTMENTS
VETO THE PARTY MADE OKAY SO THAT
THERE IS A THERE IS A SYSTEM.
IN TERMS OF THE TRANSPARENCY.
IT CERTAINLY BE WILLING TO TALK
ABOUT THAT WE BELIEVE WE'VE BEEN
VERY TRANSPLANTS PARA WE'VE
COMPLIED WITH WITH THE OUR PS
YES OUR ACTUAL CONTRACTS WITH
OUR CUSTOMERS ARE CONFIDENTIAL.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T HAVE ALL THE
CUSTOMERS KNOW YOU KNOW WHERE
PROTECT PROPRIETARY CONTRACTS
ARE BUT OTHERWISE WE FEEL LIKE
WE'VE BEEN VERY FORTHCOMING
[inaudible]
IT AND AND IT'S A MOMENT SCOTT
WHICH ON BEHALF OF Q. --
I THINK ONE THING TO UNDERSTAND
IS IT WHEN WE DID THE LAST OUR
PS BILL THE THE ESPYS RELIGIOUS
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
THEY HAVE TO LIVE TO THE SAME RP
A STANDARD AS IT AND IT BY THEY
HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE TO THE P.
YOU SEE.
THAT THEY ARE MEETING THERE ARE
PS GOALS THERE ALSO REQUIRED TO
SIGN LONG TERM CONTRACTS UNDER
SP THREE FIFTY JUST LIKE
UTILITIES ARE AT A THAT GOT A
LITTLE MUDDLED INDIA.
EARLIER DOESN'T.
OKAY THANK YOU.
YEAH I GOT KILLED LAST TIME BY
LONG TERM CONTRACTS INVEST JOINT
BECAUSE INVESTOR TO SORT ABOUT
THAT.
AND I GET KILLED BY THE COST
SHARING ISSUE AND WHETHER OR NOT
THAT THERE WAS A FAIRNESS.
THE IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY WILL
HAVE THIS ON THROUGH IN THAT
100% OUR PS WHICH WASN'T AT THE
TIME CHINA FOR A SWEETENER IN TO
SHOW GOOD FAITH THAT OKAY FINE
WILL BALANCE OUT RISK IN WILL
BALANCE OUT POLICY.
NOW ALL THAT'S MATURED IN THE
LONG LOST FOUR YEARS SO WE THINK
IT'S IT MAKES SENSE FINALLY
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible] ONE DUCT
WORK.
SO HERE IS MY CONCERN.
WE ARE ALREADY.
THE ENERGY SITUATION IS
PRECARIOUS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY I TOOK THE UNFORTUNATE IT --
MEASURE OF OVERTURNING THE CHAIR
ON SB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT IS I AM
VERY CONCERNED.
WITH ALL OF THE THREATS.
GOING ON TO THE UTILITY'S
FINANCIAL WELL BEING.
ARE THEY ARE ALREADY TERRIBLY
CHALLENGED BY THE COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATION.
AND THEY ALREADY HAVE THEIR RD
CELINE ASSETS FOR DIMES ON THE
DOLLAR --
THIS IS GOING TO RESULT IN MORE
STRANDED ASSETS WITHOUT ABILITY
TO RECOVER.
THIS MEANS THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
REMAIN WHO ARE PRIMARILY I
BELIEVE IN REPUBLICAN DISTRICTS
BUT THE PEOPLE WHO REMAIN WITH
UTILITIES.
ARE GOING TO PAY MORE MONEY.
AND THE CCA'S I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM UNDER THIS BUT
THEY PROBABLY LOSE CUSTOMERS AS
WELL.
UP BUT THE POINT HERE IS THAT WE
WILL HAVE STRANDED AT MORE
STRANDED ASSETS.
I THINK IF WE'RE GOING LOOK AT
THIS IT OUGHT TO BE AFTER WE
HAVE.
GONE THROUGH THE STORM OF THE
CCA'S.
AND WE SEE IF OUR UTILITIES CAN
STAND ON THEIR AND THE WILDFIRES
AND SEE IF WE COULD STAND ON OUR
OWN TWO FEET.
THE CCA'S ARE ALREADY DAMAGING
THE SYSTEM.
SO MUCH THAT I AM VERY WORRIED
ABOUT THE LIFE BRENT WOODS AND
THE FIRES THAT I'M VERY WORRIED.
ABOUT THE PEOPLE LEFT ON THE
UTILITIES AND THE CHARGES
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PAY.
AND THE WORKERS WHO WILL NO
LONGER BE WORKING IN UNION
PLANTS OH BY.
AND CONTRACTED BY YOU TILT THINK
OUR CURRENT UTILITIES THAT'S MY
CONCERN.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST THAT THE
TICKETS ARE JUST QUICKLY THAT
WERE WITHOUT IT.
YEAH I I GOTTA TELL YOU IT'S THE
SAME THING THE STRANDED ASSETS
ARGUMENT.
YOU KNOW I I I I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU HAVE EXPERT ANY EXPERIENCE
AND TALKING TO REPRESENTATIVES
OF ADVOCATES FOR THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES BUT THEY'RE NOT
SHY PEOPLE.
AND THEY DO THEIR HOMEWORK IF IF
THAT WAS AN ISSUE THAT WE DEALT
WITH IN THE ENERGY CRISIS WE
DON'T WITH ALL THESE OTHER
ISSUES WE DEALT WITH WITH THE
LAST TIME I HAD THIS BILL FOUR
YEARS AGO.
AND THEY WERE HERE AND FORCE
MAKING THAT ARGUMENT.
THEY'RE NOT HERE TODAY THERE
THAT THEY'RE THE ONES ARE GONNA
GET STUCK WITH THE STRESSES
THEY'RE THE ONES WHOSE BALANCE
SHEETS ARE GOING TO BE IMPACTED
BY THAT IN MY JUDGMENT.
AND AND AND AND AND THEY THEY
CLEAR THE WHAT THE OTHER THING
THAT HAPPENED JUST REAL QUICKLY
AND SO COST SHIFTING WOULD WHERE
YOU HAD THE STATE ASSETS BECAUSE
THE IDEAS CHAD ASSETS IS AN
ASSET NOT THAT DOESN'T YOU GET
ACCUSED.
BUT GET DOESN'T GET TAKEN CARE
FROM AN ACCOUNTING STANDPOINT
AND THAT'S HIS WHOLE POWER
DIFFERENCE ADJUSTMENT AND HOW
THAT ALL OF THEM IN THE HOLE
JUST MISSING KAUSHIK THING WORKS.
AND THAT WAS THE THING IN THE
WERE [inaudible]
TO PAPERS AND THEY WERE ARGUING
Y. WHAT I SAID WAS WRONG AND NOW.
THE REASON WHY I SUPPORTED S. B.
TEN EIGHTY EIGHT YEAH WAS NOT
BECAUSE I WAS WORRIED ABOUT THE
UTILITIES I WAS WORRIED ABOUT
THE RATE PAYERS.
AND IT IS THE RATE PAYERS WHO
ARE GOING TO PAY FOR THOSE
STRANDED ASSETS IT IS THE RATE
PAYERS WHO ARE NOT ON CCA'S WHO
ARE GOING TO GET A* DEAL OUT
OF THIS.
AND THAT'S WHY I AM OPPOSED TO
THE BILL [inaudible]
ABOUT [inaudible]
IT'S MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
QUESTION WHAT.
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER.
THE PROBLEM OF BALKANIZATION.
ISN'T THIS MORE BALKANIZATION.
NO I I DO BELIEVE THAT IT IS AN
HONOR MERE CITY I THINK WHAT IT
IS IS IT'S ARE.
YOU HAVE NOW LITTLE TINY POCKETS.
OF BECAUSE I COMPETITION A BIT
EXIST AROUND THE STATE IT BUT
NOT OVER THE ENTIRE STATE.
AND IS WITH THIS WILL DO IS GIVE
A CONSUMERS THE ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY CONTROL THEIR OWN
DESTINY.
AND NOT JUST BE SWEPT INTO ONE
PARTICULAR PROVIDER BECAUSE THEY
WERE SWEPT IN AND THEY HAVE TO
OPT OUT.
WE'RE IS IN EVERY OTHER CONSUMER
PROTECTION THAT IS IT IS
INTRODUCED AROUND HERE IT'S A
IT'S AN OPT IN IT'S AN OPT OUT
FOR THEM --
THIS WILL --
ALLOW US ALL OUR CUSTOMERS TO
HAVE TO HAVE THAT OPTION NOT
JUST THOSE ONES IN THE POCKETS
IS ACTUALLY.
A OPENS IT UP AND DOESN'T --
FOR FURTHER BALKANIZED SYSTEMS.
I MADE IT I I CAN'T HELP BUT
HEAR YOU SAYING THAT.
A SOLUTION.
TO LITTLE COUNTRIES BREAKING UP
IS [inaudible]
TO LET.
SMALLER AND SMALLER GROUPS OF OF
OF IF PRINT PEOPLE BREAK OFF.
TO TO PURSUE THEIR OWN ENERGY
FREEDOM HERE.
THE IDEA.
THAT I I THINK I I CAN'T ANSWER
THE QUESTION YOU MORE CLEARLY
THAN I ALREADY DID [inaudible]
TECH.
WELL SENATOR WE AGAIN.
ASSERTING.
THANK YOU --
I I I TOLD THE GROUP THE CENTER
THAT THAT THE WORLD IS --
I THINK YOU'RE VERY DIFFERENT
THAN IT WAS.
DURING THE ENERGY CRISIS WE'VE --
WE'VE MOVED TOWARD CCA'S WE'VE
MOVED MOVED TOWARD CLEANER
ENERGY SOLAR AND WE JUST HAD A
HUGE PRESENTATION ARE ON ENERGY
STORAGE MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION.
SO OBVIOUSLY THERE IS --
READY PEOPLE MOVING DIRECTLY
INTO DIFFERENT.
CHOICES HARM NOW GOING BACK TO
AYE THICKNESS IN THE FRAGMENTS
QUESTION.
WHY NOT STILL MAINTAIN A CAP?
WHY COMPLETELY REMOVED THE CAP
THAT CAPS SEEMS TO BE?
A A SAFEGUARD IN CASE THINGS
SORT OF GET.
OUT OF CONTROL UPON.
BECAUSE IT DOES APPEAR THAT --
GIVEN THE YOUR THE THE TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCE WE WENT THROUGH.
THAT MUCH OF THE STEPS OF HOME
MOVING FORWARD YOU KNOW AND WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT SOLAR.
THERE CERTAIN CERTAIN STOP GAPS
AND NET METERING STOP HAVE TECH
SALUTING SCOTT WHICH A BBQ.
THEN THAT ONE OF ARGUMENT WOULD
WOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH HAVING
A CAP ON CCA'S I MEAN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MOVING LOAD FROM.
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO
OTHERS SO IF YOU'RE CONCERNED.
WITH NEEDING A CAP DIDN'T WE
SHOULD BE KAPLAN CCA'S.
BECAUSE IT REALLY DOESN'T MATTER
IF THEY'RE LEAVING TO GO TO ANY
S. P. OR THEY'RE LEAVING TO GO.
UP TO SEE CA OR THEY'RE LEAVING
THE GRID BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST
BECOMING SELF SUFFICIENT WHICH A
LOT OF OTHER BUSINESSES ARE
TODAY PEOPLE RE GOING BROWN OFF
THE GROUND OFF THE GRID.
SO -- I HAVE
NOT HEARD ANY.
OF CONCERNS FROM FROM FOLKS IN
IN THIS COMMITTEE THAT SOMEHOW
WE SHOULD BE.
YOU KNOW CAPPING HER TO BE
PROPOSING LEGISLATION OR
AMENDMENTS TO CAP CCA'S.
SO I JUST DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S CONSISTENT AND AND YOU
KNOW WE SHOULD.
WE SHOULD OPEN UP AND THAT WE
LOOK P. JUDY'S RD LOST 80% OF
THEIR LOW TO SEE CA SO --
IF IF IF WE'RE GONNA SEE A
CLAMMY WITHIN PGE SERVICE
TERRITORY I THINK PEOPLE WOULD
HAVE SEEN I THINK WE'VE.
CROSSED THAT.
TIPPING POINT ALREADY AND WE
HAVE IT.
BUT BUT BUT I GET TO SEE IF
YEARS I MEAN YOU HAVE.
TO THERE'S A FAIRLY.
LENGTHY PROCESS TO HOP DE UNDER.
TEAR.
YOU NOT YOU KNOW QUITE THE
OPPOSITE THERE'S MORE LIKE THE
PROCESS FOR DIRECT ACCESS
KESSLER'S UNDER CCA'S DEFORMITY
CA THEY SWEEP ALL THE CUSTOMERS.
THEN YOU'RE STILL GETTING A BILL
FROM ITS A PGD YOU'VE GOTTA
FIGURE OUT THAT NOW YOU'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING POWER FROM.
MARIN CLEAN POWER AND THAT YOU
AS A CUSTOMER HAVE TO BE SAVVY
ENOUGH TO OPT OUT.
UNDER DIRECT ACCESS AND ESP HAS
TO GO IN INDIVIDUALLY SIGNED A
CONTRACT WITH EACH PERSON SO
THEY HAVE TO GO.
NEGOTIATED AND SIGNED A CONTRACT
WITH OR LABORIOUS TIME INTENSIVE --
THEN CCA'S I'LL USE CAN COMPETE
AGAINST YES PLEASE THEY CAN
MARKET AND SAY DON'T DON'T SIGN
WITH.
DUKE POWER STAY WITH US BECAUSE
WE'RE GONNA DO X. Y. Z. FOR YOU
THEY CAN'T DO THAT WITH CCA'S
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE HAS TIED
THEIR HARMS BEHIND THEIR BACK.
AND SAID I OWE YOU YOU CANNOT
MARKET AGAINST CCA'S.
DOCTOR I'M SORRY.
BUT I CONTINUE MISTER BALES OF
SOME OF OUR YEAH I MANDATE
THERE'S NOT MUCH MORE TO ADD
THAT OTHER THAN [inaudible]
EVERY TIME.
A BUSINESS GO TO DIRECT ACCESS
IT'S A ONE ON ONE TRANSACTION.
THEY HAVE TO GO AND ACTUALLY
SIGNED UP AND THEN THEY HAVE TO
BEAR PAY THE PCI A WHICH IS
LITERALLY PAIN THEM BACK FOR THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THEY'VE MADE.
SAYS MAKE SURE THERE'S NO
STRANDED ASSETS ON TOP OF THAT
IF YOU TO BE MAKES TO NEEDS TO
MAKE AN INVESTMENT.
THEY GO TO THE ENTIRE RATE PAYER
NOT JUST OF ERRORS FOR THEY GO
ESP CUSTOMERS IT'S CALLED CAMP.
AND THEY CHARGE THE CUSTOMER OF
THE S. P. COSTS FOR THINGS THAT
BENEFIT THE SYSTEM GENERALLY
THIS IDEA THAT YOU'RE SOMEHOW
LEAVING THE SYSTEM THERE'S NO
ONE TO PAY FOR IT.
THAT IS FACTUALLY ISN'T.
IT BUT JUST UP ABOVE I GUESS THE
QUESTION FOR BOND ARM MISTER
TINGS POINT OUR EXIT SO WE KNOW
THAT CCA'S ARE.
HAVE CREATED HAVE CREATED ISSUES.
AND YOUR RESPONSE WAS THAT WE
WERE JUST GONNA GIVE LIKE
CONSUMERS MORE CHOICE BUT WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE EVERYDAY
CONSUMER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
LARGE.
PROCESSING UNIVERSITY SO AGAIN
THE RATE PAYER.
IF THIS ALL GOES BAD IS THE ONE
WHO'S STILL ON THE HOOK IN IS
GOING TO SEE THEIR COSTS GO UP
[inaudible]
CORRECT.
WELL BUT THE PUT FOR THIS TO
WORK THE THEY HAVE TO HAVE GOOD
WITH THE BILL THAT WE HAVE I'VE
RESOURCE ADEQUACY.
AND LOOKING AT A LARGER DYNAMIC
THAT WHAT HAPPENS IS WHAT IS THE
BUT WHAT WHAT HAPPENED LAST TIME
AS TO WHY WHEN THE THING FELL
APART LET'S IS THE LET'S JUST
ASSUME.
THAT YOU'RE RIGHT AND THE WORLD
GOES WIGGY BITE WE WE WE CAN ON
RESOURCE ADEQUACY WE LITERALLY
ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH.
PILING PLANS CREATING RESERVES
TO CREATE THE BUFFERS SO THAT IF
THAT STARTS TO HAPPEN.
RIGHT WHAT WE'VE WRITTEN IN THE
LAW IS THAT YOU'RE GONNA NO WAY
IN ADVANCE PEOPLE HAVE
TEMPERATURE THEY HAVE TO HAVE
THE MONEY THEY JUST CAN'T CUT
OUT AND DROP PEOPLE NUMBER.
ONE NUMBER TWO ON THE WHOLE COST
SHIFTING THING THAT ALSO CREATES.
A WHOLE DIFFERENT SET OF FACTORS
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE LAW THEY'RE
NOT ONLY IF YOU DECIDE TO LEAVE
THIS I DON'T WANT TO COME BACK
YOU JUST CAN'T SAY.
OH BY THE WAY I CHANGE MY MIND.
GO AND DO THIS YOU'VE GOTTA PAY
THE RATES W. TO PAY FOR THAT
PENTECOST YOU HAVE TO PAY HIGHER
RATES FOR A TIME TO RECAPTURE TO
GET BACK ON YOU IF YOU ALL KINDS
OF STUFF SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IN
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES.
THROUGH THE EXPENSE IS BUILT IN
THIS REDUNDANCY TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF THERE'S A FAILURE. TO A
SYSTEM BECAUSE SOMEBODY WENT OFF
THE SYSTEM BUT THERE'S BOTH TIME
AND MONEY TO BE ABLE TO GET BACK
AND SO IF YOU WANT YOU GOT TO
HAVE A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT COST
SAVINGS. TO BE ABLE TO TAKE THAT
ADDITIONAL --
COST RICK.
HOW WOULD YOU FINISH?
YEAH IT WOULD GIVE TO YOU THIS
CAR SCHERING'S YOU'VE IT
RECRUITS SEARCH RECOVERY
PROBABLY DE ON THE OTHER SET AND
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE TRADE.
AND SO WE HAVE PUT BELTS AND THE
SPENDERS ON TOP A BELT AND
SUSPENDERS ON THIS THING SO LOOK.
I LIVE FOR THAT BUT WHICH WAS
EQUIVALENT.
WE WENT.
TO YEAH IT CAN WHETHER MIT
URGENCY WIFE Y. GOT MEN SO FAST
RIGHT NOW WHEN I MEAN.
CLEARS LA QUESTIONS IN A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY OPEN BUT WHAT ITS
THIRD JUNE TWENTY SIX GOOD
STRAWBERRY MOON.
SOON EGGMAN POP UP ON YOUR
AVERAGE OF IT HAS.
WE HAVE A CAP THOSE FOR THOSE
CUSTOMERS CONTINUE TO BE SERVED
THERE HASN'T.
WE HAVE TWENTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IT JUST HASN'T BEEN
BORNE OUT. TO YOUR ARGUE FOR
SEIZE IT.
I'M TALKING ABOUT DIRECT ACCESS
CUSTOMERS.
CHAIRMAN I MIGHT ONE ONE ONE ONE
MOMENT OKAY YEAH.
IF I COULD IF I COULD JUST HAVE
YOU PAUSE FOR JUST A MOMENT I
WANNA.
WE'RE FRIEDMAN YOU'RE STANDING
THERE THAT YOU WANTED TO MAKE A
COMMENT TO ANYTHING THAT YOU'VE
HEARD HERE IF I MAY MISTER
CHAIRMAN [inaudible]
I I WOULD TAKE ISSUE WITH THE
STATEMENT THAT ALL OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED
HAVE BEEN RESOLVED ALREADY.
THAT ALL THE POLICIES HAVE BEEN
NAILED DOWN IN THE COST SHIFTING
PROTECTIONS HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
AND ELIMINATED.
I JUST SPENT WEEKS AND WEEKS
BRIEFING ARE A CASE OF THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION OVER
THE POWER COST INDIFFERENCE
ADJUSTMENT WHICH IS IN FACT THE
EXIT FEE THAT'S SUPPOSED TO
COLLECT STRANDED COSTS.
AND THERE IS Y. DISAGREEMENT
THAT THE CHARGE SIMPLY DOESN'T
WORK AS CURRENTLY CONSTRUCTED.
AND AND THERE'S WIDE
DISAGREEMENT AS TO HOW IT SHOULD
BE REFORMED.
THE P. YOU SEE HASN'T RESOLVED
THIS PROBLEM.
THE PC ITSELF HAS IDENTIFIED
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT MARKET
FRAGMENTATION AT THE RETAIL
LEVEL AND HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE ANY CONTROL OVER PLANNING
FOR THE FUTURE.
AND THEY'VE SOUNDED THE ALARM
BELLS THAT WE ARE RUNNING INTO A
SITUATION.
WHERE THERE MAY BE A SHORTAGE OF
CAPACITY WERE RESOURCE ADEQUACY
NEEDS ARE NOT BEING THAT?
AND WHERE THERE'S NO ONE TO
DIRECT TO COMPLY WITH THE
STATE'S REQUIREMENTS AND WE LOOK
AT THE EAST EASTERN MARKETS
WHERE WE TELL CHOICE IS RUN
RAMPANT.
ON STATE COMMISSIONS HAVE VERY
LITTLE OVERSIGHT AND THEY WERE
VERY BIG CHALLENGES TO THE
MEETING A LOT OF THEIR RESOURCE
GOALS AND WE HAVE SOME.
BIGGER GOALS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WERE TRYING TO MEET.
ON MUCH OF THIS STUFF SIMPLY
HASN'T BEEN RESOLVED AND YES YES
PIECE HAVE NOT DUMP THEIR
CUSTOMERS BACK TO THE UTILITIES
BECAUSE THERE HAS BEEN NO BIG
PROBLEM IN WHOLESALE MARKETS.
THE NEXT TIME THAT PROBLEM
ARRIVES ALL BETS ARE OFF.
AND IF AN E. S. P. GOES BANKRUPT
AND ITS CUSTOMERS ARE PUT BACK
TO THE UTILITY THERE'S NO ONE TO
GO AFTER FOR THE MONEY.
WE JUST DON'T THINK THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE. TO AUTHORIZE
UNLIMITED RETAIL CHOICE AT THIS
POINT IN TIME.
WITH SO MANY UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS BOTH HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE REGULATORY
AGENCIES OKAY MAG HAPPEN TO
CLOSE.
I WILL I'LL ANSWER THAT MY
CLOTHES WHAT IF WHAT BOOK A
QUESTION TO THE SENATOR SODA SO
MISTER FRIEDMAN MENTION AGAINST
THE LAST BILL YOU HAD.
HAD MORE IT ALFA RENEWABLE
COMPONENT WAS THERE A REASON WHY
YOU DIDN'T.
ON YOUR MARKET CERTAIN PORTION
FOR RENEWABLES A LOT WE DID WITH
FOLLOWING THE LAW RIGHT NOW IT'S
50% AND I SPACES BACK THAT S. B.
ONE HUNDRED WILL PASS AND GET
2100%.
SO WE DID NEED TO HANDLE IT
SEPARATELY IT'S GOING TO BE
HANDLED IN THE SHIFT TO POLICY
QUITE SO WE THINK THINK ON IT I
CAN CLOTHES.
YOUR INCIDENT OF HIS QUESTIONS I
GUESS WHAT I COULD ANSWER THE
TWO QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED
IF YOU JUST HOPE REPORT
MOMENTOUS.
MAKE SURE THAT WE SCALE YOU HAVE.
YOU JUST VERY BRIEFLY --
YOU KNOW I I THINK WHAT.
WE'RE SEEING IN THIS DISCUSSION
IS ONE OF THE PROBLEMS IS THAT
YOU KNOW THERE THERE IS A LOT OF
CONSISTENCY TO OUR OVERALL
ENERGY PLAN IT SEEMS LIKE YOU
KNOW ME ON THE ONE HAND WE WANT
TO HAVE MORE MORE PEOPLE WOULD.
COME TO GET OFF THE GRID SO TO
SPEAK -- BUT
ON THE OTHER HAND WE'RE SAYING
NO WHAT WE NEED PEOPLE ON THE
GROUP WE NEED AND IN FACT WE
NEED REGIONALIZATION RAY AND WE
NEED OTHER POWER SOURCES FROM
OTHER.
YOU KNOW OTHER WESTERN STATES
YOU KNOW I'M [inaudible]
AND AND IT WILL YOU KNOW ONE
THING ON THIS I MEAN CERTAINLY A
LOT OF BUSINESSES THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT --
THAT EMPLOY.
PEOPLE IN OUR DISTRICTS WANNA
TAKE ADVANTAGE THIS IS NO WONDER.
THE OTHER COSTS ARE 89% HIGHER.
THAN ANY OTHER STATE YOU KNOW
WHEN THEY'RE DOING COMMERCIAL
INDUSTRIAL PRICING SO OF COURSE
THEY WANNA.
BE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS AND THAT REALLY ALL GOES
BACK -- TO
OUR PS RIGHT IS WHAT IS REALLY
DRIVEN UP THE COST YOU KNOW FOR
A LOT OF THESE --
BUSINESSES AND SO BUT WITH THE
SAME TIME WE ALSO.
MAYBE WE DON'T REALIZATION WHERE
WE TAKE NON RENEWABLE RESOURCES --
TO POWER. TO PROVIDE THAT THAT
POWER RIGHT SO I MEAN THERE'S
JUST.
IT IN ON THE SAME TIME WE TALK
ABOUT CCA'S WE TALK ABOUT MICRO
GRIDS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I GUESS ONE OF THE
THINGS IS THAT WE NEED TO GET
OUT I'D I AM GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE I THINK.
WE DO NEED TO PROVIDE THIS AND
AND AND AND GIVE PEOPLE THE
ABILITY BECAUSE THIS ISN'T THE
STRAW THAT BREAKING THE CAMEL'S
BACK RIGHT I MEAN THAT THERE'S
SO MANY OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
CAUSING.
THE COST OF ELECTRICITY IN AND
RISE THAT WE NEED TO DEAL WITH.
AND THIS IS REALLY A VERY SMALL
THING.
AND THEN A VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY EVEN.
FLAT AS AS IN TERMS OF OVERALL
CUSTOMERS THAT ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS PARTICULAR
DIRECT ACCESS RIGHT --
SO.
DEFTLY ON LONG TERM WE NEED TO
HAVE A BETTER MORE CONSISTENT
PLAN OF HOW WE GONNA MAKE THIS
ALL WORK --
WE ALL WANT DIFFERENT THINGS IN
ALL OF US ARE HAPPY ABOUT
CERTAIN ASPECTS AND NOT OTHERS.
BUT THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A
COHESIVE PLAN I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE.
TO THAT HOPEFULLY WE'RE GOING TO
WORK ON BECAUSE YOU KNOW THERE
HAS TO BE A LONG TERM MORE
CONCLUSIVE CONSISTENT.
PLAN FOR OUR ENERGY NEEDS.
IN THE FUTURE.
THAT I DON'T THINK ANYONE
DISAGREES WITH THAT AND SENATOR
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION
TODAY I WON'T REPEAT THE THE THE
THE THE CONCERNS THAT I HAVE
ABOUT THE BILL THERE'S NO
RECOMMENDATION I AM VOTING NO
BUT PLEASE THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE.
I HAVE BY.
TESTIFIED BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
OR THE ENERGY COMMITTEE AND BEEN
INVOLVED IN A I KNOW HOW MANY
ENERGY RELATED ISSUES OVER THE
YEARS.
AND THIS IS THE FIRST TIME.
THAT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION DID NOT SHOW UP.
SUPPORT OPPOSE WORD VICE.
SO WHEN THE ARGUMENTS MADE AGAIN
[inaudible]
SCOTT. TO POST A BOND.
AND IF THERE IS A PROBLEM UNLIKE
WHAT WE HAD BEFORE THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT EARLY WARNING
SYSTEMS IN PLACE.
SO WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO DO. ONE
OF THE REASONS I DECIDED TO COME
BACK TO GOVERNMENT AFTER WORKING
IN RENEWABLE ENERGY FOR TWELVE
YEARS AFTER LEAVING GOVERNMENT.
WAS TO MOVE AWAY FROM.
THE BROAD DISCUSSIONS OF LET'S
HAVE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARDS ARE LET'S GO GREEN AND
HAVE A LOT OF PRESS CONFERENCES
AND TO GET INTO THE NITTY GRITTY
OF HOW DO WE DO IT. TO ASK THE
HARD QUESTIONS AT EVERY LEVEL TO
MAKE SURE THE PROCESS AND NOT TO
BE INTIMIDATED BY WHAT HAPPENED
BEFORE TO LEARN FROM WHAT WE
LEARNED BEFORE AND THEY GET IT
RIGHT.
HOW WE GONNA GET IT RIGHT NO ONE
CAN GUARANTEE HAVE BEEN TO A FEW
PERFECT STORMS IN MY LIFE?
BUT I THINK WHAT WE'VE DONE IS
IN THE BALANCE OF THINGS
PARTICULAR ENERGY COSTS ARE SO
HIGH WERE OPPORTUNITIES ARE SO
GREAT.
WHERE COMPANIES ARE SO
SOPHISTICATED WERE OF THE
FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES I
THINK FOUR HUNDRED NINETY TWO
HALVES CHIEF SUSTAINABILITY
OFFICERS WHERE THE ENTIRE
CORPORATE STRUCTURE OF BIG COSTA
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGED?
AND WE HAVE WON THE WAR.
WE HAVE WON THE WAR.
IN TERMS OF THE GENERAL THINKING
ABOUT HOW PEOPLE LOOK AT
SUSTAINABILITY ABOUT HOW THEY BY
POWER AND ABOUT HOW THEY DO DO
THIS KIND OF THING.
THAT DIDN'T EXIST BEFORE IT WAS
THE WILD WEST THERE WERE A FEW
COMPANIES WHO ARE BOTTOM FEEDERS
WHO CAME IN AND PROMISE THE MOON
I WATCHED IT HAPPEN IN LOS
ANGELES IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS.
SAYING WE'RE GONNA MAKE ALL THIS
STUFF HAPPENED PEOPLE BIT.
WE NOW HAVE TWENTY YEARS
EXPERIENCE TWENTY YEARS
EXPERIENCE IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
DO WITH THIS AT A VERY
SOPHISTICATED LEVEL.
CCA'S ARE IMPORTANT ARM FORUM I
SUPPORTED HIM A VOTER FOR EVERY
BILL EVER SEEN ON THEM.
THE QUESTION IS CAN WE EXTEND
THIS TO OTHER FOLKS THAT IN A
FAIR MANNER AND THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT NEXT YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
WILL BE IN BUSINESS.
NEXT YEAR IF THERE'S A PROBLEM
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO FIX IT.
AND AND ARMED THE THAT WE'VE
BUILT ENOUGH EARLY WARNING
SYSTEMS INTO THE PROCESS THAT
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE STUCK.
WITH THE SITUATION WHERE ALL OF
A SUDDEN THE SKY'S FALLING OH MY
GOD WHAT WE DO.
THE BIGGEST ISSUE I THINK WE
FACE WITH THESE UTILITIES IS THE
FIRES WILL I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
ACT TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM BUT I
THINK I AGAIN.
LOOK AT THAT IN THE CONTEXT THE
ENERGY CRISIS WHICH WAS REALLY A
FINANCIAL CRISIS I DON'T THINK
THAT'LL HAPPEN HERE I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR THIS IS A THE
MOTION IS DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ROLL CALL PLEASE
HOLDEN A NO HOLDEN KNOW.
PATTERSON PATTERSON AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN I'D CHEN AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
AND ONE OTHER SEE AYE MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI.
MERGING ON VOTING QUIRK NOW.
QUIRK NO [inaudible]
REYES.
REYES NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
THINK OF IT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN YOUR BILL LINK OUT TO
BE SO COURTEOUS I APPRECIATE IT
I KNOW WHAT YOU VOTE BUT I
REALLY.
THINK THAT --
CENTER HERE.
YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL.
THE BILL.
REMOVES THE BELL SECOND.
THOUGH IT MIGHT.
AND NOT THAT WE'RE ALL IN.
JUST ONE ENERGY SAY A SET OF
PRODUCTS FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF
WHO'S MY WITNESS HERE BUT SHE
WORKS IN A DIFFERENT CAPACITY.
VERY BRILLIANT ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROGRAMS YOU TALK.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS IRONY MORE
REPRESENTING THE AREA ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL THE SPONSORS THE BILL BE
VERY QUICK --
ABOUT 60% OF THE POTENTIAL
ENERGY EFFICIENCY SAVINGS.
I BET IS AT ITS POTENTIAL --
IS PRETTY MUCH LOCKED IN A BLACK
BOX OF THE P. YOU SEE FOR LACK
OF A PROCESS WHICH IS ACCESSIBLE
WHICH IS TRANSPARENT.
WHICH HAS CERTAIN TIMELINES AND
THIS BILL SEEKS TO REMEDY THAT
FIGURE.
THANK YOU ARE ARE THERE ANY
OTHER.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR.
SYLVIA'S ONLY SHAUN BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible] FOR OKAY.
IN FAVOR LET ME JUST SAY THIS
ONE THING AWAY DOLLARS TIME TO
TO USE OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
THE PRODUCERS IN SUPPORT.
WE'LL GIVE YOU ANOTHER FIVE
SECONDS IF YOU LIKE.
ANYONE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY BACK TO THE MEMBERS OF SIR
ARE ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS
HEARING NONE THE MOTION IS DO
PASS -- TWO
APPROPRIATIONS ROLL CALL PLEASE
[inaudible]
AS AMENDED [inaudible]
YES.
HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE BURKE.
BIRTH I CHEN.
CHEN AYE CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
BUT EGGMAN AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA MAYES.
MAYES AYE MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I WORK.
QUIRK AYE REYES.
REYES AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
S. MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE SAID
IT OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE OF YOU
KNOW YOU DIDN'T JUST A MADHOUSE
[inaudible]
OKAY WILL.
THAT BILL IS OUT CONGRADULATIONS.
IT WAS KIND OF A START AT THE
TOP OF THE FILE WILL MAKE OUR
WAY THROUGH THIS WILL BE THE ONE
AND ONLY TIME THAT WE WILL.
THAT WE WILL TAKE VOTES ON
MATTERS THAT MEMBERS A TO ADD
ONTO SO START AT THE TOP OF THE
FILE [inaudible]
MADAM CLERK [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
GROWING THEM [inaudible]
AROUND.
SB SEVEN EIGHTY TWO WITH GERMANY
AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
SHOULD [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
S. B. [inaudible]
TEN NINETY GALLAGHER --
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
DOROTHEA.
S. B. [inaudible]
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE PATTERSON
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
S. B. [inaudible]
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER NONVOTING [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
S. B. [inaudible]
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN EDUARDO
GARCIA.
S. B. [inaudible]
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN EDUARDO
GARCIA [inaudible]
IF I SP FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
EDUARDO GARCIA I THE CONSENT
CALENDAR [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
BURKE I EGGMAN.
CORRECTION EGGMAN VOTED AYE
EARLIER GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I IT WATER GARCIA.
IN ORDER SEE I
AS THE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN GALLAGHER CHANGING
HIS VOTE FOR NOT VOTING TO KNOW
[inaudible]
THANKS.
STARTING FROM THE TOP SB
[inaudible]
SIXTY FOUR EDUARDO GARCIA.
THE WATER SEE I S. B. SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO EDUARDO GARCIA.
AND WATER SEE I S. B. TEN NINETY
EDUARDO GARCIA.
IT WATER SEE I S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY ONE EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I S. B..
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I S. B..
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I S. B.
[inaudible]
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN EDUARDO
GARCIA.
IT WATER SEE I WE'VE CONCLUDED
OUR BUSINESS FOR TODAY WE ARE
ADJOURNED